Herzlich willkommen, sollen wir ganz förmlich sein. Herzlich willkommen zu Mobile Macs.
Beim nächsten Ton drücken Sie die Pause-Taste.
Genau.
Beim nächsten Ton ist es immer noch der 4. Dezember 2008. Wir haben uns mal wieder zusammengefunden, nachdem wir eigentlich unseren zwei Wochen-Slot verpasst haben, weil Max war im Urlaub, wie war es?
War schon sehr, sehr erholsam.
Aber du hast viel getwittert.
Wo warst du?
Ich hatte den Eindruck, du warst nicht wirklich so voll im Entspannungsmodus, sondern immer nur so, wo kriege ich WLAN?
Wo gibt es Netz?
Es war nicht so schlimm, wie ich es getan habe. Ich war auf La Palma, das ist kanadische Inseln.
Ach, da unten, der Lanzarote, Fuerteventura.
Genau, da warst du auch schon mal? Okay, ich war noch nie vorher da. Und La Palma ist eigentlich im Wesentlichen ein riesengroßer Vulkan, 2.500 Meter hoch, 25 Kilometer breit und das war's.
Ich hab das auch mal gemacht, so Winterurlaub, mal so eben schnell runter jetten, abschalten und so.
Das war echt großartig.
Ja komm, war ich da, war irgendwie scheiße Wetter und dann gab es irgendwie Sturm und dann guckte ich morgens aus dem Hotelfenster heraus und dann lagen so Boote in den Straßen und zwar so richtig. Der totale Terror. Hat sich auch nicht so richtig erholt.
So ein Urlaub finde ich gut. Es ist nicht langweiliger als nix los, die Sonne scheint und so ein bisschen Wetter ist schon auch so Natur-Action, finde ich gut.
Ich hab was zu erzählen gehabt, aber ich war auch gar nicht so richtig im Entspannungs-Modus, muss ich zugeben.
Ich hätt's ja lustig gefunden, wenn das seit drei Jahren irgendwie ein Vulkanausbruch überfällig, wenn der genau zu der Zeit gekommen wäre, wo wir da gewesen wären, dann hätt ich was zu erzählen gehabt. Dann hätt ich auch schicke Fotos gehabt. Aber so nur Fotos von Max am Strand und von Max in den Bergen.
Wie auch immer, jetzt sind wir vereint und sind natürlich total aus dem News-Flow raus, wie wir gerade auch wieder festgestellt haben. Mal schauen. Aber wir können ja auch mal so ein bisschen zwischen den RSS-Zeilen berichten und erzählen. Das ist ja auch mal ganz schön, ich muss auch sagen, News ist auch mal ganz schön ermüdend auf Dauer. Also dieses permanente Einschlagen von Gerüchten und Dementierungen und so weiter, das ist ja manchmal ganz lustig, aber da auch mal mit ein bisschen Verzögerungen drauf zu blicken ist auch so qualitativ.
Ich finde es ganz gut, wenn man mal eine Woche schafft, kein Netz zu haben, was ja schon ganz schön schwer ist. Gerade auch mit dem iPhone geht das ja eigentlich gar nicht mehr. Aber wenn du dann nach einer Woche wieder kommst, du kriegst immer nur noch das Endergebnis einer News und nicht irgendwie die tausenden Zwischenupdates und was dann noch alles nachgeforscht wird, sondern du kriegst nur noch das, was am Ende wirklich die Essenz an sich hat.
Aber die Perlen, die Perlen, die verpasst man dann häufig auch.
Aber die werdet ihr mir hoffentlich gleich... Ich bin zurückgekommen um Sonnabend und hab keine Perlen getaucht. Und hab Read All geklickt im RSS Reader im Wesentlichen. Wirklich? Nee, aber ich bin sehr, sehr flüchtig drüber gegangen.
Okay, du hast einfach auf Space gedrückt und versucht, während bei...
Und was mir ins Auge gesprungen ist...
Oh, Nacktbilder!
Kurz mal beim Porn gestoppt. Ja, verständlich, verständlich, verständlich.
Und insofern müsst ihr mich... Ich bin noch ahnungsloser als sonst.
Noch ahnungsloser als sonst. Naja, das sind ja Ausblicke. Gut.
Das wäre ein prima Titel gewesen. Aber wir haben ja anscheinend schon einen.
Genau. Aber du hast, bevor wir auf den Titel kommen, du hast gerade erzählt, du warst hier beim Developer Stammtisch, hier in Berlin, dem Cocoa Developer Stammtisch.
Der meint mich?
Ich glaub, der meint Dennis. Du Dennis, auf dem linken Kanal.
Ich bin links, ja. Da war ich ja schon eine Woche oder zwei vorher in der Love for Culture. Wir haben ein bisschen Schleichwerbung, müssen wir ja mal machen. Und da war da kein Schwein, weil irgendwie war da so ein Datumsfuck ab, warum auch immer. Dann war ich dann halt beim zweiten Termin noch mal da. Ich weiß gar nicht, wann war, am 13.11. oder so. Kann das sein?
Hab ich auch so eine Erinnerung.
Und dann war ich da und dann waren auch schon so fünf, sechs Leute so und dieser Markus Kirschner, so hieß er glaube ich, ich will jetzt keine falschen Namen nennen, aber ich glaube so hieß er. Der hat das irgendwie initiiert und der brachte auch noch zwei Kollegen mit, die teilweise iPhone programmieren, teilweise bald wollen. Also ich glaube, am Ende waren es so 15 Leute, vielleicht zwei, drei mehr. Und die meisten davon oder eigentlich alle, weil mir fällt jetzt keine Ausnahmen ein, waren alles iPhone Programmierer. Ach. Also dass einer sagte, er macht jetzt nur so hardcore-mäßig stupide jetzt noch in so einer Bude so Macintosh-Programmierung, da war irgendwie gar keiner, glaube ich. Also ich wüsste jetzt nicht. Und ja, da haben alle so ein bisschen erzählt. Wir haben so eine Vorstellungsrunde gemacht, die eigentlich immer so ein bisschen blöd ist. So jeder stellt sich so ein bisschen vor, aber dann konnte man schon so hören, hier von Nova Media waren halt ein paar da.
Ja.
Denn hier, da wo der Biafra arbeitet, wie heißt der Laden? Ist das Nova Media?
Nein.
Genau, von der Bude waren auch ein paar da, auch drei.
Okay.
Wie heißt die denn?
Ist mir jetzt gerade entfallen, aber ich denke mal drunter.
Na ja, find's mal raus. Und ja, und dann zum Beispiel der Jonas, wie heißt der? Der Fahrplan Jonas. Ich weiß jetzt nicht mehr, wie er heißt. Aber er stellt sich vor, ja ich bin der Jonas und ich mach so ein bisschen Fahrplanprogramm. Ich meine, du bist auch der.
Der, bei dem wir letztes Mal schon ausführlich gesprochen haben.
Genau. Und noch so ein paar andere Leute, hab ich jetzt nicht alle gemerkt. Aber es war eigentlich eine ganz nette Atmosphäre. Ich hab dann auch mit einem so ein Typi auch gleich so ein bisschen, der hat gesagt, hier sag mal benutzt du das und das? Und ich so, ja, was? Das geht und zeig mal und wie machst du das? Bei mir geht das irgendwie nicht. Ich hab mal gleich so ein bisschen rumprobiert und uns gegenseitig Zeug gezeigt. Aber ja, es war mehr so eine Talkrunde, so ein bisschen Quatschen. Es war jetzt noch nicht so wirklich tief technisch, was sie eigentlich auch ganz schick finden, aber es geht halt auch irgendwann nicht. Du kannst dich eh immer nur mit einem so technisch zu zweit vor einem so einen Rechner setzen und tief eintauchen. Aber der nächste ist, und die Pizza da ist total lecker, in der Lwmlaf-Vokatscherie, muss man auch nur sagen. Schmeckt ganz gut.
Ich wäre auch super gerne gekommen, aber ich konnte an dem Tag einfach nicht.
Ja, also der nächste ist nächste Woche. Und zwar, ich habe jetzt meinen mobilen Kalender gerade nicht zur Hand.
So, so.
Aber das stimmt.
Das habe ich mir sogar schon notiert.
Nächsten Donnerstag, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Richtig.
Und 19 Uhr. Aber nicht im gleichen Laden, sondern woanders.
Ach.
Die haben da irgendwie einen Raum in einer Kastanienallee, 22 oder 28 oder so, auf jeden Fall Kastanienallee.
Im Prenzlberg, die?
Und wahrscheinlich in der Schule, die da ist oder so. Da ist ja so ein Restaurant drin, wahrscheinlich da irgendwo, könnte ich mir gut vorstellen.
Das übersteigt jetzt meine geographischen Kenntnisse in der Kastanienallee. Aber wie auch immer. Das wird sicherlich auf der Webseite stehen. Das ist halt dieses Coco-Hats-Meeting, wie sie sich das eigentlich nennen.
Und da müsste man halt auch pünktlich kommen, weil die wollen dann um 19 Uhr dann auch gleich mit einem 1-Stunden-Vortrag irgendwie starten.
Ach, echt?
Und um 20 Uhr wird dann mit Beamer, oder nee Beamer nicht, aber mit Netzwerk und Zeug und um 20 Uhr wird es dann irgendwie so in so einem gemütlicheren Raum dann irgendwie verlagert und dann gibt es wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen was zu essen oder irgendwie so. Und der Raum kostet wohl, damit die Leute nicht gleich so unvorbereitet kommen, das kostet wohl ein bisschen was, 90 Euro. Und die meinen, wenn sich jeder jetzt so ein bisschen beteiligt, wenn da 15 Leute kommen und jeder irgendwie 6, 7, 8 Euro abdrückt, dann, also nicht rentiert, sondern dann bezahlt sich das auch. Da müssen halt mal ein paar kommen. Aber es war eigentlich ganz nett so, allein schon so zu sehen, was die Leute so machen und was sie so für Ideen haben. Und ich hab jetzt Mailing-Listen, da hab ich schon mal geguckt, da war da irgendwie noch nicht so wirklich viel. Ich hoffe, dass sich da vielleicht noch ein bisschen schicker was entwickelt, dass man auch mal eine technische Frage stellen kann, die man dann mal so in Ruhe beantworten kann oder auch in Ruhe stellen kann, weil so dann vor Ort geht's dann doch nicht ganz so gut. Muss man mal gucken.
Da muss ich ja auch erstmal ein bisschen abklopfen und so. Aber trotzdem ganz gut, dass es immer wieder so steht.
Aber ich fand es ganz nett da. Also es war nicht schlecht.
Fand fein. Ja, ich hab heute meinen Tag mit ein bisschen Shopping verbracht. Ich war heute mal wieder im Gravis, mal nach langer Zeit.
Am Reuterplatz.
Hatte da mal eine Reparatur einzureichen. War auch mal eine ganz interessante Experience. Mal so zu gucken. Gerade jetzt im Hinblick darauf, dass ja Apple jetzt einen Apple Store eröffnen wird diese Woche in München.
Diesen Samstag.
Und die haben ja da ja auch so einige Konzepte.
Aber in Berlin kommt doch bestimmt auch eine, oder? Das können die noch nicht weglassen. Weil es gibt da bestimmt auch ein Gravis in München, oder nicht?
Naja, sicher.
Das heißt, die haben hier keinen Laden gemacht, weil es hier Gravis gibt. Ich glaube, das würde auch Apple scheiß interessieren. Also das heißt, hier in Berlin muss irgendwie ein Laden kommen. Das ist die Hauptstadt hier.
Ich glaube, Apple geht da so ein bisschen nach Kaufkraft. Und ich glaube, in München wird noch ein bisschen mehr Geld ausgegeben als in Berlin.
Aber hier ist es halt größer.
Ja, es ist eine stinkarme Stadt.
Quatsch. Da sitzt doch Apple Deutschland auf.
Das ist die Erbsenstadt Deutschlands Weltfreude.
Ja, mag ja sein. Aber vielleicht ist die Pyramide hier ein bisschen krass. Aber natürlich haben wir ja auch Leute, die fett Geld haben.
Das ist richtig. Und ich denke auch mal, dass sie das machen. Was weiß ich, warum sie jetzt München ausgewählt haben? Ich weiß es nicht.
Weil sie da unten ihren Hauptsitz haben.
Ja, das ist sicherlich nicht der Grund. Ich meine, Apple, hat man ja gesehen, geht extrem danach, dass sie erst mal überall dort Stores aufmachen, wo sie das Einzugsgebiet...
Wo sie es rentiert natürlich, klar.
Wo sie es rentiert und so weiter. Sie werden da sicherlich ihre Erkenntnisse haben. Da stecken wir auch nicht drin. Da können wir jetzt nur Mutmaßen. Naja, auf jeden Fall.
Also ich Mutmaße mal.
Immer wieder ganz interessant zu sehen, wie sich ja selber Graves auch bemüht. Ich meine, dass Apple Stores kommen, dürften die schon seit Langem wissen oder mindestens geahnt haben. Ich habe mal so hintenrum gehört, dass zum Beispiel Graves in Berlin als Apple Lizenzpartner nicht am... Also ich weiß nicht, ob das stimmt. Das ist mir gesagt worden. Und soweit ich mich erinnern kann, mehr als einmal. Dass die, selbst wenn sie wollten, am Kudam keine Filiale eröffnen dürften. Wenn Apple sagt, dürfte er nicht. Da kriegt er dann keine Macs mehr.
Hä? Apple ist evil, wenn es stimmen sollte. Glaub ich aber nicht sollte. Wobei man kann dann natürlich hinter der Hand immer ein bisschen Druck ausüben. Was ich noch in letzter Zeit immer höre, ist, dass wenn Leute bei Apple anrufen und fragen, ich hab hier so einen Garantiefall, was mach ich denn da und so, dann kommt nicht die Antwort, ja, ist ganz easy, gehen sie mal zu Graves. Dann kommt immer, Graves ist ein bisschen voll, da dauert es ziemlich lange, gehen sie mal, da gibt es so einen anderen Schickenland, das heißt Omni Store oder irgendwie sowas, ich weiß nicht.
Geht das jetzt von Reparaturen?
Ja, und die schicken dann halt das zu diesen, ich weiß ja, ob er wirklich Omni Store ist, aber irgendwie was mit O, glaube ich, und das ist so eine kleinere Bude, und die schicken die Leute mal dahin. Da geht es schneller, sagen sie am Telefon.
Omni Store?
Ja, so für Apple Care-Fälle und all sowas. Ich weiß nicht, vielleicht...
Also ich hatte ja noch nicht einen Garantiefall.
Omni, was weiß ich nicht.
Es gibt so ein paar Vertragspartner, die halt die Reparatur machen.
Genau, und da bin ich ganz entsetzt gewesen, dass die nicht mehr abgeholt werden.
Ja stimmt, das haben sie früher gemacht, das machen sie jetzt nicht mehr. Vielleicht liegt es daran, dass sie jetzt mehr Reparaturbuden vor Ort haben. Also sonst wurden die Dinger halt zentral eingesammelt und jetzt verkaufen sie halt auch mehr Geräte und müssen sehr viel mehr einfach dezentral machen. Die ganzen Teuer, die ganzen...
Kleinen Buden kriegen so ein bisschen Geld dafür, halt, dass sie dieses so abwickeln, dieses Zeug.
Na, das würde man ja wohl hoffen, dass man für die Arbeit macht.
Ich hab ja mal bei Pixel Park gearbeitet und hab da auch Macintosh-Administration gemacht und da haben wir unsere eigenen Macs irgendwie reparieren dürfen, weil die hatten da so einen Vertragspartner-Ding, wie auch immer, die das gekriegt haben. Und dann durfte ich irgendwie, weil mein Chef hatte diese Lizenz-Zertifikat, wie auch immer. Und dann hab ich halt da Macs repariert, zum Beispiel diese 5400er Laptops, da gab's ja mal so eine Austauschgeschichte, kannste dich erinnern? Egal.
Als das Pixel Park noch gut ging.
Und wieder zusammengebaut und dann online geklickt, dass ich das gemacht hab. Und dann für jede Reparatur, die ich gemacht hab, gab's dann von Apple ein bisschen Geld, weil eigentlich hätten die das ja machen müssen. Und so haben die die Teile zu uns geschickt, ich hab die eingebaut und fertig. Ja, lang ist's her.
Jetzt ist gerade unser Internet weggebrochen.
Ja, wirklich unser Internet.
Das ist eine Scheiße hier mit dem... Das wollten wir eigentlich gar nicht hier groß über...
Ich wollt grad sagen, so viel zum Thema nicht eingehen auf die Live-Signal.
Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Jetzt weiß ich nicht, ob das Nicecast hier wunderbar weiter streamt.
Ja, mal gucken.
Ja, jetzt kommen wieder Hörer, also er streamt einfach weiter. Das ist ein Elend ist das. Ein Elend. Wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall muss ich sagen, bin ich heute gut bedient worden bei Gravis. Das wollte ich eigentlich zum Ausdruck bringen. Erstens, man kann sich da, so ähnlich wie sie das ja bei Apple mit dem Genius Bar auch gemacht haben, wenn du da ankommst, musst du nicht doof rumstehen, sondern trägst sie mit dem Rechner kurz ein, mit dem Namen. Und dann steht da gleich auf dem Bildschirm oben eine Queue, das heißt du weißt, wie viele Leute vor dir dran sind. Und das schicken sie auch oben in den ersten Stock, wo sie ja einen Kaffee haben. Das heißt, du kannst da ganz entspannt erst mal nach oben latschen, dir einen Kaffee bestellen, irgendwie an der Schrüppe nagen und hast dann irgendwie so einen Bildschirm. Und wann immer sich dabei ändert, macht es sogar bim bim. Und steht dann, bitte gehen Sie zur Counter sowieso.
Der Kaffee und die Schrüppe kosten Geld.
Wobei, ich hätte wohl, ich wurde nach einem Gutschein oder so gefragt. Ja, wenn man da irgendwie rumwartet, dann gibt es dann vielleicht auch noch ein bisschen Rabatt. Das war mir dann aber zu blöd, da gleich wieder runterzulatschen. Dann war mir dann auch Wurst. Aber soweit war das okay. Und ich muss sagen, ich war auch alle ausnahmslos, alle Mitarbeiter haben sich extrem bemüht und waren sehr freundlich.
Gibt es denn da mittlerweile kostenloses WLAN? Oder muss man dafür auch immer noch einen Kaffee bestellen, damit man ins WLAN rein kann?
Ich glaube, das ist irgendwie noch so. Warum sie das machen, ist mir auch ein Rätsel.
Total beglaubt. Heute gehst du in ein Restaurant essen, machst dein iPhone an, steht der Restaurantname mit WLAN da, klickst du, hast du net. Geht ja gar nicht. So was, den kommt man nicht mehr.
Am Ende denke ich mal, hängt es davon nicht ab. Aber keine Ahnung, man steckt da nicht drin. In Deutschland weiß ja, wie das ist mit WLAN-Bereitstellungen. Da haben sich alle immer so ein bisschen komisch.
Also der Name von diesem kleinen Laden, der von Apple empfohlen wird, ist OmniLab. In der Körnerstraße, da fahre ich gerade. 9.21.
Da wird man hingeschickt. Da bin ich nicht hingeschickt worden, sondern ich hatte so ein Allerweltsproblem für einen Rechner, der so ein MacBook, bei denen springt immer, wie auch bei meinem. Hier vorne ist dieses Plastik aus der Kante.
Das ist aber kein Serienfehler, kannst du bei Apple nachfragen. Das tritt nur bei 98% aller Gelegenheit auf.
Naja, ich hab das weiße MacBook da hingelegt, das hatte halt genau an der Stelle diesen Bug und er guckte dann nur kurz drauf und meinte, ahja.
Das hat jedes, oder?
Das ist eine totale Solbostelle bei den MacBooks.
Welche Ecke?
Hier am Rand, direkt vorne, da wo Handauflage ist, bricht irgendwann vorne rechts, wohl nicht nur vorne rechts, aber vor allem vorne rechts bricht es irgendwie raus. Das haben sie auf jeden Fall gefixt bekommen mit den neuen Modellen. Und sowas tauschen sie dann auch anstandslos aus. In dem Fall war das halt so eine Gravis-Zusatzversicherung und nicht dieses, wer ist das? Apple Care. Ja, aber das macht dann wohl letztlich auch Apple. Keine Ahnung. Auf jeden Fall war das eine brauchbare Experience und weil sie alle so nett waren, habe ich auch gleich Produkte gekauft, die ich schon immer mal haben wollte. Zum Beispiel ein Kensington Fernbedienungs-Device mit Laser-Pointer. Class 2 Laser-Produkt.
Und das brauchst du auch?
Das brauche ich auch, weil ich ja von Zeit zu Zeit, wie zum Beispiel auf dem nächsten Kongress, Vorträge halte und ich hasse es, hinter meinem Rechner zu sitzen, während ich einen Vortrag halte. Ich will das nicht. Ich rede immer frei. Steve Jobs hin, Steve Jobs her. Ich finde, wenn man einfach einen Vortrag hält, dann hat man sich mit den Leuten zu beschäftigen und nicht mit seinem Rechner. Und Leute, die die ganze Zeit auf ihren Bildschirm gucken, nur um eine 5 Minuten vor und rückwärts, die ganze Zeit die Slides ablesen, das kommt mir vielleicht in die Tüte. Deswegen brauche ich eine solide Fernbedienung. Die Infrarot-Fernbedienung, die dabei ist, die funktioniert nur dann gut, wenn du wirklich eine korrekte Sichtverbindung hast. Und du musst dann auch immer zu deinem Rechner zeigen, was manchmal gar nicht geht, weil du stehst halt auch davor. Von daher fällt das schon mal aus. Ich habe zwar jetzt auch so eine Software für das iPhone, Stage Hand heißt das, die auch immer besser wird und auch ganz gut funktioniert, die ein paar schöne Features hat. Also du installierst eine Software auf dem Mac dazu.
Der Touchscreen hat dann da schon so einen kleinen Nachteil, weil man kann sich das nicht erfühlen. Man muss hingucken. Das nervt mich schon immer, wenn ich mit dem iPhone ein Bild machen will. Ich habe vom Gefühl, ich will immer den Homebutton drücken, weil den Homebutton kann ich erfühlen. Und da muss man halt hingucken. Das ist ein bisschen blöd, weil ich will ja eigentlich sehen, was ich fotografiere und nicht wo ich hin drücke.
Ja für ein Selbstportrait, oder?
Das stimmt schon, das geht schon. Aber das Interface von dem Stage Hand ist ziemlich straightforward. Du startest das halt und dann ist einfach der ganze Bildschirm einfach nur deine Show Notes. Und du wischst einfach von links nach rechts, dann geht er zum nächsten Slide oder zum nächsten Punkt. Also das geht schon alles in der Hand und machst einfach die Geste und dann musst du ordentlich hingucken. Du kannst das dann irgendwie drehen, also die neueste Version hat das auch, dass es nicht automatisch geht. Also wenn du es im Landscape Modus hast, dann hast du ein Preview von deinem Slide, was natürlich ein Riesenvorteil ist, weil du dann eben auch nicht mehr auf deinen Rechner schauen musst, sondern der kann wirklich irgendwo stehen und es ist einfach eine reine Präsentationsmaschine. Du kannst halt zur Not auf dein iPhone gucken, wobei man auch nicht da stehen will und die ganze Zeit auf sein iPhone starren will.
Weil es welcher Flight da gerade ist.
Genau, es wäre auf jeden Fall möglich. Ich könnte mir das noch ein bisschen pfiffiger vorstellen, aber die Software macht auf jeden Fall Fortschritte. Trotzdem hast du schon recht, so eine Taste hat auch was. Und deswegen habe ich mir jetzt dieses Kensington-Teil gekauft, auch weil da noch ein Laser-Point da drin ist. Das kann ja manchmal ganz hilfreich sein, auch wenn ich nicht so ein Typ bin, der jetzt auf seinen Slides rummalt oder so.
Das ist prima, wenn man eine Katze hat.
Ja, vielleicht auch das. Aber das finde ich sehr schön designt, das Teil. Das ist auch 2,4 Gigahertz, aber das ist halt nicht Bluetooth. Bluetooth habe ich früher auch mal gemacht, mit meinem Sony Ericsson, da gab es diesen Sawling-Clicker, erinnert euch vielleicht noch. Das hat auch sehr gut funktioniert, aber du hast halt das typische Bluetooth-Problem und auch bei dem Klein für den iPhone. Das iPhone ist halt WLAN. Du kannst dir vorstellen, Vortrag halten auf dem Kongress und auf WLAN oder Bluetooth angewiesen sein, ist einfach keine gute Idee. Ich habe einmal meinen Vortrag bei der Eröffnung auf dem Kongress damit ganz gut verkackt, musste dann während des Vortrags alles neu starten. Da sitzt so dein 4.000 Nerds, alle mit ihrem Laptop auf dem Knie, die alle den neuesten Bluetooth-Stack installiert haben, mit allen entsprechenden Attacken und Scannern. Du hast es nicht gesehen. Und was weiß ich, ob sie mich da gededost haben oder ob es einfach in dem Moment ausgefallen ist.
Oder ob es einfach nicht war.
Es ist einfach uncool. Und keine Ahnung, ob das jetzt so sehr viel sicherer ist, aber ich habe es schon ein paar Mal benutzt, dieses Kensington-Teil. Es liegt super in der Hand. Und es ist einfach sehr zuverlässig. Du hast hier vorne so ein kleines Loch, da kann ich draufdrücken, dann kommt so ein kleiner Minischnipsel, sieht aus wie ein USB-Flash-Dreif. Das stecke ich einfach per USB in den Rechner und dann ist das für den Rechner wie eine Tastatur. Das heißt, wenn ich hier Tasten drücke, dann kommen die als USB-Keyboard-Device-Key-Events.
Das gibt es auch für Sony Ericsson-Telefone. Da gibt es ja direkt so eine kleine Tastatur, die mitgeliefert wird, quasi mit der Software. Wie war denn das? Da sind so, wenn man Sony Ericsson-Telefon hat, und dann kann man das per Bluetooth anmelden und dann hat das auch eine Tastaturfunktion. Da sind so ein paar Standard-Tastaturen drauf.
Also das sich sozusagen als Bluetooth-Tastatur anmeldet.
Genau, und dann kann man beliebige Tastenkombinationen da drauflegen.
Das ist ja interessant.
Das ist ganz niedlich.
Aha, das wusste ich noch gar nicht. Ich habe ja mal diesen Soling-Clicker benutzt, der war extrem nett und sehr zuverlässig auch, muss ich sagen. Abgesehen jetzt von der generellen Bluetooth-Problematik, wofür der Soling-Clicker nichts kann.
Na und, die Verbindung schläft nach einer Weile. Im einen kann das sein. Also, dass er sich nach ein paar Minuten dann Auto-Log und Bluetooth sagt, naja, okay, dann lege ich mich erstmal schlafen, dann muss ich neu verbinden und dann dauert es ein bisschen. Oder haben die das beim Soling-Clicker gelöst?
Kann ich nicht ausstehen, ich habe das Problem aber nie gehabt.
Du redest so schnell, das passiert eh nicht. Dass das Gerät einschläft in der Zeit.
Nee, ich mache teilweise sehr lange Vorträge. Keine Ahnung, meinst du jetzt zwischen zwei Key-Events oder was? Achso, ich mag inkrementelle Slides, das ist immer nur der eine Talking Point, über den du wirklich gerade redest, selbst wenn du dich noch innerhalb einer Slides bewegst. Wenn da fünf Bullet-Points sind, dann erscheinen die bei mir auch nacheinander.
Ich habe das Selen-Clicker mal genutzt, nicht für Präsentationen, sondern als Fernbedienung für iTunes. Wenn man da mitten in einem Song auf die Idee kommt, mach mal weiter, nachdem man 20 Minuten ein Stück gehört hat. Dann kann man sich schon darauf einstellen, dass er dann erst mal schlafen gegangen ist. Und sich erst mal wieder verbinden muss. Das ist ein bisschen nervig. Da ist dann eine echte Fernbedienung schon schöner.
Ja, so viel dazu.
Und was hast du dir noch gekauft?
Ein Kabel. Ein Toslinkkabel hab ich mir gekauft. Das find ich eine der ganz tollen Sachen am Mac. Was nicht jeder so weiß. Ich stelle immer wieder fest, dass vielen Leuten das gar nicht bewusst ist, dass die Macintosh, Laptops zumindest, ich glaube bei den iMacs ist das nämlich nicht so. Oder ist das bei den neuesten jetzt vielleicht auch so? Weiß ich gar nicht. Dass der Audio-Eingang nicht nur ein analoger Audio-Eingang ist, sondern auch ein digitaler Eingang, nämlich optisch. Sprich, wenn du eben nicht eine Klinke in eine normale Miniklinke reinsteckst, sondern eben so eine optische Klinke.
Und der Ausgang sowieso.
Und der Ausgang sowieso. Aber ich glaube, das haben sie auch parallel eingeführt. Also in und out war...
Out war früher, in kam später. Out gibt es schon ziemlich lange als digital.
Weiß ich jetzt nicht mehr ganz genau. Aber auf jeden Fall funktioniert das ganz prima. Und das ist natürlich toll fürs Aufnehmen. Gerade jetzt so bei Podcasts. Ich plane also hier, mein Setup da eingehen zu erweitern, dass eben auch ein SPDIF optischer Ausgang verfügbar ist. Das heißt, das Mix-Signal wird dann nicht analog zum Rechner übertragen, was den Vorteil hat, dass ich eben dann nicht auf dem Rechner auch noch mal mit Input-Pegeln arbeiten muss. Sondern es kommt halt einfach digital. Dann kann ich keinen Pegel einstellen, weil da gibt es keine Pegel-Einstellungen.
Also im Augenblick wird es digitalisiert wirklich erst am Rechner in deinem MacBook. Und dann wird es digitalisiert da in diesem Schrank, den ich vorhin mal kurz hochheben durfte.
Nö, da ist gar nichts digitalisiert in dem Schrank, den ich hochheben durfte. Das ist alles analog von vorne bis hinten.
Aber wird das denn nicht? Also wenn da das digitale Signal schon rauskommt, muss doch da irgendwo der...
Da kommt kein digitales Signal raus. Derzeit kommt da kein digitales Signal raus. Genau, da ist ja hier gerade meine Tomann-Lieferung gesehen, dieses neue Gerät, das soll das dann leisten.
Genau, dieser Podcast wird nämlich relativ kurz werden, weil Tim schon ganz, ganz dringend drüber rennen will, um sein neues Spielzeug auszuprobieren.
Na ja, wir versuchen trotzdem mal durch unsere Themenlandschaft durchzugehen.
Aber man muss zu dem Digitalen noch was dazu sagen. Es ist ja nicht nur diese von analog nach digital, dass die Qualität ein bisschen besser ist und dass man hört, dass das Signal halt irgendwie, dass es halt ein gleichmäßiges ist und nicht schon in der Lautstärke veränderbar ist, sondern dass es ein konstantes Signal ist. Sondern kommt es halt noch dazu, dass man halt galvanisch getrennt ist von zum Beispiel seiner Anlage oder so. Und dadurch hat man diese Brummenschleifen, Rauschzeugs irgendwie alles weg. Und das finde ich ist fast noch das allergrößte Feature.
Exakt. Das ist ein anderes Thema.
Wie ist das denn? Wie viele Kanäle gehen denn da drüber, über so ein optisches Kabel?
Entweder zwei. Also Grundkurs optische Audio-Übertragung. Also es gibt da ein Stecker-Format. Das ist das Gute. Das ist bekannt als, ja, entweder sagt man nur Optical Out. Oder eben auch Toslink. Von Toslink wird meistens immer nur gesprochen, wenn es ums Kabel geht. Aber ist ja klar, Stecker. Toslink ist dann auch die Buchse Toslink. Das T steht, glaube ich, für Toshiba an der Stelle, die das das erste Mal eingeführt haben. Und das Protokoll, was dort gesprochen wird, ist das sogenannte SPDIF. Hast du bestimmt schon mal gehört, oder?
Ich schon mal was gehört. Das ist dieser SPDIF-Standard, genau.
Genau, das ist das, was man seit Jahr und Tag an jedem halbwegs guten CD-Player findet als Ausgang. Und SPDIF sagt halt sozusagen, wie die Daten über dieses Kabel rübergehen, über dieses Tostling-Kabel an der Stelle. Und das steht irgendwie, glaube ich, für Sony Philips Digital Interface. Also die haben halt irgendwann mal sich da drauf geeinigt und die anderen haben es alle nachgebaut, wie das eben immer so ist. Und dann hast du einfach zwei Kanäle Stereo, 44,1 oder 48 Kilohertz. Das ist selbst taktend. Also es hat keinen expliziten Takt, sondern halt einen impliziten Takt, sodass du verschiedene Herzzahlen dort erreichen kannst. Und ja, das funktioniert vor allem sehr schmerzfrei. Das ist so, dieses Stechse reingeht.
Ich nehme an, das sieht so ein bisschen aus, als ob es komplett DRM-frei wäre, kein komplexer Protokoll dahinter, sondern eher relativ nah am Analogen dran.
Doch, genau da ging das nämlich los mit dem DRM. Das waren diese DAT-Recorder, die damals, wenn du digital überspielst, dann ist da so ein Bit gesetzt, ob das sozusagen jetzt der erste oder der zweite Schritt ist. Und beim zweiten Schritt machen sie dann sozusagen nicht mehr weiter. Was dazu geführt hat, dass DAT sich nicht durchgesetzt hat im Konsumerbereich. Das war einfach der Tod von DAT. Also damit haben sie es eigentlich gekillt.
Na das war doch dieser schöne Fall, dass Sony hat diese Disc-Mans damals massenhaft, oder wie hießen die Dinger, diese kleinen...
Mini-Discs.
Diesen Mini-Disc-Player und ihre eigenen CDs in einem Format rausgebracht haben, dass man sich von vornherein nicht auf Mini-Disc überspielen konnte.
Die Mini-Discs haben einfach das Überspielen generell nicht zugelassen. Du konntest einfach nicht die Scheiße da digital rauskriegen oder...
Draus war ja sowieso ein komplettes Farmer.
Ja, es war Lossi, aber es war immerhin digital. Ich meine, wenn es eh digital vorliegt, dann kann man es ja auch vielleicht auch mal digital gleich rausspielen. Und das haben sie halt unterbunden. Also ich habe auch eine Weile lang Podcasts mit einem Mini-Disc-Player aufgenommen. Das ist halt einfach total elend. Musste dann halt analog raus. Gibt dann zwar die super teuren großen Geräte, die so im Hi-Fi-Style daherkamen. Und da durfte sie das dann eben auch machen. Wenn du richtig viel Geld bezahlst, dann. Aber es ist halt einfach alles diese Consumer-Verhinderungsscheiße.
Das war total doof.
Ja, ist ja auch alles gestorben. Aber was übrig geblieben ist, ist halt dieser SPDIF-Standard. Der ist einfach sehr praktisch. Und das können halt alle Macbooks und, wie ich gerade gelesen habe, wohl auch die iMacs.
Und auch die Airpodexpress.
Und auch die Airpodexpress, genau. Und das ist eine sehr, sehr sinnvolle Geschichte. Einerseits, weil man eben nicht mehr pegeln muss. Andererseits, weil man eben auch diese Brummschleifenproblematik damit nicht hat. Derselbe Stecker wird auch verwendet für etwas, was als ADAT bekannt ist. Das ist, sagen wir mal, so im Semi Pro Bereich recht verbreitet. Wenn du also so Audio-Equipment kaufst, Mixer, Mischpulte, Audio-Interfaces, dann haben die alle auch mal ADAT dabei. Das ist derselbe Stecker.
Aber ist nicht kompatibel mit SPDIF.
Ist nicht kompatibel mit SPDIF, sondern das ist dann 8 Kanäle. Das ist sozusagen für Mehrspur-Recording gedacht. Von Alesis mal aufgebracht worden. Aber ein gutes Gerät, so wie das Teil, was ich mir gerade geholt habe, kann über denselben Stecker entweder das eine oder das andere, je nachdem, wie du es konfigurierst. Insofern ist es schon sehr praktisch. Ich fände es super, wenn Apple ADAT einbauen würde in die MacBooks. Weil sie haben die technischen Voraussetzungen. Die Schnittstelle ist da, sie machen darüber SPDIF. Nichts hält sie davon ab, auch ADAT zu machen. Das wäre der Hammer.
Wir haben im Club einen dicken Verstärker. Der hat ja auch digitale Eingänge, müsstest du ja wissen. Und wir haben uns express mit einem SPDIF-Kabel, also mit einem Tosslink-Kabel dran.
Ja, aber halt nur einmal stereo. Aber über ADAT kannst du halt Mehrspur-Recording machen. Das heißt, der Mac könnte theoretisch ohne größere Probleme und ohne größeren Aufwand. Das ist meiner Meinung nach eine reine Frage des Treibers. Oder vielleicht des Audiosteins. Wahrscheinlich muss der Audiostein das machen. Ja, und keine Ahnung, wie das mit Lizenzen ist und so weiter. Gut, es mag sicherlich jetzt Gründe geben, warum sie das heute nicht können.
Aber du meinst, es wäre dann das Gerät für die DJs.
Ich sagte, die Audioloiter würden jubeln, wenn man mit jedem Laptop mal eben 8-Spur-Aufnahmen machen kann, wofür die sich heute noch teure Audio-Interfaces mit Firewire und dem ganzen Treiberkack kaufen. Weil ADAT ist relativ unkompliziert, genauso wie SPDip.
Weil es dann irgendwann keinen Firewire mehr gibt.
Ja, das ist noch das nächste Problem. Aber es ist halt einfach so synchron, verstehst du? Es kommt dann einfach mal 8-Spur rein. Und gut, das reicht jetzt nicht für... In der Standard-Spezifikation sind das auch nur 44 oder 48 kHz und höhere Sampling-Graten.
Das waren sie bitte.
Da kriegst du dann nur, da hast du nur noch 4 Kanäle und so weiter. Es gibt da so andere Modi. Wie auch immer, wäre einfach ein cooler Zug. Wäre einfach etwas, wo ich sagen würde, wow, super, würde einfach die Universalität des Gerätes wunderbar verbessern, ohne dass jetzt hier nennenswert ein großer Platzverbrauch entstehen würde. Man ist nicht jetzt so wie Firewire oder nein, was wirklich ein komplett eigener Stein ist und irgendwie eine 1,5 Ampere Stromversorgung bedarf und so den ganzen Kram. Hier geht es einfach nur, optische Schnittstelle könnte auch einfach Out of the Box, Ardent machen, alle wären glücklich. Du hättest einfach serienmäßig so ein Audiodevice, das sagt, ich habe 8 Eingangskanäle. Wäre geil, aber ist nicht. Und schade eigentlich, wo wirklich so viele Leute im Musikbereich, Apple sowieso, jetzt wieder schräg angucken wegen dieser Firewire-Geschichte. Und ich selber muss sagen, I think it's that Jim. Also ich glaube, Firewire ist jetzt ein Auslaufmodell. Ich denke, ich wäre nicht...
Du müsst da vorsichtiger mit deinen Investitionen.
Ja, ich wäre nicht überrascht, ich sage nicht, dass das passieren wird. Ich will jetzt mal nicht wieder mit dem Wetten anfangen. Aber ich wäre nicht überrascht, wenn wir Ende nächsten Jahres schon Max sehen mit USB 3.0. Weil es ist für Anfang 2009, 2010 angekündigt, dass die ersten Geräte rauskommen. Und es riecht für mich nach Apple macht es früher. Vielleicht danach auch erst im Januar oder so. Aber ich denke, sie werden ganz weit vorne sein.
Ich habe auch noch eine kurze Geschichte, weil wir gerade bei Firewire und USB sind, muss ich kurz mal noch meinen Samp ablassen. Und zwar, vielleicht könnt ihr das auch hören, das gibt es so bei Ebay und auch so bei den Händlern in der Krabbelkiste, gibt es so für 7 bis 10 Euro so ein USB nach SATA und IDE, so ein Stecker, so ein Adapter halt.
Das hier, Treifu, habe ich gerade rumgelegen.
Ja Treifu, so ein Treifu, genau. Und ich habe letztens mal eine größere Menge an Daten kopiert, nämlich 320 Gigabyte. Und da ich ja so ein ZFS Fan bin, war das natürlich von einer ZFS Platte. Und das ZFS hat mir gemeldet, dass während dieser Kopieraktion circa 1000 Fehler aufgetreten sind. Und das ist nicht die Platte, weil die Daten wurden schon beim nochmaligen Lesen schon korrekt geholt vom ZFS. Aber dieser Treifu ist einfach möglich. Ich will das jetzt nicht dem USB anlassen. Ich wollte nur sagen, dass wenn Leute irgendwie auch, weil jetzt haben ganz viele diese Treifuteile, weil die so schön bequem sind, aber man muss da ein bisschen aufpassen. Also es kann echt doll in die Hose gehen.
Ja, ich hab da auch Ärger mit. Hier, guck mal, dieser komische Schalter hier.
Na ja, man kann ihn nur berühren und schon ist irgendwie...
Ja, du weißt nie, wann er an ist und so.
Die früheren waren auch ohne den. Also die meinten, das wäre ein Feature.
Ich weiß auch nicht, was das soll, warum sie da jetzt noch so einen Schalter gemacht haben. Eine absolute Sollbruchstelle. Können wir nicht empfehlen? Aber es gibt mittlerweile auch im gehobenen Zubehörbereich gibt es entsprechende Produkte. Ich glaube, das weiß ich gerade nicht, war das Belkin. Ja, so eine von diesen üblichen verdächtigen Zubehörbuden. Die haben auch so ein Universal Data Teil.
Da kostet man vielleicht 15 Euro anstatt 7. Aber ich meine, die 7 Euro sollten einem die Daten wert sein. Und ansonsten ZFS, dann passiert sowas nicht.
Apropos USB, das ich jetzt schon seit einigen Wochen mit mir rumschleppe, ist so eine kleine Art. Ich glaube, das wird euch ganz gut gefallen. Ich konnte es bisher noch nie einsetzen, also ich weiß nicht wirklich, was es taugt. So eine Art MagSafe für einen USB-Anschluss. So ein kleiner Adapter.
Ach so.
Also man hat einen USB-Stecker, man hat einen USB-Buchse.
Und dazwischen ist so ein MagSafe-Style eine Verbindung.
Genau.
Und das schnappt schön. Das heißt, man kann ein USB reinstecken, und wenn man kräftig am USB-Kabel zieht, fliegt nicht der ganze Rechner runter, sondern dann geht es an der Solberstelle auseinander.
So einen Dyncom-Log habe ich jetzt im Kopf verwechselt, sondern verstehe, verstehe.
Wie heißt das Ding?
JAPNAP. Steht auch die Adresse drauf. japnap.com Wie schreibst du das? JAP, jabnab.com Aha.
Das ist ja echt fancy. Voll toll. Ich will auch schnappen. Ich will auch.
Wusste ich doch, dass das was für euch ist.
Ja, das ist cool. Das ist eine echt gute Idee.
Jetzt bräuchten wir Fernsehen. Ich frag mich ein bisschen, wie sie es geschafft haben an der Apple-Advent...
Na, ist ja nicht Stromversorgung. Aber finde ich gut, dass die Apple-Patente jetzt nicht so gnadenlos sind, dass die Innovation den anderen gleich komplett zum Erliegen kommen muss. Das hätte ich jetzt ganz gerne auch noch für alle anderen Kabel, die ich hier reinstecke, ehrlich gesagt. So ein magnetisches Dock bräuchte man eigentlich.
Ich hätte lieber Wireless-Strom.
Ja, allerdings.
So alles komplett auf Wireless?
Ja, da müssen wir noch warten. Ja.
Aber nicht mehr lange.
So viel zum Kabel-Fu. Was gab es Neues? Es ist ja so einiges passiert. Ich fand ja von den ganzen Meldungen der letzten Zeit vor allem eine interessant. Es gab einen Vortrag von Jordan Hubbard. Wo war das jetzt? Ich glaube bei der Usenix-Konferenz. Das muss man erstmal ein bisschen über Jordan Hubbard erzählen, finde ich. Genau. Müsst du?
Ist das nicht der, der Syntology gegründet hat?
Nein, das ist ein anderer Hubbard. Jordan Hubbard ist completely mentally sane. Naja, ist ein Unix-Hacker. Ich weiß nicht, der andere Hubbard hätte vielleicht mal mehr Unix machen sollen. Er hätte sich nicht mit so einem Scheiß beschäftigt. Wie auch immer. Also Jordan Hubbard ist, soweit ich weiß, kein Scientologe. Man kann sich da ja immer nicht so sicher sein.
Er war früher bei FreeBSD, ganz oben in der Hierarchie. Er hat irgendwie die Releases von FreeBSD gebaut. Ich weiß nicht, bis 3 oder 4.
Er war Ewigkeiten-Core-Development.
Und wurde dann abgeworben von Apple, als die mit ihrem Darwin und Open Source losgelegt haben. Ist aber schon ziemlich lange her.
Der ist schon eine Weile da, ja. Das war glaube ich 1999 schon.
Kann sein, ja.
Genau, dann hat er das mal sein lassen mit dem FreeBSD und das den anderen überlassen. Und er war auch, glaube ich, so ein bisschen frustriert. Hat er sich damals zumindest so geäußert, dass er so, oder so ein bisschen früher war alles besser.
Das weiß ich gar nicht mehr.
Ich glaube, ihm ist einfach auch so ein bisschen dann die Lust vergangen.
Ich wollte auch mal ein bisschen ordentlich Kohle verdienen. Hat vielleicht auch Frauen, Kinder, war Physik nicht alles.
Wird sicherlich nicht schlecht bezahlt in seinem aktuellen Job. Er ist halt so eigentlich der Main Unix Integrator. Das heißt, er hat ganz erheblich dran gearbeitet, dass eben aus Darwin auch ein richtiges Unix wird. Weil, also wenn es einer weiß, was Unix ist, dann Jordan Hubbard. Sonst kann man glaube ich so festhalten, da haben sie sich einfach mal den Unix-Experten geholt. Und ja, bis heute ist er noch in dieser Position und er muss es wissen. Das heißt, er ist treibende Kraft auch bei diesen Ports-Anstrengungen.
Ich weiß, dass ich immer ganz gut finde, weil es ist ja ganz oft, dass ich Firmen, irgendwie so Profis rannehme, aus der Open Source-Welt und die sind dann irgendwie ein, zwei Jahre und dann hörst du noch, nee, hatte ich keinen Bock mehr, weil es scheiße, die interne Prozesskommunikation, tralala, war viel zu kompliziert und viel zu anstrengend, man kriegt nichts gebacken und das macht alles keinen Spaß und hör dann auf. So wie gerade der Typi, der so über Meiersgöl abrentet, seitdem es von Sun gekauft wurde, dieser Monty, tralala. Und der ist halt jetzt seit, keine Ahnung, neun Jahren immer noch da. Also kann es ja so schlimm bei Apple nicht sein.
Ja, oder sie haben Geisel genommen. Aber den Eindruck macht er nicht.
Wie wir wissen, wo deine Kinder zur Schule gehen.
Auf jeden Fall hat er vor kurzem einen Vortrag gehalten. Soweit ich mich erinnere, auf der Unix-Konferenz. Wo es halt, was so eine schon seit Ewigkeiten existierende Unix-Gemeinde ist. Und dort hat er einen längeren Vortrag gehalten, von dem es leider keine Audio- und Videoaufzeichnung gibt. Wohl aber einen Satz von Slides als PDF, die er rausgebracht hat. Und das ist viel diskutiert worden. Nämlich, weil er ganz am Anfang erstmal eine Übersicht von Mac OS X Releases gebracht hat. Und dort war eben auch das Release von 10.6 bereits aufgeführt, mit dem Release-Date Q1 2009. Wobei er jedes einzelne Release auch mit einem Zeit-Delta zu dem letzten Release davor angegeben hat. Und da steht halt 14 plus months. Also so richtig festgelegt hat er sich nicht. Er hat aufgeführt Public Beta September 2000, dann die 10.0, März 2001, also sechs Monate später, dann acht Monate später 10.1, neun Monate später 10.2, 14 Monate später 10.3. Also da hat sich das alles noch verlängert, bis Tiger auch noch 19 Monate, also immer, immer länger dauerte es. Dann kam Tiger Intel nach acht Monaten, na gut, das als eigenes Release aufzuführen.
Das kam ja erst mit 10.4.5 oder so was.
Genau, und dann kam irgendwie Leopard.
Nochmal 21 Monate.
Was 21 Monate noch mal gedauert hat, wenn sich das jetzt auf die Intel Release bezieht, ja wahrscheinlich. So, das heißt 10.6 dauert jetzt nicht ganz so lange. Und wie lange es genau dauert, weiß ich nicht. Also ich schätze einfach mal, sie werden zum Macworld im Januar wahrscheinlich schon relativ viel darüber erzählen, was es alles so haben wird. Aber es kommt dann halt tatsächlich erst kurz vor der Developer-Konferenz raus. Aber nicht eine Woche vorher, sondern schon so ein, zwei, drei Monate damit alle sich schon mal drauf eingeschossen haben und sie auf der Developer-Konferenz so richtig schön darüber reden können. Aber das ist eine reine Vermutung.
Ich tippe Januar, Februar.
Ich tippe April. Weil April ist immer noch ganz schön früh im Jahr. Also April ist auf jeden Fall früher als Mitte 2009.
Meines Wegen sollen sie sich noch ein bisschen Zeit lassen. Also wenn es wirklich all about Performance und Stability ist, dann... Meines Wegen auch erst Mitte nächsten Jahres. Ich hätte mal richtig Bock auf so ein richtig schön schnelles und stabiles Teil.
So schnell wie möglich.
Also es gibt ja sehr.
Also jetzt quasi.
Gestern ein neuer Bild. 10A222 oder so was. Nachdem der letzte 190 war. Und die Release Notes flattern ja auch irgendwie im Netz rum. Und ich meine, es hört sich an wie eine mega Baustelle von vorne bis hinten.
Was gut ist. Ich meine, ich bin nicht davon ausgegangen, dass sie jetzt einfach nur so 10 Sachen fixen, die ihnen nicht gefallen hat und zwischendurch gehen sie mal viel reisen, sondern die arbeiten nicht weniger hart da dran, als sie auch sonst dran arbeiten.
Das heißt aber auch, dass sie komplett alles auseinandernehmen und wieder neu zusammenschustern und wir am Ende aber noch nicht mal so wirklich viel davon haben.
Es ist kein Bug-Fix-Release. Es ist ein Performance und Stability. Haben sie Stability gesagt oder interpretiere ich das jetzt gerade rein?
Ich weiß es gerade nicht.
Ich interpretiere das jetzt gerade rein. Kuroafinder ist ja schon mal ein Ding.
64-Bit irgendwie alles umgestellt. Das ist auch ein Riesending.
Stimmt.
Übrigens steht da auch drin, dass bisher PowerPC... Wie war das? Da gibt es irgendwie keinen Support für... Für irgendwas gab es in Snow Leopard keinen PowerPC-Support. Irgendwie bei Xcode. Irgendwas mit irgendwelchen Lips oder irgendwas tief drin. Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht.
Es gibt glaube ich gar keinen PowerPC-Support, weil Snow Leopard nur auf Intel läuft.
Nee, nee, das ist nicht richtig. Also der Bild von vor einem Monat oder wann es war, der war komplett auch Universal, Binary, also auch PowerPC alles. Für drei Architekturen war der Kernel zum Beispiel. Das war irgendwie PowerPC, Intel und Intel 64-Bit. Aber kein PowerPC 64-Bit. Es kann sein, dass Snow Leopard 64-Bit halt nur auf Intel läuft. Aber schon PowerPC supported. Ob das dann am Ende auch dann so benutzbar ist und eingeschaltet wird, ist noch eine andere Frage, weil Apple sagt ja auch zum Beispiel, das iPhone SDK läuft nicht auf PowerPC. Dabei weiß ich noch, dass es früher eine Anleitung im Netz gab, was man irgendwie drei Stellen irgendwo drehen muss, damit das ganze SDK doch auf dem PowerPC läuft. Weil gebaut war es dafür.
Ja, ich fand auch so ein paar Sachen, die er in diesem Talk angesprochen hat, also jetzt nach den Slides zu urteilen, ganz interessant. Also er ist dann nochmal schnell über ein paar Security-Features drüber gegangen, die sie jetzt so bei Leopard eingeführt haben. Also ich schätze mal, er dürfte da so etwas ausführlicher drüber geredet haben. So lassen die Slides das vermuten. Unter anderem über File Quarantine, also dieses Feature. Ihr kennt das, wenn man jetzt ein Programm runterlädt und man das erste Mal startet, kommt so ein Dialog hoch, das sagt, das ist vom Internet runtergeladen worden, das könnte ganz böse sein, willst du wirklich? Und wie sie das gemacht haben, ist, dass sie hier einfach File System Metadata verwenden, das heißt, sie setzen da ein Extended Attribute im Datalsystem und sie haben auch alle ihre Tools, also alle ihre Kopiertools und halt, also wenn man jetzt mit dem System Apis das kopiert, aber eben auch auf der Kommandozeile, so umgeschrieben, dass die das berücksichtigen, das heißt, wenn du davon eine Kopie machst, bleiben diese Quarantine-Flags erhalten. Und so, dass du auch wenn du davon eine Kopie machst und es dann startet, immer noch diese Warnung kommt. Das fand ich nochmal eine ganz interessante Geschichte. Was haben sie noch? Dann hat er noch ein bisschen was zu der Sandbox erzählt, die halt wirklich eine richtige Sandbox ist auf Basis dieses Sicherheitsframeworks. Das heißt, viele Prozesse, die so im System sitzen, dürfen einfach verschiedene Sachen nicht. Also was weiß ich, so ein Spotlight-Importer zum Beispiel darf halt nicht aufs Netz zugreifen. Weil ein Spotlight-Importer muss nicht im Netz irgendwas tun. Ein Spotlight-Importer hat gefälligst, Dateien lokal zu importieren. Und deswegen, wenn diese Prozesse laufen, laufen sie halt in einer Sandbox, in der sie eben auch nichts anderes dürfen als Dateien anfassen. Sowas zum Beispiel. Was super ist, weil es geht ja immer davon aus, was passiert, wenn ich hier eine Sicherheitslücke finde, dass ich in solche Prozesse reinkomme. Also angenommen, du hast irgendeine bekloppte Buffer-Overflow-Geschichte wieder übersehen und dann stattet sich das immer, wenn irgendein Spotlight-Importer gemacht wird.
Und der prädestiniert sich ja dafür, weil der geht ja wirklich über alles drüber.
Ja genau, sie haben alle so ihre Vor- und Nachteile und das war halt hier auch Teil der Geschichte. Dazu haben sie so eine Profile-Language, die in Scheme gehalten ist, interessanterweise, in der halt genau gesagt werden kann, was ein Prozess darf. Darf irgendwie Files lesen, darf Systemkontroll-Sachen machen und so weiter. Das ist alles ganz interessant. Dann hat er noch erwähnt, über Codesigning hat er geredet, wie sie das so gemacht haben und wo sie das vor allem benutzen. Gut finde ich ja zum Beispiel, benutze ja übrigens noch nicht so viele. Na, wenn man so Programme runterlädt. Der Anteil von gesignten Programmen hält sich doch noch sehr in Grenzen. Also alle System-Sachen sind gesigned, aber so Third-Party sind es relativ wenig.
Wie sieht das dann aus mit dem Codesigning? Also ich brauche wahrscheinlich ein stinknormales Zertifikat.
Als Entwickler meinst du jetzt?
Als Entwickler. Muss ich mich da irgendwie bei Apple registrieren? Oder müssen die das erst nicht bestätigen? Oder reicht das, wenn ich mir irgendwo bei VeriSign ein Zertifikat kaufe? Und alles ist super.
Ich weiß nicht genau, wie der Prozess läuft, aber es läuft unter Garantie über Apple. Weil letzten Endes ist ja Apple, die das signen. Das wird so ähnlich laufen wie bei den iPhone-Applikationen, wo du halt so Zertifikat hin und her schicken musst.
Also nicht, dass ich einfach quasi mir auch zur Not meine Programme selber sein könnte mit CRSert oder irgendwie sowas.
Doch, das kannst du, glaube ich. Es gibt auf der Kommandozeile ein Codesign-Programm, mit dem du was machen kannst. Und das OS macht ja auch so Signing on Demand. Wenn du jetzt ein Programm in die Firewall einträgst, zum Beispiel, dass das zugreifen darf oder nicht, dann, und das ist nicht gesigned, dann signt er das sozusagen mal on the fly. Dabei geht es aber nur darum, um zu verhindern, also um zu erkennen, ob ein Programm verändert worden ist oder nicht. Da geht es jetzt nicht so sehr um dieses Signing im Sinne von, dass du sicher sein kannst, wo es herkommt, sondern nur, dass es in sich...
Dass es nicht sicher sein kann, dass es noch das Gleiche ist.
Genau.
Das hattest du doch schon mal als Problem, dass du irgendein Programm von dir, ich weiß nicht, was, eine Mail, irgendwelche Sprachen gelöscht, und dann ging deine Mail nicht mehr, weil die Keychain meinte...
Das ist diese Services-Plage. Dass ich halt die Services ausgeschaltet habe, dazu muss ich halt im Bundle irgendwie einen P-List-Fall ändern, und dann bricht mir halt das, und dann dürfte halt Mail und solche Programme nicht mehr auf die Keychain zugreifen. Die Keychain sieht halt, oh, du bist nicht mehr gesigned, du darfst hier gar nichts.
Also bastelt nicht mehr in euren eigenen Application-Bundles rum, ist inzwischen alles signiert.
Ja, das ist wirklich hart. Also Omni-Outliner hat jetzt seine neueste Version zum Beispiel auch geco-signed. Und da nervt mich halt ein Shortcut auch wie blöde. Und ich kann den nicht mehr rausmachen. Jeden Abend sag ich mir, jetzt schratzt du mal eine ganz lange ätzende Mail auf die Omni-Outliner-Mailing-Liste, aber man kommt ja immer zu nichts. Auf jeden Fall ist das gerade mit der Firewall extrem elegant gemacht, dass es einfach auf Identität von Programmen basiert und nicht mehr auf Ports. Weil die ganze Firewall-Sicherheit, die man so üblicherweise kennt, basiert eben einfach nur auf dem, wo darf was rein und wo darf was raus. Aber du kannst halt unter macOS 10 sagen, dieses Programm darf rein oder dieses Programm darf raus. Also dieses Programm darf hier diese anbieten.
Egal, was es dann ist.
Genau, was auch immer es tut, dieses Programm darf das. Ich meine bei so komplexen Sachen wie Skype oder so, wo du eben mit einer Port-Definition das gar nicht so ohne weiteres fassen kannst.
Die Firewall ist ja noch nicht per Default an, ne?
Ich glaube nicht.
Das könnte man ja mal einschalten. Dann poppt die Firewall alleine so little-snitch-mäßig und fragt, das Programm würde gerne raus.
Das darf dann einfach nicht.
Die Firewall geht doch sowieso noch.
Dann würde es langsam interessant werden. Wenn ich sagen könnte, das hab ich gerade runtergeladen, das ist voll okay, das darf hier transmischen. Die können rumsauen, wie sie wollen, aber hier irgendwelche anderen Tools, die ich hier hab, was ich gerne hätte, ist bestimmte Programme, wo ich weiß, die machen gar nichts mit dem Netz, dass ich dir noch sage, die machen nichts mit dem Netz, damit es auch definitiv so bleibt, dass sie dann doch wieder nach Hause telefonieren.
Das kannst du machen, aber du kannst, die Firewall ist nur für reinkommenden Traffic und nicht für rausgehenden im Augenblick, wie man schön leicht überprüfen kann.
Was ich dann noch sehr interessant fand in dem Vortrag, ist, dass er dann über non-executable data gesprochen hat, die sogenannte NX-Funktionalität. Das bezieht sich jetzt auf die Art und Weise, wie ein Prozessor Code ausführt. Wenn man so ein Programm lädt, unter Unix, dann besteht das aus verschiedenen Teilen. Da gibt es also einen sogenannten Textbereich, das ist der eigentliche Code. Und dann gibt es so Data-Bereiche, das ist halt so die Daten innerhalb des Prozesses. Und dann gibt es aber während das Ding läuft halt auch noch andere Bereiche wie den Heap, wo Daten, wo Speicher angefordert wird, oder den Stack, wo halt sozusagen der Laufzeitpunkt des Programms, also du machst so eine Subroutine auf, da wird natürlich der Stack benutzt und so weiter. Naja, und die klassische Problematik im Internet von Vulnerabilities, Verletzbarkeit von Software über das Netz basiert im großen Teil auf Buffer-Overflows. Das heißt, man ballert irgendwo Daten rein, das Programm erwartet eine bestimmte Anordnung dieser Daten und kommt dann was anderes, verhält es sich halt irgendwie, und ein richtig finniger Hacker ist halt in der Lage, dann in diesen Daten Code mitzuschicken und den auch noch so zu gestalten, dass das Programm nicht nur über seine eigenen Beine stolpert, sondern bei dem Stolpern auch noch die Auslöser-Taste drückt beim Aufschlagen auf den Boden, sodass der gerade eben übertragende Code auch noch aktiviert wird und du sozusagen Code eingeschleust hast.
Das ist eine hübsche Analogie.
Den Stack-Pointer verbiegen, so war das immer.
Den Stack-Pointer verbiegen und vorher dafür sorgen, dass auf dem Stack-Pointer halt entsprechende Daten liegen, die dann ausgeführt werden. Und in dem Moment, wo du überhaupt erst mal Code ausgeführt hast, hast du sozusagen von außen die Kontrolle übernommen. Das ist das Einfallstor Nummer eins. Und da ist halt auch immer wieder die Programmiersprache C besonders unter Attacke, weil sie von Haus aus eben keine Automatiken bringt, das zu verhindern. Und jetzt hat man eben auch...
Mal kurz vielleicht erklären, was so ein Buffer-Overflow ist. Also man hat, was weiß ich, was ist vorgesehen, dass irgendwo dürfen maximal 200 Leitungen stehen.
Es gibt ein Passwort ein. So. Und dann sagt das Programm, mein Passwort darf eh nur acht Zeichen lang sein, also muss ich auch mein Buffer, wo ich jetzt die Eingabe abspeichere, nur acht Zeichen lang sein. Aber dann schickst du da 5.000 Zeichen hin. Und dann schreibt er da einfach hin und merkt gar nicht, dass er sozusagen schon lange über seine eigene Grenze hinaus schreibt und schreibt sozusagen auch in Speicherbereiche, wo andere Variablen drinstehen.
Und eigentlich würde es komplett reichen, wenn der Programmierer irgendwann am Anfang sagt, guck mal wie lang das eigentlich ist, was da in Daten kommt.
Und schneide hinten ab.
Und schneide hinten ab. Oder stürz ab, ordnungsgemäß oder wie auch immer. Aber das vergisst man gerne mal.
Das ist einfach so ein Dauerbrenner und bestimmte Programmiersprachen machen es da einfach einfacher. Und manche verhindern das komplett. Das ist halt mal so und so. Aber wie das eben so ist, shit happens. Und deswegen sind die Prozessorenhersteller auch dazu übergegangen, Features einzubauen in die CPUs, mit denen eben dieser Shit von vornherein verhindert werden kann. Weil das Grundproblem ist ja eigentlich das, dass eben Code ausgeführt werden kann, obwohl er nicht in diesem eigentlichen Code-Segment, dem sogenannten Text-Segment liegt. Sondern eben im Stack, im Heap oder wo auch immer. Und das ist diese NX Non-Executable-Feature vom Prozessor. Und unter Leopard... Ne, jetzt muss ich mal kurz nachdenken. Unter Leopard ist es noch so, dass noch alles...
Ruhe.
Unter Tiger, genau. Tiger-Intel-Version hatte schon das Feature, den Stack Non-Executable zu machen. Das heißt, 10.4 auf dem Intel-Prozessor konnte den Stack schon mal nicht executable machen. Das schützt so ein bisschen. Und eigentlich will man halt mehr haben. Und bei Leopard gibt es jetzt schon mehr Features, nämlich, und zwar nur, jetzt wird es interessant, nur für 64-Bit-Applikationen. Wenn also eine Applikation 64-Bit ist, dann können auch alle anderen Bereiche dichtgemacht werden. Dass es sozusagen nur noch das Textding dicht ist. Das heißt, eine 64-Bit-Applikation ist nicht nur schneller theoretisch, sondern auch sicherer.
Ist das eine Problematik des Betriebssystems, also das Leopard das nicht kann, oder kann ein Intel-Prozessor im 32-Bit-Modus beherrscht? Das vielleicht einfach diese Security nicht.
Das kann ich dir nicht sicher sagen.
Weil zwischen den Intel-Prozessoren, bei den Gefehlsätzen gibt es ja große Unterschiede zwischen 64-Bit und 32-Bit. Die haben ja mehr aufgeräumt, als nur das bisschen 64-Bit-Modus zu verfügen.
Ich weiß es nicht ganz genau. In den Slides steht irgendwas von 32-Bit-Apps sind so wie in Tiger wegen Kompatibilität. Das hat wahrscheinlich mit Registerübergabe und Pipapo, da stecke ich jetzt nicht genug drin, um das bewerten zu können. Man kann allerdings das auch in Data-Segmenten, kann man sozusagen vom Programm aus das selber von Hand ausschalten. Da gibt es so ein System-Call-M-Protect, den man benutzen kann. Also es gibt da sozusagen Möglichkeiten. Aber natürlich will man das quasi automatisch haben, dass sich ein Programmierer gar nicht darum kümmern muss. Bloß da ist mir dann halt auch ein Gedanke, noch mal ein Licht aufgegangen, weil warum soll alles 64-Bit sein in Snow Leopard? Es soll schneller sein, aber es soll auch sicherer sein. Das heißt, wenn alle im OS enthaltenen Executables alle 64-Bit sind, bringen die natürlich dann auch eine sehr viel höhere Resistenz mit gegen solche Attacken. Ich sag nicht, dass das jetzt Sicherheitslücken komplett verhindert und ausschließt. Da gibt es immer noch andere Sachen, aber das ist auf jeden Fall ein großer Schritt.
Übrigens, dieses Non-Executable, das ganze iPhone ist komplett so. Man kann auf dem iPhone nichts aushören, was nicht signiert wurde. Du kannst sogar Code im Textbereich drin haben. Wenn er nicht signiert ist, kannst du den nicht aushören. Deswegen gibt es auch keine, ich weiß nicht, ob es ganz stimmt, aber diese ganzen Interpreter-Zeugs und Flash und Java oder was auch immer. Geht nicht, sagt ja auch Apple, weil das halt nicht, kein Code erzeugen kann.
Na ja, aber ein bisschen müssen sie sich da drum herum arbeiten.
Weil wir im Safari mit dem, da müssen sie schon eine Ausnahme machen, weil...
Na ja, da weiß ich nicht, wie sie das halt regeln. Also bei Safari ist es...
Also das Problem ist ja, sozusagen wenn ich jetzt so eine Sachen, um das vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen zu erläutern, viele moderne Programmiersprachen, also Scriptsprachen, die erzeugen den Code ja dann on the fly, also zum Beispiel die neuesten Safari-Generationen.
Squirrelfish und so, das haben wir ja schon alles schon mal... Ja, jetzt wissen wir wahrscheinlich warum.
Genau, es gibt nämlich diesen Squirrelfish Extreme, der funktioniert bisher nur für 32-Bit Intel. Also noch nicht mal für 64-Bit Intel. Und bis das dann auf ARM läuft, das wird wahrscheinlich noch eine ganze Weile dauern. Wobei dafür wäre es natürlich eigentlich interessant, gerade fürs iPhone, da soll ja JavaScript schön schnell sein. Da ist es am wichtigsten, wie ich finde.
Ja, also was auch noch gemacht wird in Leopard, also wenn ich jetzt dieses Dokument hier von dem Jordan Hubbard richtig interpretiere, also sie machen auch noch weitere Fortschritte im Bereich Adress, Space, Layout, Randomization.
Dahinter steckt das, was es schon ziemlich lange für QuickTime gibt.
Was sie da mal so ein bisschen eingebaut haben als erstes, weil QuickTime sozusagen das größte Schallentor von allen ist. Da haben sie so viel alten Code und durch diese ganzen Mediendaten, also so Buffer-Overflow, sind natürlich...
Ja, die ganzen Codex, die sie benutzen und so.
Genau, mit Codex und mit Movies, wo du einfach beliebig den Leuten auch Daten unterschieben kannst, ist das einfach das größte Schallentor.
Wie oft mussten wir schon das TIFF-Plugin fixen und das PNG und so und GIF?
Ich glaube nicht, das alte QuickTime ist nicht zu retten. Ich denke, das ist auch ein guter Grund, QuickTime X rauszubringen, was sie ja angekündigt haben. Einfach um das Ding Security technisch mal nach vorne zu bringen. Lass mich das kurz mit diesem Address-Base, Layout Randomization machen. Wenn so ein Programm läuft, dann besteht es ja aus verschiedenen Teilen. Du hast erstmal verschiedene Frameworks, ein Betriebssystem, die du benutzt. Und dazu natürlich noch dein eigenes Programm mit Bibliotheken, die du verwendest. Und das Problem ist, dass viele von diesen Bibliotheken sind quasi bekannt, nicht? Also gerade diese System Frameworks sind einfach bekannt. Das heißt, wenn ein Attentäter, wollte ich jetzt schon sagen, also ein Attacker, einen Terrorist, einen Weg gefunden hat, auch mit NxData und so weiter, in irgendeiner Form Code zu aktivieren, dann ist es für ihn immer auch sehr hilfreich zu wissen, wo dieser Code liegt. Und in den alten OS X Versionen war es einfach so, dass eben bestimmte Frameworks, wie zum Beispiel Libsystem oder so und UpKit und wie sie alle heißen, an festen Adressen lagen. Weil ja alle Programme, die so verwenden. Und das machte die Sache sozusagen einfacher.
Man wusste, wo man...
Die virtuelle Adresse war sozusagen immer dieselbe.
Man muss ja relativ blind schießen. Man muss ja Code liefern und man muss ja darauf hoffen, dass das Programm irgendwann mal an die Stelle tatsächlich springt. Und dann muss man sich darauf verlassen können, dass wenn da irgendwie steht und jetzt manipuliere noch anstelle sowieso das und das.
Ja, die konnten sich halt darauf verlassen.
Genau.
Und das wird sich jetzt auch ändern. Mir ist nicht so ganz klar, inwieweit das jetzt die Zukunft ist hier. Ich glaube, das bezieht sich auf Leoparden. Das halt einfach Address Space, Layout Randomization ist dort schon eingeführt worden. Kann aber auch glaube ich noch ein bisschen weitergehen. Dazu müsste man glaube ich den Vortrag mal gehört haben. Oder finde ich das jetzt hier noch? Ich weiß es nicht. Naja, ich will jetzt auch nicht zu tief hier reingehen. Das ist auf jeden Fall ein sehr interessantes Dokument, wo noch viele andere Sachen drin stehen. Insbesondere halt unter dem Hinblick auf Mac OS X als Unix. Das war ja auf einer Unix-Konferenz. Deswegen war das jetzt hier der Schwerpunkt. Die haben also auch die Tools nochmal, so Launch Day und so weiter, den Mittelpunkt gestellt. Auch von ZDFS ist natürlich dort erwähnt worden. Und Directory Services und wie sie so mit Open Source umgehen. Und auch diese Micrubi-Sachen, die wir schon mal besprochen haben, kommen mit rein. Und dann noch so ein bisschen auch so diese These, die ich letztes Mal schon vertreten habe, hier so CPUs und GPUs gehen gemeinsam. Also es gibt da einfach eine ganze Menge zu lernen. Kann ich sehr empfehlen, dieses Dokument. Wir werden das verlinken. Nur eine Sache ist mir vollkommen unklar. Jetzt kommt's. Jetzt kommt's. Er hat nämlich am Anfang die einzelnen OS X Releases mit ihren Kernfeatures vorgestellt. Und bei 10.2 geht's los. Bei 10.2 steht nämlich als letzter Punkt Lwmlaf 20%. Habt ihr irgendeine Ahnung, was das heißen kann?
Also wenn 20% sind, dann könnte das F schon mal für Faktor stehen.
Es kommt nochmal. Und zwar bei 10.4 bei Tiger steht auch nochmal Lwmlaf 70% in Klammern buy-buy-vario.
Dann heißt es das wirklich. Und zwar wird hier im Golem Forum darüber diskutiert, was das denn bedeuten könnte. Ich hab das vorhin nämlich mal gesucht. Und die haben das getauft als den Lame-Windows-Machine-Lav-Ed-Factor. Und man muss ja sagen, dass...
Und mein 10.2 hatte nur ein 20% Faktor.
Also die ersten Mac OS X Versionen waren eher so...
Das ging so.
Also am Anfang muss man ja wirklich Fan sein, um Mac OS X zu benutzen. Also 10.0.
10.1... 10.0 war unbenutzbar.
Mit 10.1 hab ich damals gewechselt, mit den ersten Beta-Versionen, die kamen. Und 10.2 war dann so die erste Version, wo man sagen könnte, ja, damit kann man echt mal arbeiten. Jetzt kommt's langsam. Da gab's noch keinen Photoshop und sowas. Man musste sich nicht mehr so richtig schämen. Also da war's schon so ein bisschen besser als Windows.
Ja, aber was sagt denn jetzt ein Lame-Windows-Machine- Love-Ed-Faktor von 70% aus? Dass man sozusagen 70% vorne liegt?
Ich glaub, das ist eine frei gewählte Zahl. Aber mit dem Bye-Bye-Vario, das passt natürlich insofern rein, dass Sony damals noch relativ schicke Laptops hergestellt hat, mit denen man vielleicht durchaus geliebäugelt haben könnte.
Die haben doch schon immer beschissene Laptops hergestellt. Ich erinnere noch daran, dass bei Varios grundsätzlich die Scharniere weggebrochen sind.
Aber Leute fanden die süß.
Also ich kann mich noch dran erinnern, als Steve Jobs damals das Titanium Powerbook angekündigt hat, hat er explizit die Sony Vario-Rechner als die Latte, die es einzuholen ging, genannt. Und das dann sozusagen in dem Moment, in dem dieses Betriebssystem draußen war, jetzt kommt auch kein Vario mehr in Frage. Das ist jetzt meine Theorie dazu.
Weitere Theorien in den Kommentaren von Mobile Macs im Posting zu dieser Sendung. Lwmlaf, ich hab keine Ahnung. Wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall ist das ein sehr schöner Vortrag. Den solltet ihr euch mal anschauen, wenn ihr ein bisschen Interesse habt an Technik. Ja, damit können wir das jetzt eigentlich auch beenden.
Ich muss mich wieder kurz einklinken, weil du hast wieder Keywords gesagt, und zwar ZFS.
Das Dennis Activation Keyword.
Da gibt's neue, wie sagt man?
News! Tell us! Moin, ich kurz das ZFS checken. ZFS News mit Dennis!
Ja, heute ZFS News. Und zwar bei FreeBSD gibt's den Patch, der Ende Juli rauskam, der aber nicht im Source direkt drin war. Da musste man alles von Hand patchen, und dann ging's auch irgendwie zu doll auseinander, dass es nach einer Weile nicht mehr ging. Jedenfalls ist der jetzt direkt in FreeBSD drin. Das heißt, wenn man jetzt FreeBSD Current auscheckt, also Version 8 Beta könnte man das dann nennen, hat irgendwie das neueste, letzte, greatest ZFS-Feature drin, Version 3.10, weil Apple ist ja noch bei Version 8, die Version, die wir haben.
Immer noch nicht?
Na, da ist noch so ein Typ am basteln, aber ich hab mich jetzt noch nicht so richtig gekümmert, da könnt's demnächst ne Anleitung zu geben. Vielleicht geht's schon, aber ist noch...
Was ist denn eigentlich das Problem?
Na, der Bootloader muss halt das ZFS können. Jetzt muss man erstmal alles machen. Der Bootloader ist immer so Assembler-Shit und weiß schon. Da ist er ganz tief unten.
Na okay, das komplexe ZFS...
Aber die sind dabei. Es gibt schon ein File, das heißt GPT ZFS Boot oder so. Grand Partition Dinge ins Table, ZFS Boot. Und da ist schon ein Typ, der es da machen. Vielleicht kann der schon booten, aber es ist noch nicht so...
Geht denn das bei Solaris mittlerweile? Gibt es denn von Sun-Maschinen, die booten können?
Die machen das ja mit GRUB. Auch so ein Bootloader.
Achso, der Standart Linux-Bootloader ist das, was du brauchst, oder?
Wie Solaris verwendet GRUB? Wieder heute gelernt.
Und bei denen ist ja jetzt, wenn du hier so ein Open Solaris, kam ja auch gerade die letzte neue Version raus, 2008.11, wenn du die benutzt, ist wohl ZFS auch schon alles und mit Booten davon ist alles schon Default. Also das nächste Mal hier, du musst irgendwie einschalten, weil du ZFS willst, sondern es ist einfach so. Wenn du installierst, hast du ZFS. Und dann als News noch so ein bisschen am Rande, weil wir auch alle so ein bisschen hier so ein Nerd sind und Paranoia schieben und unsere Daten, wenn wir dann unsere Laptops verlieren, was da hier auch schon jedem mal passiert ist, ne, okay, mir nicht. Aber wir wollen nicht, dass unsere Daten in fremde Hände gelangen. Gibt es halt bei ZFS den Support für Krypto und das nährt sich auch immer und soll wohl mit Release 107 oder eventuell 109 kommen von OpenSolars. Die releasen immer so, also alle zwei Wochen kommt eine neue. Und sie sind zurzeit bei 103. Das heißt, theoretisch in 6 mal 2 Wochen, 2 Wochen, 3, 4 Monate sollte das dann mal das Krypto-Feature in ZFS kommen. Und das heißt dann, das ist fertig. Weil fertig ist es eigentlich schon, das ist nur noch nicht im Source gelandet, wir müssen jetzt noch Quality-Checking machen und all sowas, bevor es dann richtig drin landet. Aber es ist, es kommt.
Wie würdest du so vom Bauchgefühl her, die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass ZFS so als, naja, vielleicht lassen wir das Boot nochmal weg, aber dass man zumindest so vollwertige, also ich meine, für Server haben sie es ja angekündigt. Und der Server wird ja zeitgleich mit dem Client erscheinen, sollten sie da nicht ihre Methodik ändern, wovon ich nicht ausgehe. Das heißt, eigentlich ist es ready for Primetime. Die Frage ist nur, wann und in welchem Maße, weil ZFS ja nun eine ganze Menge Optionen hat. Keine Ahnung, würden sie dann auch gleich mit Krypto starten? Oder machen sie es erst, wenn sie booten können?
Da bin ich mir nicht so sicher. Das ist immer so die Moves bei Apple, da sagst du, ui, so wenn es dann kommt, aber ich würde erst mal nicht davon ausgehen. Ich wäre schon happy, wenn es einfach so ein Default-Feature ist, dass ich meine Platte, mein USB-Flash-Ding, so ranstecke und boop, das geht. Und ich ziehe es wieder raus und es meldet sich ab oder weißt schon, dass alles schick ist. Da wäre ich schon happy. Weil dieses hier mit dem USB-Schnupsige Treffuhr, teile ich mir diesen 1000 Eros bei 320 Gig, das kann ja nicht sein. Also lass das irgendwelche wichtigen Sachen sein und dann ist so ein Bitfehler schon entscheidender. Wenn das zum Beispiel Krypto ist oder ein Archiv, was du auspackst, dann ist eventuell dein Archiv kaputt.
Ja, ein Bit im 100 Gigabyte Movie und das Teil ist im Arsch.
Das kann passieren. Ich meine, Movies und Archive sind teilweise auch wieder so ein bisschen da ausfallsicher. Die haben ja auch Sachen dagegen, dass es halt nicht so schlimm ist, aber will's einfach nicht. Ich hab da kein gutes Gefühl.
Es bleibt nur zu hoffen.
Ich wünsche mir übrigens zu Weihnachten für Dennis so eine ZFS-Wetterkarte vor, der dann immer sofort die ZFS News sagt. Von Norden, von FreeBSD kommt eine. Kaltpad-Front.
Starke Einflüsse von oben, Solaris, bewirken Wirbel im Apple-Bereich.
Man kann es ja nur begrüßen, dass die bei FreeBSD so stark da vorne sind, weil es sind dann schon wieder zwei OSer, die das halt pushen. Und es kommen nicht wenig Fehler von dem Pavel, der das bei FreeBSD macht.
Ich würde sogar sagen, FreeBSD ist eigentlich die wichtigste Plattform, damit sich ZFS bewähren kann.
Warum?
Weil FreeBSD ist einmal das Hardcore-Server-OS.
Aber auch nur Server. Der Marktanteil ist wirklich gering.
Klar, aber auch das sehe ich als Vorteil. Ich meine, wer ein FreeBSD aufsitzt und betreibt, der weiß auch, was er tut.
Er hat auch sonst keine Logis.
Die Leute gucken sich das genau an. Die wissen, warum sie das tun. Und sie tun es deshalb, weil es ihnen einfach Flexibilität ermöglicht, die man eben so nicht hat. Und die Einfachheit der Administration.
Und Leute, die keine Ahnung haben, greifen sich halt eine Linux-Live-Installed-CD.
Genau, und auf Linux wird es noch lange dauern, mit ZFS, allein aus Lizenzgründen.
Sieht so aus, ja. Angeblich hatte der ZFS-Typ mit dem Linus Torvalds da mal gequatscht. Die haben die da mal getroffen, privat zu Hause sogar. Aber bisher gibt es da keine weiteren News. Man sollte wohl gespannt sein, aber der Spannungsbogen ist schon längst überzogen, weil es ist schon ein halbes Jahr her oder länger.
Die sind mit Treff mittlerweile fertig.
Mir ist Linux an der Stelle jetzt auch erstmal egal, weil ich sehe einfach nicht, dass man sich unter Linux mittelfristig wirklich energisch mit ZFS auseinandersetzen wird können. Einfach wegen dieser Integrationsproblematik.
Entspannt, was File Systems angeht. Die haben ja so viele File Systems, also X3, X4, BTF, oder was da jetzt kommen soll, Reiserzeugs und XFS und dann noch irgendwie ein zukünftiges.
Ja, aber es kann halt nicht in den Körner.
Das kann man aber fix ändern. Da sagt es dann, GPL, zack, fertig.
Wie? Ach so, ich glaube nicht, dass... Du meinst Dual Licensing.
Klar. Deswegen war Linus Torweils bei diesen Chef-Strategen von ZFS.
Gut, klar.
Darüber quatschen wir halt. Und Linus ist halt der Typ, der bestimmt was in die Körner kommt.
So ist es jetzt nicht, aber mir ist jetzt der Dienungsaspekt dabei auch vollkommen egal. Ich sehe einfach nur eine Technologie, die sich bewährt. Die muss halt auch in der FreeBSD-Community überleben können. Und etwas, was, also wenn das Default FreeBSD mit ZFS kommt, dann sehe ich da einfach eine große Verbreitung und ein hohes Maß an Testing. Ich würde einfach vermuten, dass das jetzt nicht nur irgendein Feature ist, was keiner anschaltet, sondern da werden die sich drauf stürzen wie die Höllenhunde. Und binnen eines halben Jahres wird es da einfach zu Ergebnissen kommen.
Das ist ja nur ein Current, was nicht jeder einsetzt.
Genau. Das heißt, dass da eben auch viel developed wird und das ist ja nun auch einer der Source Codes, wo Apple sich selber immer wieder bedient. Was bei FreeBSD und NetBSD und so weiter auch bei OpenBSD entwickelt wird, das ist einfach relevant auch für Darwin. Naja, wir werden es sehen.
Kann nur hoffen.
Es geht auch an anderen Fronten weiter. Es wurde gemeldet, dass diese OpenCL-Gruppe Kronos. Bitte?
Kronos.
Genau. Kronos, die auch OpenGL macht. Die haben sich wohl so richtig fix einigen können auf diesen Standard. Also OpenCL, die Arbeit am Standard als solchen ist abgeschlossen. Nach sechs Monaten. Was ungewöhnlich ist, weil es normalerweise, je nachdem, worum es geht, aber sechs Monate ist ein bisschen wenig. Sechs Monate haben andere Standard-Bodies normalerweise Review-Time. Und das war jetzt wohl von Start bis Ziel. Keine Ahnung, was da jetzt zugeführt hat, dass das so fix ging. Auf jeden Fall ist OpenCL als Standard jetzt abgeschlossen. Sprich, wenn Snow Leopard rauskommt, ist es halt nicht so ein, hier wie mit dem WLAN-Standard, mit irgendwie vorübergehend und Draft-N, das ist einfach 1-0. Beim WLAN, das steigt aber auch ganz gut so. WLAN ist auch echt so ein Bereich, da sollte man lange drüber nachdenken, bis man Stempel drauf gibt.
Ja, aber benutzt doch jetzt eh jeder schon.
Ja gut, aber du musst ja auch mit den ganzen Rogue-Installations klarkommen, die sich irgendwie an solche Standards nicht halten und musst gegebenenfalls deinen Standard daraufhin härten, dass er eben von solchen Doof-Männern nicht durchher nachgebracht wird. Das hast du bei OpenCL so jetzt erstmal nicht. Das ist kein Funk.
Wie lange haben wir jetzt den neuesten WLAN Shit schon? Das ist es 802.11g? Ja siehst du, ich komm schon miteinander. Und den N gibt es jetzt aber auch schon, die ersten Geräte gibt es auch schon seit zwei Jahren, oder?
Eineinhalb Jahre, ja, sowas.
Ja, ist klar, aber es ist...
Nein, nein, nein, mein Ding ist ja N, das ist zwei Jahre alt.
Zwei Jahre?
Hattet ihr nicht Neue gekauft? Also ich hab...
Wie viel Geld, oder was?
Ich hab, weiß nicht, hatte ich nicht irgendwie sowas...
Wir hatten Neues als ich, aber ich hab hier so das erste 64-Bit...
Core 2 Duo.
Core 2 Duo, genau, und das hat N.
Ja, ja, klar, das hat N.
Also zwei Jahre her.
Das wollte ich jetzt nicht, ich war nur gerade überrascht, ich dachte, ihr hättet irgendjemand von euch... Wer war denn das? Ich verwechsel gerade mal.
Viele hat sich ein neues MacBook gekauft.
Ja, so einige. Ich dachte, einer von euch ist jetzt auch dabei.
Jedenfalls gibt's den Standard schon seit zwei Jahren und vielleicht ein bisschen länger, weil andere schon noch ein bisschen früher diese Draft tralala rausgebracht haben. Das heißt, eigentlich müsste doch langsam schon wieder mal was noch Geileres, Neueres kommen. Weil, ich meine, N ist schon ziemlich cool. Ich meine, du kriegst da locker 7, 8 Megabyte die Sekunde drüber.
So viel? Also ich habe zu Hause über meine N-Hardware kriege ich so 4, 5 Megabyte Max.
Man muss schon mal deine Station umstellen, aber den Nachbarn mal ein Strom wegmachen.
Nein, ich habe mir extra eine N-Station gekauft, um ein paar neue Kanäle zu haben, weil ansonsten ist meine Wohnung...
Betreibt sie noch im 5 Gigahertz-Bereich?
Ich glaube schon, dass User Interface von dieser Belkin-Scheiße wirklich nicht zu durchschauen. Ich habe so einen Belkin-N-Router, glaube ich. Und einen Router glaube ich schon, den nicht nochmal.
Den N kann man sowohl im 2,4 als auch im 5 Gigahertz-Bereich betreiben. Man sollte den 5 mal nehmen, weil der ist nicht so voll. Und dann für unsere Tausenden von Milliarden von Zuhörern habe ich noch eine kleine Idee, nicht einen Tipp, sondern es ist eine Idee. Weil wenn jeder seine Station mal nicht ans Fenster stellt, weil man braucht außerhalb von seiner Wohnung kein Netz, und jeder, der ein bisschen mehr in die Wohnung rein, dann würden sich die Leute auch nicht so gegenseitig alle übersprechen. Und vielleicht hat dann auch jeder dann doch so ein bisschen besseren Anfang.
Das sprach zu Ihnen Pastor Dennis A.
Weil wenn ich in meinem Schlafzimmer bin, und mein Schlafzimmer ist eigentlich technisch frei, so mehr oder weniger, in meinem Schlafzimmer kann ich circa 15 Stationen sehen und ich bin nicht mal am Fenster dran. 15. Das heißt, jeder Arsch und sein Uhr hat eine WLAN-Station. Wenn ich rausgehe, so vor meinem Schlafzimmer, ich hab so einen Garten daran, dann ist es wahrscheinlich...
Ich muss immer wieder grinsen, auch wenn es hier so um irgendwie, wir machen jetzt mal free Wi-Fi in unserer City irgendwie. Ich sehe das ja nicht.
Es ist doch überall free. Jeder Kackcafé hat irgendwie WLAN.
Ja, aber es funktioniert dann nicht, weil du eben an der Stelle, wo du sitzt, auf Kanal 8, wo das irgendwie reinkommt, noch 10 andere Anbieter hast, bei Kanal 8.
Genau, weil die Leute alle ihre Stationen zum Beispiel am Fenster dran stehen haben und die mal ein bisschen tiefer in die Wohnung reinziehen sollten.
Ach, das nützt doch gar nichts, selbst wenn sie das nicht tun würden.
Eigentlich wärs doch langsam mal angebracht.
Oder die andere Idee ist, wenn man einfach mal ein bisschen runterpegelt, man muss nicht irgendwie volle Pulle oder so das Signal machen.
Wer kann das schon einstellen?
Außerdem will doch jeder, ich meine, wenn alle anderen schon mit voller Power pullen, dann möchte ich da auch mit voller Power, damit ich es selber empfangen habe.
Immer drauf! Den Jungs vom Dritten stoppt keine Chance. Was die neuen Standards regeln müssen, dass die halt nur so viel senden, wie die Gegenstation meint, wie sie brauchen, nicht halt da überpusten. Vielleicht macht das N ja schon, ich weiß gar nicht so genau. Aber das muss alles besser werden.
Eigentlich muss man ja mal sagen, kann man langsam mal doch ein bisschen die Telcos da ein bisschen in Verantwortung nehmen oder so was, dass die mittlerweile nicht mehr nur noch fürs Kabel verlegen zuständig sein sollten, sondern sich auch mal um sowas langsam Gedanken machen.
Ich will doch mein eigenes WLAN haben. Ich will doch nicht, dass mein Telco, der will ja grad wieder Geld dafür haben.
Nee, aber dass es legal ist und dass es vielleicht auch ein bisschen unterstützt wird, dass man sich sowas einfach teilt. Dass man dann als Haus eine 50 MBit Anlage hat und dann hat jeder die gleiche SSID. Und darüber geht das dann irgendwo. Ich weiß, das ist ein schöner Traum.
Und die machst du dann mit dem Krypto, dann sehe ich ja, was meine Nachbarn für einen Porn zu öffnen, die will ich gar nicht. Ich will die normal grüßen können, wenn ich morgens irgendwie nach Hause komme.
Ungelöste Probleme, ich sag's dir.
Wie du könntest deine Nachbarn nicht mehr grüßen, wenn die konsumieren alle Pornografie.
Ja, aber welchen?
Grüß sie nicht mehr, also mach einfach keinen Handschlag.
Welchen Porn?
Mach so ein entspanntes, wenn es nicht stimmt.
Das ist nicht schön.
Ich will das nicht wissen.
Dann guck nicht nach, ich meine, du musst nicht runterladen.
Na ja, aber wenn das da so in deinem Netz rumfliegt und dir die Bandbreite raubt, dann willst du ja auch wissen, was es ist.
Vor allem dann irgendwie lädt einer da einen Scheiß runter, lädt das neueste deutsche Spiel runter, die deutsche Firma ist da hinterher, weil es halt in Deutschland so und dann sagen sie, der Anschluss war's gewesen.
Das muss geklärt werden. Im Café geht's ja auch.
Mit so einer Special Force und raiden das ganze Haus. Nee, lass mal.
Genau.
So in meine Nachbarin ist es nicht gut für ihr auch.
Nach zum Drei kommen sie da in dein Haus, in deine Wohnung.
Ich wohne nicht bei Dennis.
Herr Winde, Sie haben gerade Elefantenporn gesurft. Das ist verboten nach Paragraph, hast nicht gesehen, neues Schäuble gesetzt, so geht's ja gar nicht.
Elefantenporn?
Na ja, kennst du nicht Rules 34? Nee. If you can imagine it, there's porn of it.
Ja, aber das würde mich interessieren, wie du das vorstellst.
Sind wir mit dem WLAN-Thema durch? Ich glaube, das müssen wir jetzt nicht weiter vertiefen, oder? Nein, das haben wir eh nur durch Zufriedener gekommen. Wir haben hier eine weitere Spezialdisziplin von Dennis auf der Liste, die Apple is Evil! Ja!
Wo denn jetzt schon wieder?
Heute aus Berlin.
Naja, die neuen MacBooks haben jetzt HDCP eingefroren.
Ich finde das gar nicht evil.
Na, dann sag mal.
Also das ist natürlich schon evil, weil...
Moment mal, jetzt erst mal was ist HDCP?
Erst mal sollten wir erklären, wovon wir reden, und dann analysieren wir das, oder?
Ich weiß jetzt gerade nicht, wofür die Abkürzung steht.
Na, HD steht für High Definition und CP steht für Content Protection.
Also die Sache ist die, dass wenn man jetzt im Apple Store einen HD-Film kauft und man will den mit seinem neuen MacBook über seinen Mini Display Port-Tropritärstecker abspielen und hat aber nur einen Adapter nach DVI dran und da sein altes Apple Cinema Display dran und was ohne Mini Display Port ist, dann sagt der Player geht nicht, weil der Bildschirm ist dafür nicht geeignet. Oder nicht erlaubt oder so.
Naja, nicht geeignet ist nicht der Punkt, sondern...
Ist nicht erlaubt, den dort abzuspielen über dieses Interface.
Genau, weil der Rechner nicht in der Lage ist, den Bildschirm verschlüsselt zu schicken. Was er nämlich dann tut, weil es dann nämlich die Dechiffrierung im Bildschirm stattfindet. Das ist ja der heiße feuchte Traum der Content-Mafia und HDCP.
Die Content-Mafia hat da bestimmt ein Stück mitgemacht, aber ich glaube, die eigentlichen Winner an der ganzen Geschichte...
Sind die Monitorhersteller?
Ja, klar, die wollen natürlich neue Bildschirme verkaufen.
Na da bin ich einmal...
Weil ich meine, wer klaut in ein Movie, weil er das auf dem Mac abspielen kann? Niemand, wenn der Film im Apple Store kommt, ist doch eh alles schon gelaufen.
Na ja, aber ich meine, es ist ja für...
In der Zukunft vielleicht immer...
Mehr gedacht als...
Du weißt doch, wie die Idee ist. Die Idee ist, dass die Daten einfach gekryptet angeliefert werden und sich erst im Bildschirm, wo ihnen keiner mehr abgreifen kann, theoretisch, dass er dort erst dekodiert wird, sodass er ihn sozusagen nicht im Computer dekodieren muss, wie das bei DVDs ist. Ich glaube da auch nicht dran, dass das funktioniert. Bloß der Punkt ist, die Scheiße wird eingebaut und Apple macht jetzt mit. Und die neuen MacBooks haben sozusagen HDCP für ihre internen Bildschirme.
Für die internen auch? Ja.
Wie für die internen?
Na, das, wo du drauf guckst. Deinen Laptop-Bildschirm.
Also damit ich nicht mal mehr die Möglichkeit, also ich damit selbst diese ganz komplette Paranoide aus dem Film zu klauen, dass ich mir ein MacBook kaufe, das Display abnehme, an das Kabel, wo normalerweise das Display dranhängt, einfach ein mega gemeines Aufnahmegerät hänge und damit dann meine Filme aufzeichnet. Das wird damit verändert.
Sehe ich das richtig? Genau, was sowieso kein Mensch macht.
Aber so eine Geräte gibt es schon, die das machen. Die sich so dazwischenklemmen?
Es gibt genug Geräte, die das machen könnten.
Na, dazwischenklemmen ist ja damit ausgeschlossen mit HDCP.
Ich meine, es wird auch, das ist halt der Aberwitz. Natürlich wird es auch Geräte geben, die sagen hallo ich bin ein HDCP-konformes Gerät.
Das ist die Frage, vielleicht kriegen die kein Key und so weiter.
Dann kriegen die halt da doch irgendwie ein. Dann gibt es halt so eine Geräte. Ich glaube nicht, dass das so wasserdicht ist.
Am Ende freuen sich doch nur die Bildschirmhersteller, die dann irgendwie neue Bildschirme verkaufen können.
Na ja, ich weiß nicht, ob sich die Bildschirme herstellen. Ich glaube den Bildschirmhersteller ist das ziemlich egal. Das ist irgendwie dann wieder noch etwas, was irgendwie nicht...
Aber Apple zum Beispiel freut sich doch, weil ich könnte jetzt angenommen, ich kaufe mir jetzt ein neues MacBook Pro und ich hab zu Hause halt noch so ein schickes 23 Zoll Cinema Display. Mit 1920, so wie das neue Display auch. Es ist halt nur 23 Zoll. Die Größe hat sich geändert, die Punkte sind die gleichen. So, dann könnte ich mir einen schicken Mini Display Port nach DVI Adapter kaufen und meinen Bildschirm weiter benutzen. Kann ich aber nicht, weil ich da keine HD Movies gucken kann.
Kann ja sein, dass die Bildschirmhersteller sich alle freuen und vielleicht freut sich Apple auch. Wer sich nicht freut, sind die Anwender. Weil du schließt dann einfach deinen scheiß VGA-Beamer an und der sagt dann einfach, ich liefer dir keinen... Ich meine gut, bei HD könnte man jetzt sagen, was willst du mit einem HD-Content da auf dem Beamer? Aber es ist einfach allein die Präsenz von dem Scheiß wird dazu führen, dass mehr kopiert wird.
Und die Komplexität steigt natürlich noch ab.
Das wird eher dazu führen, dass keiner dann HD-Movies kauft. Also zumindestens niemand, der nicht so einen Schirm hat.
Das ist auch wieder eine neue Fehlerquelle. Wodurch das bekannt geworden ist, dass es halt ein Bug gab im OST oder in der Firmware von irgendwas.
Das war bei MechTunes, oder?
Aus Versehen auch SD-Movies.
Genau, dann kam diese Fehlermeldung mit, du hast einen Bildschirm angeschlossen, der keine HD-CP unterstützt und so weiter, obwohl es gar nicht um HD-Content ging. Na ja, ich meine, die Bugs kann man irgendwann raus squeezen. Dann kann man sagen, wenn es funktioniert, dann funktioniert es.
Aber ist nicht Blu-Ray mittlerweile auch komplett ein für alle Mal gehackt worden? Ja, sowieso.
Es ist eh alles void.
Also HD-DVD war ja schon ein lang fällig.
Ich meine, Apple hat sich bisher dem doch ziemlich erfolgreich entzogen.
Zum Beispiel mit dem iPhone, wo sie ja komplett offen sind. Wie? Das war jetzt Ironie.
Ach so, nicht die Diskussion. Mir geht es jetzt wirklich um diese Content-Geschichte. Ich meine, bei den Programmen hat man ja gerade mit Kurzeilen, das macht ja auch alles Sinn. Aber bei dem Content, ich glaube einfach nicht, dass das gut ist. Ich hätte lieber das nicht.
Ich auch nicht.
Kommen wir zu den Updates hier.
Nein, jetzt sind wir noch beim Mini-Display-Port kurz mal.
Ah ja, richtig, wo wir das gerade haben?
Normalerweise ist der Display-Port ein bisschen größer. Apple hatte aber keinen Bock auf so einen großen Stecker, was man ja verstehen kann, weil es sollte auch am MacBook Air funktionieren, zum Beispiel, das Gerät ist einfach nicht mehr so groß für so einen Stecker. Und da es keine Alternative gab, hat sich Apple gedacht, shit, machen wir halt unseren eigenen Stecker. Und damit sie auch halt nicht ganz alleine dastehen, weil das ging mir ja bisher auch oft in die Hose, wenn Apple mit eigenen Steckern kamen, die haben sich nicht so durchgesetzt.
Gerade Monitoranschlüsse?
Erinnerte auch an die Monitoranschlüsse, genau. Die Idee ist aber nicht schlecht, aber wenn es sich halt nicht verbreitet, dann hat man da nichts von, muss man später nur teure Adapter kaufen und das ist alles blöde. Also hat Apple gedacht, diesmal machen wir es anders. Und hat halt die Lizenz für den Stecker freigegeben, es ist so ein PDF mit allen technischen Zeichnungen drin, was man als wann, wie, wo beachten muss, sogar in welcher Reihenfolge sich die Pins irgendwie zu connecten haben, also dass sich erst Ground berührt und dann der Rest und all sowas. Und ja, habe ich auch schon in der Kommentare gehört, warum Apple nicht gleich zu dieser VESA Group, die das spezifiziert, warum sie denen nicht das gleich rüberschieben und sagt, hier habt ihr, könnt ihr for free irgendwie verteilen, sondern dass sie immer noch selber eine Lizenz machen.
Weil es vielleicht schneller geht?
Kann sein, ja.
Weil jetzt das irgendwie nochmal durch VESA durchzukloppen, dass sie das announcen, da sagen sie einfach, wir machen das jetzt übrigens so und wir rollen jetzt hier in den nächsten 6 Monaten 5 Millionen Geräte raus, die das alle haben. Und hier, kostet nichts, bauts ein, ist kompatibel mit Max, gib ihm.
Habt Spaß dran.
Apropos Mini DisplayPort, wie heißt der jetzt? Mini, Mikro, ich weiß nicht. Mini DisplayPort. Das ist ja nicht nur fürs MacBook, eher interessant. Ich hab einen sehr schönen Artikel, ich hoffe, ich find den noch gleich, gelesen oder eigentlich ein Forumsbericht darüber von jemandem, falls ich das beim letzten Mal schon hatte, warum möglicherweise das MacBook kein Firewire hat. Und zwar schlicht und ergreifend, weil auf der Platine nicht mehr genug Platz war. Und zwar, weil die ja aus produktionstechnischen Gründen, also das MacBook Pro hat ja noch Anschlüsse auf beiden Seiten, weil das Maserboard einmal komplett rübergeht. Und nun ist ja bei den neuen MacBook Pros, ist hier unten die Tastatur, dann ist im oberen Bereich das CD-ROM-Laufwerk oder das optische Laufwerk. Das heißt, da ist eigentlich nur noch relativ wenig Platz, wo überhaupt so ein Maserboard rein kann. Und damit ist nur noch relativ wenig Außenseite nach links bzw.
nach rechts. Wenn Sie der Meinung gewesen wären, dass Firewire da unbedingt drin sein muss, dann hätten Sie auf einen USB-Anschluss verzichten müssen. Dann hätten Sie den Platz gefunden, dann wäre das Gerät halt nochmal einen Millimeter höher oder was weiß ich, länger breiter gewesen.
Es hätte eine Firewire länger tiefer sein müssen, quasi. Oder Sie hätten eben eine Reiserkarte auf die andere Seite.
Dann weiß ich über alles, was Sie rausschmeißen können.
Insofern, da hätte auch gar kein Voll-DVI-Port mehr einfach so dran gepasst. Oder wahrscheinlich auch kein Display-Port. Das geht schon alles, das ist eine Millimeterarbeit, so ein blödes Laptop nach wie vor.
Ja, es muss ein kleines Stecker her.
Jemand, von dem ich weiß, dass er jetzt sogar live zuhört, hat mir gesagt, dass an seinem neuen MacBook Pro die beiden USB-Stecker näher beieinander sind. Aber ich habe das heute mal beim Gravis verglichen und konnte ehrlich gesagt das nicht bestätigen. Also der Abstand zwischen den beiden USB-Ports scheint mir nach wie vor konstant zu sein.
Habe ich auch gehört, dass da jemand beschwertet, dass zwei USB-Flash-Schnupsies da nicht gleichzeitig reinigen, weil die zu breit sind. Aber dann müssen die Hersteller immer ein bisschen schmalere Teile machen.
Das wird er ja sicherlich schon. Ich habe es jetzt nicht mit einem Lineal genau ausgemessen. Ich habe es so nebeneinander gehalten und ich konnte so recht keinen Unterschied feststellen.
Also bei den MacBook Pros ist es ja sehr nervig, dass der Stromanschluss direkt neben dem USB-Port ist und da ist einfach viel zu wenig Abstand dazwischen. Weil gerade wenn man so einen Card-Reader oder so was dran hat, so einen kleinen, der direkt dranhängt, stellt man und man mittendrin feststellt, Moment mal, jetzt wollte ich doch eigentlich rasch mal ein bisschen Strom ranpacken. Kriegt man keinen Strom mehr ran, weil der USB-Anschluss das entsprechend drüber ragt. Gibt es einige Geräte.
Ich habe immer so eine kleine USB-Verlängerungsstrippe dabei. Hört zu meinem Standard-Kabel-Set. Macht manchmal einfach die Sache angenehmer. Generell mag ich einfach so lang herausstehende Sachen, die fest drin sind. Da ist ja dein komisches Magnet-Ding ganz gut. Aber das ist auch ganz schön dick.
Da würdest du auch nicht zwei von rein kriegen.
Hier habe ich gerade mal probiert, das passt gerade so gut.
Neben dem Strom, aber wenn jetzt noch der USB-Port wäre, wären ja noch die Alhinten-Macbook-Posts. Da sind ja links und rechts jeweils ein. Da haben wir ja so ein Problem nicht.
Eigentlich würde es komplett reichen, wenn ich beim Reinstecken dran denke, das wäre ein USB-Port, aber weil ich links einer bin, steckt es immer zuerst im linken drin.
Naja, unsere Geräte sehen so alt aus, wenn ich auf diesen Tisch gucke. Das ist echt alles antik.
Wir sind halt Power-User.
Was hat denn das damit zu tun?
Ein Power-User hat immer den ältesten Scheiß, was du noch nie gemerkt hast.
Was?
Klar.
Seit wann?
Ist so.
Sagt Dennis, der sich sonst immer jedes Gerät sofort kauft.
Vielleicht sollten wir mal einschränken auf arme Power-User. Wir können halt mehr rausholen.
So, jetzt wollte ich mal ein bisschen zum Thema Software-Updates kommen. Software-Updates, wo wir jetzt gerade...
Wir sollten mal jingeln zwischendurch.
Software-Updates, welche Software?
Ja, in unerwarteter Reihenfolge. Und zwar gab es ein Software-Update für Apple TV. 2.3? Genau, 2.3. Und sie haben meinen größten Kritikpunkt, den ich bisher bei Apple TV hatte, behoben. Nämlich, die Dinger können jetzt auch Airpodexpresse, Audio, AirTunes ansprechen. Das heißt, kann nicht nur selber als ein AirTunes-Ding verwendet werden, so wie das bisher war. Dass du sozusagen wie eine Airpodexpress auch eine Apple TV als Lautsprecher benutzen kannst.
Ist das so?
Das war bisher so, ja.
Schon immer?
Nee, seitdem 2 irgendwas update.
Auch erst mal.
Oder 2.1.
Das heißt, ich hab mir mal überlegt, wenn ich mir schon so eine Apple TV kaufe, dann will ich, dass ich auch da Musik hinschicken kann.
Das kannst du.
Und das ging aber am Anfang nicht, ne?
Das ging am Anfang nicht, aber das ging das Grunde.
So und jetzt kann das Ding auch selber schicken.
Und jetzt kann es auch selber schicken. Was für ein Media-Center-Teil für mich immer das wichtigste ist.
Das Apple TV ist immer noch keine Basis-Station.
Aber jetzt mal das WLAN-Mass jetzt.
Soweit ich weiß nicht.
Weil dann wird es interessant. Weil es meine Express komplett ersetzen kann. Man braucht keine Express kaufen, sondern kann mir eine Apple TV kaufen. Die ist dann eine Basis-Station. Die ist dann ein und Ausgangspunkt für Musik. Das ist einfach ein mediales...
Das ist nicht unbedingt der Ort, da wo du den Fernseher hast, hast du nicht unbedingt deinen DSL-Anschluss.
Aber was ich in dem Zusammenhang......
uns nicht unbedingt spannender finde, ist...
Das würde ich...
also das finde ich nicht so wichtig.
Ich hab nicht Bock auf tausend Geräte.
Ist die Frage, ähm...
Kann man denn das? Geht das nur für Ausüben? Per iTunes oder kann man denn auch Firmen darüber abspielen?
Allerdings, das wär jetzt die Frage.
Tja, also... Hast du eine Apple TV? Nein, aber jetzt ist sozusagen mein vorletztes Hindernis ausgeräumt. Und das letzte Hindernis räume ich gerade aus, indem ich mir einen neuen Bildschirm kaufe, der Component hat. Weil mein alter Fernseher, den ich hier noch stehen habe, der alte CRT, der hat halt keinen Component-Eingang, deswegen konnte ich bisher eine Apple TV überhaupt nicht anschließen. Also ich hätte einfach kein Bildschirm gefilmt.
Ich hab eine Vision.
Du hast eine Vision, oh Gott, soll ich kurz die Tür...
Ja, kurz Pause, merke wo du warst. Und zwar kommt bald ein neues Apple TV-Hardware raus, mit Mini Display-Port und mit HDCP. Muss einfach sein.
Na, wir haben jetzt schon HDCP, weil das Ding hat HDMI. Wobei du auch über Component rausgehen kannst.
Plopp, die Vision ist wieder weg.
Du kannst auch über Component rausgehen, ich weiß, und man müsste eigentlich auch dein HD anzeigen können. Also an der Stelle ist das irgendwie auch alles Quark. Ich weiß nicht, ob sie...
Aber ich hab eine Vision, und zwar Tim wird sich jetzt quasi ein Fernseher kaufen, vielleicht sogar noch dieses Jahr 10. Wie lange redest du jetzt über Fernseher?
Ich hab ihn bestellt. Du hast ihn bestellt? Ja, er könnte jeden Moment... Ding Dong, Ding Dong. Ich möchte betonen, dass ich mir... Nur deshalb einen Fernseher gekauft habe, weil das die billigste Methode ist, an einen großen Bildschirm ranzukommen.
Ist das, oder?
Weil Fernsehen interessiert mich immer noch nicht. Ich hab mir mal so ein ITV geschoppt, ihr wisst schon, diese USB-Fernsehendings. Das schalte ich so einmal die Woche... Nee, alle, keine Ahnung, selten an, so, wenn ich mal so eine ruhige Minute habe, selten. Und dann geh ich da so durch und es ist skurril. Also es ist alles Tant, was ich sehe. Was ist es? Das ist so Tant. Ja, es ist billig und schlecht. Aber ich will nicht über Fernsehen reden.
Doch ich aber, ganz kurz, ganz kurz.
Warum? Fernsehen ist landweilig.
Ja, aber ich war ja im Urlaub eingeladen von meinen Eltern. Darum war ich mit meinen Eltern in meinem Haus und meine Eltern gucken Fernsehen. Und die gucken das wirklich für die Kindes anderes.
Ich weiß, Leute tun das. Und manchmal ist das auch okay. Und ich finde Fernsehen hat auch durchaus eine Berechtigung.
Nee, hat's nicht mehr.
Doch, wenn man so live irgendwas gucken will, ist Fernsehen toll.
Ich hab ein Interview gesehen. Ich hätte die Fragen besser formulieren können. Und das sag ich. Ich glaube, ich hätte sogar die Kamera besser halten können. Die wollten jugendlich sein und haben die Kamera so komplett schiefgehalten.
Das geht aber auch für viele Podcasts.
Das geht natürlich auch für viele Podcasts. Aber warum brauch ich da für Fernsehen? Und ich hab irgendwie einen Tatort oder Polizeiruf oder sowas gesehen.
Das war so unterirdisch.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie Seifen-Urbanosch immer sein soll.
Mit dem Hacker, mit dem Telefon?
Nein, das war es nicht. Das sind Bundespräsidenten-Kandidaten hervor.
Ach so, Peter Solan.
Das sind doch mal steile Karrieren.
Das hat noch niemand gesagt. Dann ist er kein Tatort-Kommissar mehr.
Jetzt wird es hier langsam zum Spreeblick-Podcast. Wir wollen uns nicht über diesen Kulturaspekt unterhalten. Wir bleiben bei der Technik. Fernseher kaufen, schließt die letzte Lücke und das Ding muss nur noch der Preis runter.
Und eine viel, viel größere Festplatte rein.
Bei Ebay habe ich gesehen, werden neue Apple-TVs verkauft für 220 Euro.
Was kosten die in Laden offiziell? 300.
Nur da, wo Filmverleih ist, sind die billiger geworden. Apple hat den Preis gesenkt um ungefähr 70 Euro. In den Ländern, also USA.
Da, wo sie noch denken, wo sie noch eine Marke über den Verkauf machen können.
Da, wo sie ein großes Interesse daran haben, dass die Leute sich das kaufen, damit sie ihre Filme mieten. Und das bieten sie ja in Deutschland so noch nicht an. Wird sicherlich irgendwann kommen. Das Wann, was weiß ich, steht in den Sternen. Fände ich übrigens auch ganz interessant, weil so mein Filmkonsum ist eh sehr reduziert. Und die Möglichkeiten, sich mal in Ruhe mal einen Film anzuschauen, sind immer sehr, wie soll ich sagen, sehr begrenzt. Und dann muss man sich immer ganz schnell entscheiden. Und dann ist natürlich so ein Download-System echt cool.
Der fängt, man kann schon während der Download noch läuft, kann man sich schon anfangt anzugucken, oder?
Soweit ich das erinnere, geht das.
Das ist natürlich schon sehr schick. Also ich plane ja an einer relativ ähnlichen Lösung wie du, aber komplett auf Open Source basierend nach Möglichkeit. Also ich will mir, also Augenblick, mein aktuelles Setup ist irgendein Aldi-Fernseher, der zu Hause noch rumsteht.
Aldi-Fernseher?
Den hab ich irgendwann mal bei Aldi gekauft, weil er silbern war.
Echt, du kostest Fernseher bei Aldi?
Ja, weil er war billig und hatte eine große Bildröhre und ist so echt okay. Und Röhre. Röhre, richtig, richtig alt und damals auch ein Schnäppchen und so und der ist 6, 7 Jahre, ist ja mindestens schon alt. Und da hab ich eine Xbox dranhängen, eine gehackte und zwar eine alte Xbox.
Ist das nicht ein bisschen laut?
Man muss halt Actionfilme gucken. Nee, es geht, es ist echt, es ist echt, es ist erträglich. Also die steht ganz...
Oh, guckst du wieder den Dampferfilm?
Und da hab ich ein alternatives Dashboard drauf und das ist in der Lage, im Gegensatz zum Original Dashboard, nämlich den Lüfter runter zu regeln. Dashboard? Dashboard ist quasi das Programm bei der Xbox, nicht die Firmware, so quasi das Betriebssystem. Und dieses Software, das da drauf läuft, heißt XBMC, was mal stand für Xbox Media Center. Absolut nichts Offizielles ist. Und das ist einfach die, wie ich finde nach wie vor, geilste Software zum Anzeigen von, also die geilste Media Center Software überhaupt. Spielt jedes Format ab, was man draufspeist, spielt...
Aber man muss das alles noch so selber drauf kopieren und so. Es gibt da keine...
Und sich vorher seinen Chip moden lassen.
Keine Quelle.
Also Chip moden muss man nicht, weil es gibt ja ein Software Hack für die Xbox. Und die haben jetzt aber ihr System umgestellt und haben irgendwann mal mitgekriegt, Moment mal, die Leute kaufen keine Xboxen mehr, weil die dann schon lange nicht mehr hergestellt. Und haben das Ganze irgendwann mal angefangen zu portieren unter dem Namen XBMC auf Linux. Und dann ist ihnen aufgefallen, wenn wir hier schon auf Linux sind, dann ist Mac OS eigentlich ein ganz, ganz kleiner Schritt. Und Windows ist auch nicht mehr so weit. Das heißt, es gibt es jetzt für alle Betriebssysteme so weit. Ist steuerbar über Apple Remote und schmeißt man einfach drauf. Startet und ist glücklich. Und es gibt eine installierbare Live-CD mit Linux drauf. Das heißt, man lädt sich so ein Linux ISO-Image runter, installiert das und hat sein wirklich sehr, sehr schickes Media Center drauflaufen.
Aber man hat immer noch keine Content-Quellen.
Man hat immer noch keine legalen Content-Quellen. Da muss man sich dann halt was überlegen.
Aber alle anderen Probleme sind gelöst. Zum Angucken, aber es würde gehen.
Ich würde nicht sagen, dass es da nichts zum Angucken gibt, aber egal. Auf jeden Fall ist das also, wer MP3s hat und wer schön die ganzen als M4V vorliegen, wer zum Beispiel Mobile Macs gerne hören möchte über Xbox oder den... Es gibt ja auch vielen Freien. Es gibt auch ein YouTube-Plugin dafür.
Mobile Macs liegt da als M4V vor? Das wäre mir neu. Ich wäre ja mal ganz froh, wenn es mal als M4A vorliegen könnte. Wolltest du mir nicht mal so ein Plugin ins Internet... Ich werde jetzt mal anfangen, dich on Air dran zu erinnern.
Solange ich nicht auf der Straße angesprochen habe, deswegen...
Und zwar habe ich gehört, dass die neue Version 2.3 von dem Apple TV auch jetzt fremde Fernbedienungen lernen kann.
Was?
Stimmt.
Also stimmt, habe ich auch gehört. Sie lernen?
Wenn du irgendeine Fernseher-Fernbedienung hast, dann kannst du das programmieren. Du kannst dann auf dein Fernseher, auf den Channel-Button drücken oder was auch immer, dass dein Apple TV darauf reagiert.
Was natürlich sehr cool ist, weil dann...
Du kannst ein bisschen Fernbedienung sparen. Vor allem haben die Apple Fernbedienungen, die ist wirklich ein bisschen sehr minimal.
Die sind ein bisschen sehr minimal. Man möchte ja nicht immer so ein komplettes Setup von Fernbedienungen haben. Viele Leute haben ja auch so spezielle Combo-Fernbedienungen. Du kannst ja bei Konrad dir da gleich solche Schiffe kaufen, wo du alle möglichen Umschalter hast.
Außerdem muss man sagen, dass die Apple-Fernbedienung ist ja dazu geneigt, gerade wenn man Kinder hat, schnell zu verschwinden. Schnell zu verschlucken.
Ja, bleiben wir bei den Updates. Auf dem Mac. Wir reden ja viel über den Mac. Ach, diesmal, ne? Finde ich ja gut. iTunes 8.0.2. Normalerweise würde ich dem ja keine nennenswerte Aufmerksamkeit entgegenbringen. Aber warum ich das erwähne, ist, man kann jetzt endlich mit der Tastatur durch die Dialoge gehen, wie sich das gehört. Ich dachte ja, diese Software wird das nie lernen. Aber offensichtlich machen sie jetzt total auf Accessibility.
Das macht mich ein bisschen wundert.
Naja, das ist halt der Markt von Leuten, die das brauchen, der ist nicht klein.
Na, ich hätte gedacht, dass auch des iTunes mit Snow Leopard vielleicht als Cocoa irgendwie 64-Bit-Schnick-Schnack rauskommt und sie dann schon ne Menge neu machen müssen und sich dann dieses Feature auch gleich an das Neue einbauen und an eine Altenwechslung ganz viel... Du meinst, das ist jetzt Cocoa, glaub ich ja nicht.
In Teilen? Ich sag nicht, dass das so ist. Ich sag nur, dass es so sein könnte. Tatsache ist, dass ich jetzt das User-Interface nicht mehr so verhält wie noch vor kurzem, wo du halt einfach nicht mit... Also ich gehöre zu den Leuten, wenn ich einen neuen Mac aufsetze, einen neuen Account aufsetze, das erste, was ich einschalte, ist Keyboard Navigation. Dass ich halt mit Tab und Kursor und so weiter durch alle Elemente durchgehen kann. Also nicht nur durch Textfelder, sondern eben auch durch Tabs und Buttons und so weiter. Und ich benutze einfach meinen Mac die ganze Zeit mit der Tastatur. Ich klicke zwar auch mal mit der Maus irgendwelche Buttons an, aber so es sich vermeiden lässt, tue ich es eigentlich nicht. Und bei iTunes bin ich halt jedes Mal gegen eine Wand gelaufen. So, und dann musste ich dann die Maus bedienen. Und das fand ich schon eine echte Zumutung. Und das haben sie jetzt irgendwie gefixt. Habe ich noch nicht zu viel benutzt, aber so meine ersten Tests waren irgendwie ganz okay. Und dann gab es noch irgendwie so einen Bug-Fix mit dem MP3.
Ja, da gibt es ja diese Hydrogen-Audio, die irgendwie so MP3-Tests machen und die meinten dann so als Zusatzkommentar, dass sie wohl einen Bug in iTunes gefunden hat, in der 8er-Version und auch schon seit vielen, seit Version 5 oder so, wäre er wohl da drin. Sie haben ein bisschen umgetestet. Und zwar, dass die Bitrate, die man einstellt von Dual-Code oder Multiprozessor-System, auf den iTunes läuft, nicht eingehalten wird. Also, dass da irgendwie weniger rauskommt. Also nicht, dass schlecht entkodet ist, sondern einfach nur mit ein bisschen weniger als angegeben. Und sie hätten auch Apple Bescheid gesagt. Und Apple hätte auch gesagt, dass sie den Bug sofort und schnell fixen. Und dann kam auch eine Woche später nach diesem Bericht kam auch das 801 oder 802, wo dann ja auch drin stand, dass sie da einen Quality-Bug oder so für manche User gefixt haben. Ich weiß nicht, was Apple mit manche User meint, weil ich denke, Dual-QoA hat inzwischen doch ganz schön viele. Also ein Multiprocessor-System.
Das müssen sie natürlich fixen.
Ja, haben sie auch gemacht. Ich denke mal nicht, dass es ein wirklich schlimmes, also nicht, dass es schlechte Encodings rauskamen, sondern nur, wenn, weiß nicht, 128 angegeben hast, hat er vielleicht mit 120 gerechnet. Vielleicht irgendwie sowas. Ich bin mir nicht ganz so sicher, was das genau ist.
Wir wissen es nicht.
Ihr müsst nicht alles nochmal rippen, nehme ich mal an.
So, jetzt müssen wir aber langsam hier auch mal auf das unvermeidliche iPhone Thema kommen.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, wenn wir bei iTunes sind, dann, es hat doch einen Grund gegeben, warum die neue iTunes-Version rausgekommen ist.
Genau. Also auch eine neue Firmware gab.
Für deins vielleicht.
Ja.
Für meins auch.
Für deins nicht?
Wieso? Was?
Natürlich. Alle haben das. Hallo?
Warte, wie, wie? Firmware oder Software? Also Firmware, also Spaceband ist nur bei dem 3G neu gekommen.
iPhone Software.
Er hat gesagt, neue Software und auch noch eine neue Firmware. Also ich meine, also deswegen.
Was hab ich das gesagt?
Ich hab's nicht verstanden.
Ist egal.
Ich weiß nicht.
Also auf jeden Fall sprechen wir von der...
Wir wissen, wovon wir reden.
Von iPhone 2.
Ist ja nun auch keine wirklich neue Nachricht. Aber sie haben, also ich hab so langsam den Eindruck, dass Steve Jobs es sich mit mir nicht so ohne weiteres verscherzen möchte. Ja. Er hat schon auch mal... Er hört zu, glaube ich.
Genau, der hat extra wegen uns Deutsch gelernt. Hallo Steve.
Hi Steve. Sie haben im Podcasting-Bereich ein paar Bugfixes gemacht. Ein paar. Aber ein paar Sachen haben sie auch noch nicht so richtig gemacht. Aber ich finde die neuen Features, finde ich geil. Darauf wollte ich auch noch mal zusprechen kommen.
Das sind jetzt nicht so unglaublich viele neue, oder?
Naja, ich finde das ist schon ein bold move. Also in der Abteilung kleine Bugfixes sind erst mal so Sachen wie, dass die Episodenliste, wenn du jetzt einen Podcast auflistest, du hast mehrere Episoden, dann war das bisher sinnloserweise so sortiert, dass der neueste Podcast oben war.
Ja.
Und da sie ja immer noch, das haben sie leider nicht gefixt, das muss ich dahin mal dazusagen, dass das immer noch der Kernfuck-Up ist überhaupt. Wenn du Podcast auswählst, den ersten und machst Play, dann spielt der einfach Episode auf Episode auf Episode. Übrigens anders als in iTunes.
Das finde ich total nervig.
Spielst du eine Episode, dann spielt der nur diese Episode und dann ist Schluss. Und so muss das auch sein. Und so war das auch beim iPod.
Ja, es gibt welche, da ist das ganz schick, wenn die hintereinander kommen, aber dann sollte man es einstellen können oder irgendwie sowas.
Genau, dann möchte ich das gerne einstellen können. Die einzige Möglichkeit zu verhindern, dass er einem gleich in den nächsten iPod springt, die ich gefunden habe, ist... Was hab ich gesagt?
In den nächsten iPod springt.
In die nächste Episode springt. Du hast ja auch beim Abspielen von Podcasts, was ich irgendwie Quatsch finde, auch noch diese Möglichkeit, diese Repeat-Sachen und random noch anzustellen, wie bei Musik. Also das ist überhaupt das Grundübel ist, dass einfach das iPhone, wie auch der iPod an vielen Stellen, bei Podcasts einfach genau dieselbe Denkantaktik wie bei Musik. Das macht aber einfach keinen Sinn. Radiosendungen hört man einfach anders als Musik. Ich will nicht Radiosendungen im Shuffle-Modus hören.
Na, es gibt ja auch Musik-Podcasts. Oder in einer Wiederholung.
Oder Repeat. Ich meine, was soll denn das Repeat? Hörst du dir irgendwie die Tagesthemen im Repeat- oder im Shuffle-Modus an?
Ja klar, ich steh total auf Anne Will. Ach, die macht das ja gar nicht mehr.
Naja, verstehst du, das ist einfach Blödsinn. Also Sendung, zwei Stunden, ich meine, du hörst ja nicht. Mobile Macs oder was weiß ich und machst dann Shuffle und dann irgendwie ach, vielleicht hab ich jetzt rein zufällig noch irgendeiner. Das macht man einfach nicht. Sondern man weiß, was man hören will. Man spielt es an und dann will man nur das hören. Und wenn man halt abends im Bett liegt und eingeschlafen ist, dann will man nicht, dass das iPhone dann noch alle anderen Episoden, die noch schön als ungedesen markiert waren, noch durchspielt, bis man morgens aufwacht. Sondern er soll natürlich nur die... Und man kann sich anschauen. Die einzige Möglichkeit, das zu verhindern, ist, dass du auf Single Repeat schaltest.
Und dann spielt das wieder von vorne los.
Ja, dann spielt er halt zumindest diesen einen immer wieder. Und das macht er auch noch so bekloppt, dass wenn du zum Beispiel eine Podcast-Episode erstmal nur eine halbe Stunde gehört hast, dann merkt er sich ja, bis wohin du es gehört hast. Tolles Feature. Dann willst du den Rest hören. Jetzt machst du dieses Single-Repeat an. Dann spielt er, sagen wir mal, das Ding dauert eine Stunde. Spielt er jetzt wieder eine halbe Stunde, bis er zum Ende ist. Dann würde er normalerweise in die nächste Episode springen, was doof ist. Also mache ich Single-Repeat an. Was macht er dann? Dann springt er wieder zu dieser schon gehörten halben Stunde. Also er repeatet sozusagen auch nur das, was ich gerade... Erst wenn ich da aus diesem Menü rausgehe, wieder reingehe, setzt er diesen...
Das heißt, du kannst quasi mit ein bisschen Trickserei auf dem iPhone Loops definieren.
Das ist wirklich krank. Es ist einfach...
Ich verstehe einfach nicht, wie...
Mir versagt das Hirn.
Wie kann man auf so einen Scheiß kommen?
Das ist doch wirklich total bekloppt.
Und ist es jetzt in 2.2. immer noch oder gefixt?
So ist das jetzt in 2.2. Es ist ein bisschen besser, weil du zumindest die Episoden in der chronologischen Reihenfolge hörst. Ja, das mussten sie machen. Das haben sie gemacht, aber es ist immer noch so ein Playlist-Verhalten. Aber ich bitte dich, ein Podcast, ein gewisser Podcast, ist keine Playlist.
Man kann ja aber jetzt übers WLAN runterladen und muss den nicht immer an seinen Rechner anschließen.
Genau, das wollte ich ja gerade mal drauf eingehen.
Da muss ich aber sagen, Miraculpa Tim, wir hatten ja über dieses Podcast-Programm gesprochen und du hast ja gesagt so, hm hm hm.
Wer sagt dir eigentlich, dass sie daran nicht arbeiten?
Wer arbeitet? Was ich nicht gedacht hätte, ich dachte, dass sie einfach nur ein Podcast-Feature implementieren wollen, aber sie haben auch einen Scheiß-Podcast-Feature implementiert, genau wie das Original. Weil diese Lösung ist ja wohl wirklich mal grottig. Ich dachte, wenn die so was einbauen, dass man entweder das Ding automatisch einmal die Nacht einwählt und guckt, ob neue Podcasts da sind, über WLAN, oder dass ich einen Button habe, wo ich drauf klicke, lad mir alle neuen Podcasts runter. Wie ist es?
Es ist so, und ich sag dir auch gleich, was ich davon halte. Ich hab mir das wirklich in Ruhe angeschaut, weil mich das natürlich sehr interessiert. Also, erstmal das Feature, was neu dazugekommen ist, Podcasts sind jetzt auch in der iTunes-Applikation auf dem iPhone sichtbar. Das heißt, dieses Podcast-Directory von iTunes, was man ja schon seit Jahr und Tag in iTunes durchstöbern kann und wo man halt auch sich Podcasts raussuchen kann und abonnieren kann, ist jetzt auch über das iPhone zugänglich.
Auch Videopodcasts?
Auch Videopodcasts. Alle. Alles, was im Podcast-Directory ist, siehst du dort. Das heißt, du kannst danach suchen und dann findest du die Podcast. Und dann kriegst du eben, wie in iTunes auch, eine Episodendiste und du kannst dann an der Stelle zweierlei machen. Du kannst eine Episode direkt abspielen. Du kannst draufklicken, will ich jetzt sofort hören. Das heißt, du hast so einen Instant-Play-Modus. Irgendjemand sagt dir ja, hier, hör dir doch mal diese Episode an. Blablabla, dann suchst du dir den Podcast, gehst durch die Episodendiste durch, klickst da drauf und dann, wie er halt auch so ein Stream von einer Webseite macht, lädt er sich immer so ein bisschen was, spielt das ab. So, und da, das geht auch über UMTS. Also auch, wenn du nur im Funk unterwegs bist, ohne WLAN. Doch, das geht auch im UMTS.
Unter der Bedingung, dass?
Welcher?
Dass die Datei nicht größer als 10 Megabyte ist.
Nein, das ist unbeschränkt.
Ach so, das ist echt? Ah, okay.
Das ist dann genau der Unterschied. Es gibt außerdem noch die Möglichkeit zu sagen, diese Episode möchte ich vollständig herunterladen. Und da gibt es diese Beschränkung. Wenn die Episode größer als 10 Megabyte ist, dann macht ihr das nur über WLAN. Der Punkt ist, der beim Streaming, also was weiß ich, was da jetzt ihre interne Argumentation ist. Ich denke einfach mal, dem geht es darum, dass sie keine Stresslast auf UMTS legen wollen. Auf die 3G-Netze. Stresslast im Sinne von 100 Megabyte Download, klack, volle Power. Das iPhone lebt wirklich verdammt schnell.
Irgendwelche Lizenzverträge, dass wir gesagt haben, Downloads dürfen nur maximal so und so groß sein.
Das ist sicherlich ein Deal, den sie mit den Betreibern haben. Da bin ich mir ganz sicher. Bei Apple könnte es eigentlich ziemlich egal sein. Ich meine, die Daten kommen oder nicht.
Es wäre auch nicht so verkehrt, wenn man als Gerät auch ein bisschen Rücksicht auf die Infrastruktur nimmt. Wenn alle losballern, obwohl sie sich gar nicht anhören. Ich meine, wie viele Sendungen werden von iTunes runtergeladen, die nie gehört werden? Es sind bestimmt einige.
Aber es gibt ja hier keinen, wie Max ja schon richtig gesagt hat. Was sie nicht gemacht haben, ist die Möglichkeit zu abonnieren. Ich will mal kurz beschreiben, wie es funktioniert. Dann sage ich auch, warum ich das für eine gute Idee halte. Du kannst also jetzt dir Episoden runterladen. Und in dem Moment, wo du das machst, taucht der Podcast als solcher, zu dem diese Episode gehört, auf dem iPhone in der Liste der Podcasts auf. Und wenn du dann das nächste Mal mit deinem iTunes synchronisierst, wird diese Episode auch in dein iTunes zurück synchronisiert. Und auch dort taucht dann der Podcast als solcher auf.
So wie die Applikation.
Ist aber noch nicht abonniert. Du kannst aber dann in iTunes, da ist natürlich der Button dahinter, sagen, möchte ich abonnieren. Mit anderen Worten, du kannst auf das Direktorit zugreifen, du kannst Episoden sofort hören, du kannst Episoden vollständig runterladen und hören. Und du synchronisierst das, was du geladen hast, auch von bereits abonnierten Podcasts zurück zu iTunes. Und kriegst dann in deiner, sozusagen in der Umgebung, wo du das Abonnieren gewohnt bist, die Möglichkeit, diesen neu entdeckten Podcast dann auch zu abonnieren. Aber du abonnierst ihn nicht dadurch automatisch. Und ich finde, das ist eine relativ coole Lösung für dieses Problem. Du sagst ja, ich will aber jetzt auch gleich wieder so kommen, das ist das Feature, was du vorhin auf jeden Fall haben wolltest, willst du gleich das nächste. Du willst halt abonnieren. Aber dann haben sie das Problem, dass eben zwei Geräte sozusagen diese ganze Abonnement-Geschichte machen wollen. Dann müsstest du auf dem iPhone auch noch fein konfigurieren, wie häufig er das jetzt checkt und wie viele Episoden er behalten soll und so. Also das ist etwas, was sie auf diesem Gerät so erstmal nicht sehen.
Also was ich gerne haben möchte, ist, dass ich, wenn ich irgendwo unterwegs bin und ich sitze beim Arzt oder ich sitze im festgesetzten Fahrstuhl oder ich sitze im Flugzeug und hab das Gefühl, ich würde gerne mal wieder einen Postcast hören, dass ich dann nicht feststelle...
Also einen festgesetzten Fahrstuhl, das solltest du ein bisschen Batterie sparen.
Der braucht Litantenlampe.
Das ist mir einfach zu konstruiert. Ich finde, dass sie da einfach eine gute Abwägung getroffen haben.
Nee, ich finde das überhaupt nicht konstruiert. Mir passiert das regelmäßig, dass ich irgendwo sitze. Ich möchte mich nicht darum kümmern, dass ich jetzt, bevor ich losfahre, dran denke, dass ich die Podcast runterlade, wie ich es im Augenblick machen muss, indem ich es noch mal mit iTunes synchronisiere.
Aber du kannst doch live direkt in einen reinhören.
Das ist doch nicht so schlimm. Du kannst sie auch runterladen.
Ach so, ich habe ja noch das alte Telefon.
Du kannst sie runterladen, du kannst die Seife anhören, du kannst das alles tun.
Und das mit dem Flugzeug war tatsächlich, hatte ich ja gerade erst.
Was ist denn das Problem, dass du kein UMTS hast?
Über GPS kannst du das knicken, glaube ich.
Na gut, aber das Problem ist gelöst, kauf dir ein neues iPhone. Wenn das dein Problem ist, kauf dir ein neues Gerät.
Das würde auch mit dem alten Telefon gehen, man muss dazu sagen, wir haben halt so Unlocked aus Amerika, wir haben halt irgendwie nur GPS und wir haben nicht mal Edge, weil wir nicht bei der Telefon sind.
Ja, aber das würde die Infrastruktur nicht so belasten. Dann würde ich das nämlich über mein eigenes WLAN machen und nicht über das öffentliche Telekom.
Ich will noch kurz die negativen Sachen sagen. Was sie jetzt überhaupt nicht auf die Reihe kriegen, ist, sie sind einfach nicht in der Lage, Podcasttitel richtig anzuzeigen. Sie zeigen die ersten 30 Zeichen an, die bei den meisten Podcastern erst mal mit dem Titel des Podcasts gefüllt sind, bevor sie dann eigentlich auf ihren Text kommen. Das heißt, du kannst einfach überhaupt auf dem iPhone überhaupt nicht sehen, worum sich eine Episode dreht. Da ist der Titel zu lang. Ich meine, das hat doch der alte iPod schon hingekriegt. Da hat der Text einfach gescrollt. Ich meine, sie haben noch den Platz. Sie verbrauchen da einen riesen Platz. Da ist alles weiß. Sie bestehen auf einer Zeile. Warum machen sie es nicht zweizeitig? Warum scrollen sie es nicht? Warum kann ich es nicht antippen und dann zeigt er mir ein größeres Infofenster, wo alles steht, mit der Beschreibung der Episoden.
Das ist total ätzend.
Das ist wirklich scheiße. Es ist so, dass es bei nahezu allen Podcasts, die ich abonniert habe, nicht zu vertragen ist. Es ist generell unbenutzbar und ohne Not. Und diese andere Eigenschaft, dass sie nämlich den Autor in einer Episode, also wenn ich eine Episode poste und ich trage einen Author mit ein in den Feed für die Episode und sage hier, bei uns steht dann hier Tim Brüttler, Dennis Ahrens usw. Dann ist das auf einmal ganz groß und der Titel ist ganz klein. Da hab ich mich schon von Anfang an drüber geärgert und ein bisschen gewundert, was sie dazu getrieben hat. Jetzt hab ich herausgefunden, muss ich unseren Feed unter Umständen nochmal beibringen, wenn man das weglässt für die Episode, also wenn man nicht explizit bei der Episode auch nochmal die Autoren angibt, dann zeigt er die halt auch nicht an und dann wird der Titel groß. Sie sagen wohl so, wenn der Autor angegeben wird, dann ist das wohl auch wichtig. Das ist eine neue Situation, da muss ich noch mal ein bisschen über nachdenken und gegebenenfalls unseren Feed nochmal anpassen. Das ist nämlich so doof nicht gedacht. Na ja, also im Großen und Ganzen ein großer Fortschritt, aber noch nicht alles gefixt.
Okay, dann listen wir noch ein bisschen mehr neues Zeug. Wobei, das habt ihr auch schon drei Wochen alt.
Drei Wochen ist noch nicht alt, oder?
Ja, dann zwei halt. Also wie gesagt, das gibt es schon eine Weile.
Das gibt es schon ein bisschen. Ich hab seit Sonntag drauf erst.
Maps wird natürlich dann interessant, wenn Berlin endlich mal Street View kriegt.
Also es gibt Street View, wenn man irgendwo in Amerika ist und wo es Street View gibt, kann man das nutzen.
In Paris gibt es das auch schon. Das hab ich noch nicht mal probiert bisher.
Das sieht echt ganz hübsch aus. Also es ist ein bisschen umständlich zu bedienen. Dann muss man einen Pin setzen an der Stelle, wo man gerne Street View hätte, wenn man nicht die Adresse gesucht hat explizit. Und dann hat man dann so ein kleines Street View-Eiken, was natürlich nicht ganz so original aussieht wie bei Google, sondern offensichtlich von einem Apple-Designer gemacht wurde. Und dann kann man diesen Street View-Modus umschalten und der ist echt sexy, das muss man sagen. Der ist wirklich hübsch gemacht.
Der ist wirklich gelungen.
Also der lädt relativ flott, er dreht sich schnell, er ist besser als dieses Flaschgewürge, was man bei Google Maps sieht. Der ist echt niedlich gemacht und man hat diese Radar-Anzeige unten. Man hat unten rechts, glaube ich, hat man so ein...
Das Schöne ist, da ist halt keine Flasche auf dem Telefon, die müssen alles in ordentlich schnellem Code machen.
Street View ist ja auch überarbeitet worden innerhalb von Google Maps, das ist jetzt schon aufgefallen.
Ach so, das hab ich dann noch gar nicht gesehen.
Also sie haben auch Maps geändert, Google hat Maps geändert und Street View ist auch besser geworden.
Also auf jeden Fall sieht man so einen kleinen Radar, quasi radarähnlichen Ausschnitt noch unten drinnen, wo man hin und gerade guckt und sowas. Das ist echt ganz niedlich gemacht.
Ich finde das auch sehr gelungen. Also ich meine, ihre Philosophie mit diesem Ding ist so, du suchst halt nach einer Adresse und dann willst du da nochmal genau schauen und dann zeigen sie dir an, da gibt es Street Viewer. Das ist jetzt nicht so Explorer-mäßig. Übrigens ist es auch bei Google Maps jetzt ein bisschen anders. Vorher war es ja so, du gehst auf Street Viewer, dann ist gleich alles blau. Und dann ziehst du da dein Männchen hin und guckst. Sondern jetzt ist es so, dass links das Männchen nur dann überhaupt angeht, wenn irgendwo was ist. Und dann musst du das Männchen halt mal überlegen, runterdraggen und in dem Moment, wo du dragst, dann erscheinen erst die blauen Linien. Also auch da ist es so ein bisschen, dass diese Information verspätet kommt.
Also es wird so ein bisschen darauf eingestellt, als ob es das überall geben würde, mach ich so das Gefühl. Also als ob man eigentlich davon ausgehen sollte, das existiert schon und nicht so wie unsere Situation in Europa ist.
Überall, denke ich mal, da sind wir noch weit von entfernt. Aber in den Städten, ja. Ich denke, Europa werden sie auch relativ bald abdecken.
Was ich ja bei den Karten, denke ich, viel, viel schicker finde, oder nicht schicker, sondern lebensnotwendiger, lebenspraktischer ist, dass man endlich einen Fußgängermodus hat für die Verbindungssuche, für die Navigation. Dass man nicht nur als Auto navigieren kann, sondern auch als Fußgänger. Und dass, wenn es die Möglichkeit gibt, da macht ja die BVG nun dummerweise mal wieder nicht mit, würde mich ihn verwundern, wenn sie so bald dabei sind.
Hafer's muss mitziehen.
Genau, dass die Daten mit eingeliefert werden, dass man direkt eine Streckenverbindung gleich empfohlen kriegt. Und da steigst du in die S-Bahn und fährst erstmal ein paar Stationen mit der S-Bahn. Das würde ich ein tolles Feature finden, weil diese Navigationsfunktion vom iPhone nutze ich wirklich gerne. Gerade in fremden Städten, wo ich mich nicht auskenne. iPhone rausholen, Strecke suchen, fertig. Und wenn ich da noch in Zukunft dann mitgeteilt kriege und da steigst du jetzt in die Straßenbahn, kaufst für 3,80 Euro ein Ticket und steigst da wieder aus, dann bin ich, bis auf das Ticket, zufrieden.
Ja, es ist diese, ich glaube, das heißt Google Traffic oder so?
Google Traffic ist doch mal was anderes, oder? Google Traffic ist doch, dass er in Amerika anzeigt, auf welchen Strecken gerade Stau ist. Also genau das Gegenteil von Personennahverkehr.
Achso, nein, wie heißt er das? Nicht Traffic.
Ich weiß aber nicht, wie es heißt, um ehrlich zu sein. Ich glaube, das war geraten, oder?
Transit. Google Transit heißt das. Das ist halt ihre XML-Spezifikation, die sie mal rausgehauen haben. Das heißt, jeder Verkehrsverbund, der seine Daten in diesem Format bereitstellt, das saugt sich Google gerne rein. Wenn man sich das anschaut auf google.com/transit, da gibt es dann auch in Europa schon so einiges. Also der ÖBB macht zum Beispiel mit in Österreich. Also Österreich, da funktioniert das jetzt mit dem iPhone-Update auch schon. Also du kannst in Österreich tatsächlich dir... Kannst sagen, ich will von da nach da und hast auch die Option zu sagen, wie ist das, wenn ich mit dem ÖBB fahre?
Gibt es keinen Grund mehr nachts um 3 mit 70 durch die Ortschaft zu fahren und dann gegen die Wand zu knallen?
In der Schweiz auch. Also SBB und VBZ, ich weiß nicht, ob es da noch andere Relevante gibt.
Beim SBB gibt es ja sogar so schicke Karten im Netz, wo man sich auf Google Maps live einblenden lassen kann, wo alle Züge gerade sind.
Nein.
Ja, das ist richtig schick.
Wie cool.
Ich muss jetzt mal die URL raussuchen.
Willkommen im 21.
Ja, wer hat's erfunden? Naja, also Deutschland, ich weiß es nicht, wo es da hängt. Ich schätze mal, da wird sicherlich geredet, aber ich habe keine Ahnung, wann das kommt. Aber hier, die Liste ist ganz gut so. Ich meine, United States bin ich immer wieder überrascht, dass es überhaupt Public Transport gibt. Kanada ist dabei, wenn auch nicht Toronto, interessanterweise. In Asien natürlich Japan, Rail, Domestic Airlines, End Ferries, mit anderen Worten alles. Oh, Taiwan, steht hier alles nur in Chinesisch. Keine Ahnung, ein bisschen Australien, naja, hier und da, Polen. More is coming, denke ich mal. Ist auf jeden Fall hervorragend auch gemacht, die Integration, aber diese Fußgänger-Geschichte, das finde ich jetzt besonders gut.
Wir gucken ja gerade auf die Karte von Zürich und man kann hier alle Straßenbahnen sehen, wo die gerade sind und die bewegen sich live.
www.swisstrains.ch Schon ziemlich cool. Geil ist ja das Terror-Tool Nummer eins.
Es dauert nicht mehr lang und dann sagt das iPhone, geh mal zwei Schritte zurück, sonst wirst du von der Nichtleckung gefahren.
Nee, ich warte drauf, dass ich das erste Mal bei Twitter lese, so zwei, ne? Hey, ich bin gerade in der Leipziger Straße. Hey, ich bin auch in der Leipziger Straße.
Aua!
Das ist für Selbstmörder, damit die nicht so lange warten müssen, bis der Zug kommt. Naja, ich meine, und im Upstore? Ich hab davon nichts gelesen, dass so eine Applikation...
Bitte schubsen sie jetzt...
.als wahrscheinlich miscellaneous, was sie dann absehen.
Geld-zurück-Garantie.
Jungs, Development Opportunities. Development Opportunities. Unsere Kompressoren werden jetzt hier aus der Härteste getestet.
Keine Demo-Version anbieten.
Nee, nee. Haben wir noch Update-Bits?
Update-Bits?
Na, vor dem 2-2, da gab's schon noch mehr Sachen.
Gute Frage?
Du kannst ja mal eine Weile nachdenken, dann erzähl ich schon mal eins. Und zwar war es ja so, dass wenn man sein iPhone lockt, dass es vorher so war, dass man über den Emergency Call weiterhin normale Gespräche führen konnte. Was ja, wenn man sein Telefon verliert, dann wird halt eine Sexnummer angerufen, dann ist man danach pleite. Und das haben die in Amerika, also mit dem 2-2 Update haben die wohl gefixt, dort für deren Nummernsystem. Aber in Good Old Europe, oder zumindest in Germany, kann man weiterhin, wenn das Phone lockt ist, also mit diesem Passcode lockt, kann man weiterhin über den Emergency Call eine normale Nummer wählen. Also du kannst mit meinem Telefon telefonieren, obwohl es gelockt ist. Und das haben die nicht so richtig gefixt. Für Amerika anscheinend schon.
Was für ein Skandal.
Unglaublich. Ein bisschen schon, weil man muss schon ganz, ganz schnell anrufen, wenn das Telefon geklaut ist, um es sperren zu lassen, obwohl es eigentlich schon an sich gesperrt ist, damit die da keinen Schindluder fremden. Vielleicht sind die zu blöd und wissen das nicht. Aber der Deep hat halt gar nichts anderes an Benutzer-Interface als irgendwie Emergency Call.
Das ist auf meinem iPhone viel besser, weil ich hatte nämlich gar keinen Lock. Das heißt, er spielt erstmal mit dem ganzen Programm drauf rum. Und ruft nicht an. Und surft lieber mit Safari ein bisschen im Netz rum. Bei Safari gibt es ein paar kleine...
Im Ausland auf fremden Datentarif.
Safari hat sich auch ein bisschen geändert. Es stürzt nicht mehr ab. Safari stürzt nicht mehr ab?
Ich hatte, also kurz eine Woche bevor das rauskam, ich hatte eine Serie von Dauer abstürzen.
Ich erinnere mich an den zweiten Eintrag.
Ja, und zwar, dann hat mir jemand geraten, doch mal nicht nur History, Cache und was war das dritte, was man mal löschen könnte? Hab ich vergessen. Man kann also drei verschiedene Sachen löschen. Genau, Cookies natürlich. Hat ich natürlich gemacht, hat nichts gebracht, aber der Trick ist, dann noch mal gleich booten. Also, iPhone ausschalten, neu starten. Das hat dann tatsächlich ein paar Tage gehalten und dann ging es wieder los. Es war der Horror. Und jetzt? Kann ich mich nicht erinnern, seit dem 2.2. Update, dass mir der Browser überhaupt schon mal weggeflogen ist?
Also, mein Safari ist eigentlich so, also nicht übermäßig stabil, aber das war, man konnte echt okay mitsurfen. Die ganze Zeit über. Es stört sich dann ab, aber nicht wirklich.
Ja, keine Ahnung, also bei mir, ich kann jetzt nur sagen, vorher war es tendenziell richtig scheiße und jetzt ist es...
Tendenziell richtig gut.
Fels solide.
Also ich finde ja, was ja geändert wurde, ist oben diese Navigation, die sich jetzt...
Find ich scheiße.
Find ich auch nicht so doll. Also da ist ja, mit dem Google...
Vor allem, wenn du da draufklickst, wandert es so runter, damit es oben so einen kleinen Cancel irgendwie noch machen kann und der ganze Platz ist aber eigentlich verschwendet. Das hätten wir ein bisschen schicker machen können.
Den musst du eh einmal hin tippen.
Ja, aber es ist trotzdem...
Jetzt kannst du zumindest mit einem Tipp die Suche starten und vorher musstest du irgendwie oben ranklicken und dann nochmal tippen.
Nee, wieso? Du hattest doch vorher diesen Suchen-Button, wenn ich mich recht ankenne, oder? Du hattest einen Suchen-Button, hast du draufgetippt und dann warst du in der Suche.
Genau.
Eigentlich das bloß... Also was ich nervig finde...
Das ist wahrscheinlich das Feature, was keiner verstanden hat. Das hab ich auch so nicht benutzt. Aber es ist auch ein relativ kleines Ziel gewesen.
Man musste auf die Suche... Ja, aber jetzt find ich den Reload-Button so ein relativ kleines Ziel, weil da drückt man auch relativ leicht mal daneben. Da der Reload-Button ist jetzt da oben in der Adressleiste mit drinnen. Und das passiert mir relativ flott mal, dass ich da versehentlich in die Adressleiste gehe, obwohl ich eigentlich nur ein Reload machen wollte.
Ja, die Stelle find ich auch ein bisschen unglücklich. Das ist normal, dass da auch mal so der Ort ist, wo man so die URL löscht, und dann kommt man dann irgendwie schnell durcheinander.
Wo ich natürlich immer als Erstes nachgucke, als alter Edwin-Entwickler, ist, was hat sich dann an Safari, an der Sahood getan? Ich hoffe, ich hatte ja immer noch ein bisschen die Hoffnung, dass man auf die Location API bzw. auf die Fotos irgendwann mal zugreifen kann.
Auch auf diese Web App API. Gibt es auch spezielle Widget Features, die das Safari liefert? Für Widget Programmierer. Edwin ist doch ein Widget, oder?
Edwin ist eine geschnitten normale Webseite.
Es hat keinen Unterschied. Es ist eine Webseite.
Ein Widget kann eine Web App sein.
Diese Web App können auch spezielle Features benutzen.
Die im Dashboard? Für die Optik und so. Davon kann man schon relativ viele nutzen. Was es zum Beispiel seit 2.1 gab, war die Möglichkeit, dass wenn ich eine Webseite als Abspeicher auf dem Springboard, als Icon, wenn ich dann das Icon anklicke, ich keine Navigation mehr habe. Damit das ein bisschen nativ applikationiger wird. Man konnte Touchless auswerten. Das ist jetzt alles ein bisschen hübscher geworden. Und es gibt jetzt die Möglichkeit, nachdem ich aufwendig eine Technik dafür ausgedacht hatte, dass man eine sogenannte Manifest-Datei definieren kann. Und dass dann die Applikation lokal auf dem Icon gecached wird und nicht mehr jedes Mal neu geladen wird. Das heißt, ich kann dann unter Umständen Web-Applikationen in Zukunft hoffentlich offline nutzen. Ich habe leider noch nicht 100% rausgekriegt, wie es funktioniert, weil die Dokumentation von Apple zwar vorhanden, aber sehr, sehr spärlich ist. Aber prinzipiell ist das ein sehr schönes Feature, dass Web-Applikationen in Zukunft auf dem Icon quasi auch offline funktionieren können. Und das ist natürlich immer noch ein ganz, ganz wichtiger Punkt gewesen, der für eine native Applikation gesprochen hat.
Oh ja, das finde ich auch gut. Dann kann man endlich die Autokorrektur abschalten, habe ich aber trotzdem nicht gemacht, weil sie ist nämlich nebenbei auch besser geworden.
Ich bin ein Freund der Autokorrektur.
Ich eigentlich meistens.
Ich habe sie erst mal abgeschaltet, obwohl ich vorher... ne doch, die hat mich schon genervt.
Die war voll krank.
Also ich hätte gerne, dass sie andersrum funktioniert. Ich will gerne klicken, wenn ich den Vorschlag gut finde und nicht andersrum. Dann wäre es okay.
Das hätte ich gerne konfigurierbar. Aber das kann ich auch verstehen, dass sie sowas nicht...
Also an der Autokorrektur erst mal sind nach wie vor Wörter vorgeschlagen, die einfach mal komplett am Bullshit sind.
Ja, die ist nicht gut. Das verstehe ich auch überhaupt nicht, wo sie das hernehmen.
Ich warte da noch ein bisschen mit der Autokorrektur.
Ich glaube, das ist komisch. Die kaufen ihre Adressküche an den falschen Stellen.
Ich bin mir nicht so sicher, ob das darauf... Ich glaube nicht, dass sie wirklich diese Worte in einer Liste haben. Sondern was ich glaube, ist, dass sie da eine...
Die haben davon gehört, dass es im Deutschen zusammengesetzte Wörter gibt.
Ja, das ist ein echtes Problem mit S einfügen und so weiter. Von daher gehen sie da unter Umständen algorithmisch ran, bloß geht ihnen der Algorithmus manchmal nach hinten los.
Ja, aber manchmal sind es auch einfach Wörter, das ist nichts zusammengesetztes, das ist gar nichts. Da steht dann Höck, Hingst und so weiter. Also so, mir fällt das natürlich auch nicht ein.
Und du hast auch schon recht, Dennis. Also dadurch, dass es sich, wenn du nichts dagegen tust, sich automatisch dazwischen schiebt, merkst du es einfach.
Und eventuell dann das gleich schon dazulernen, also in dem Augenblick, wo du tippst weiter, er nimmt es automatisch an, obwohl du gar nicht wolltest. Das lernt er dann sogar gleich, weil du hast es ja genommen und du löscht es zwar weg, um es zu korrigieren, weil du es gar nicht haben wolltest, aber vielleicht hat er es ja trotzdem schon gelernt und nimmt es nicht wieder raus. Und dann bringst du mir auch noch Shit bei. Also es geht gar nicht. Ist jetzt aber eine Vermutung. Aber ich hab es erstmal ausgeschaltet. Es ist auch schneller, vor allem, wenn man das Dictionary ausschaltet, weil der bremst nicht immer so zwischendurch.
Das ist natürlich ein interessanter Punkt.
Also das fand ich, bin mir nicht sicher. Vielleicht hat es auch grundsätzlich mit dem 2.2 Update zu tun.
Oh mein Gott, das ist mir auch gar nicht aufgefallen. Wenn ich SMS tippe, dann schlägt er mir tatsächlich SMS vor und nicht mehr AMS. Und sogar komplett groß geschrieben.
Eine wiederentdeckte Liebe.
Und wie viele Programme habt ihr so auf eurem iPhone? Hunderte, oder? Stimmt.
Ich hab viele. Ich wollte eigentlich auch vorher noch mal zusammenrechnen, wie viel Geld ich jetzt eigentlich schon ausgegeben habe, aber ich hatte dann leider die Zeit nicht.
Du hast doch bestimmt 50 oder 100 Programme, oder? So ein Screen hat wie viel? 20?
Ein Screen hat 16. Ich habe hier eins. Also anschließlich der vorinstallierten. Das wird glaube ich 8, ne?
Naja, die Seite ist voll, die erste.
Nee.
Klar.
Eins ist da unten vielleicht extra, aber fast voll. Also 14 sind es bestimmt.
Warte mal. Das kann man ja schnell rauskriegen, indem man hier den Wackel-Modus anmacht.
Also ich hab vorhin nur ein fremdes Programm.
2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13. 13 sind es glaube ich.
Also es sind 14 und da macht man Kontext dazu, weil Kontext ist normalerweise auf der nächsten Seite sind es 15. Und dann habe ich ein Fremdes und das sind 16.
Also eine Seite kommt sozusagen weg, dann zähle ich mal. Ich habe auch nicht alle ganz voll hier.
5, 6, 7, 8.
Also 8.
Und die letzte zählt einfach mal nicht, würde ich sagen.
Also um das mal ein bisschen zu beschleunigen, ca. 7 mal 16 pro Gramm, macht nach Adam Riese 100. 102 nicht, dass er dir Kommentare voll will.
Ich rechne das jetzt hier mal richtig aus.
Also ich hab solange 82.
Solange wollt ihr es gar nicht machen. Ihr habt auf jeden Fall reichlich Programme. Und das heißt, ihr habt bestimmt auch täglich und andauernd viele Apps. Was euch zugutekommen würde, ist, dass man jetzt Update All drücken kann. Weil ich hab ja nicht so viel, ich kann nicht noch eins.
Das ist total toll, dass man jetzt Update All endlich wieder hat. Das reimt sich sogar und darum ist es gut, dass man endlich wieder Update All tippen kann.
Was hat sich jetzt auf was gereimt?
Das ist toll, Update All. Und was natürlich auch ganz toll ist, wenn man so viele Programme hat und man ist gerade auf Seite 7, dann drückt man auf den Home-Button und man ist wieder vorne auf Seite 1.
Hast du eigentlich auch gewusst, dass man unten neben den Punkten drücken kann? Dass man gar nicht wippen muss, sondern neben den Punkten drücken kann?
Ich hab schon wieder so ein paar Spiele entdeckt, die mich total bannen.
Ich?
Hast du dir jetzt mal was gekauft, Dennis?
Ja, ein Seismometer, weil ich mal ein bisschen rumspielen wollte. Aber sonst noch nichts.
Ein Seismometer für so was langweiliges Kostüm?
Ja, voll doof war.
Also was ich mir gekauft hab für den Urlaub, das gibt es allerdings auch als freies Programm, hab ich mittlerweile festgestellt. Ich hab sagenhaft 80 Cent ausgegeben.
Aber ihr könnt mir gerne sagen, was richtig toll ist. Dann würd ich vielleicht auch mal eins kaufen.
Ja, wenn man mich dazwischen quatschen würde, dann würd ich das sagen.
Das muss doch dauern. Was ist denn die beste SSH-Version jetzt von den Vieren? Oder wie viel es auch mal inzwischen schon gibt?
Das kann ich dir nicht sicher sagen. Ich hab hier mal eine installiert, aber ich benutze die selten, was die... Also ich benutze nicht, ich habe installiert TouchTerm, was jüngst ein Update bekommen hat mit einem echt sinnvollen, coolen Feature, was dazu geführt hätte, dass ich das Programm mehr benutzt hätte, hätten sie nicht eine blöde Annahme gemacht. Das Feature ist, dass sie Screen unterstützen. Das heißt, du kannst dich connecten und dann ruft er automatisch Screen auf und du kannst dann sozusagen, wenn du das Programm beendest......
wieder reingehen und irgendwie das Screen auf.
Nur, dass sie aus irgendwelchen bekloppten Gründen es nicht konfigurierbar gemacht haben, wo er den Screen aufgerufen hat, muss in User Bin Screen sein. Jetzt hab ich aber da einen FreeBSD, wo es natürlich in User Local Bin ist.
Warum nicht einfach Screen auf? Dann sorgt man dafür, dass es dort, wo man hinspringt, im Fahrt liegt.
Du könntest aber einen Symbolik-Link anlegen.
Das könnten sie auch echt konfigurierbar machen. So einen Scheiß muss man konfigurierbar machen.
Also auf jeden Fall auf einem Steilhälter.
Ist auf jeden Fall bekloppt. Also wäre eigentlich eine tolle Idee gewesen. Aber ehrlich gesagt, naja.
Also ich nutze als iPad Railbreaker, benutze ich OpenSSH mit Terminal.
Aber es ist nicht so schlecht, weil die Verbindung wegbricht, dass man das weiter nutzen kann. Das ist ja schon mal gar nicht so doof. Das kann man auch selber machen, aber so.
Finde ich auch eine elegante Sache. Haben sie bloß ein bisschen bekloppt realisiert.
Also was ich hier nutze ist zum einen VFinder. Das ist die kostenlose Version und die kommerzielle Version, die allerdings heißt Wi-Fi Track. Das ist so ein Programm, mit dem kann man sich anzeigen lassen, welche WLANs existieren. So weit, so simpel. Was beide Programme machen, ist gucken, ob es offene Access Points gibt. Also man kann einstellen, dass sie z.B. alle 10 Sekunden nachgucken, alle 20 Sekunden nachgucken, ob irgendwelche WLANs vorhanden sind. Gucken, welche davon offen sind. Gucken, ob darüber klappt, versuchen sie sich darüber zu verbinden und eine Verbindung in Internet herzustellen. Und wenn das dann alles funktioniert und man sozusagen definitiv WLAN hat, dann pfeifen sie kurz oder vibrieren kurz. Was, wenn man in einer fremden Stadt rumrennt und keine bilden Roamingkosten haben will, wie ich es jetzt gerade hatte, relativ praktisch ist. Man sucht sich dann einfach erst einen Kaffee, setzt sich kurz hin, trinkt einen Kaffee und kann ein bisschen rumsurfen. Weil Kaffees mit offenem WLAN gibt es hier vielleicht, aber da noch nicht.
Worauf testet der, dass das WLAN kein Passwort hat oder lockt er sich auch automatisch ein und checkt schon mal, ob er eine App-Adresse kriegt?
Und ich glaube, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, probiert er sogar eine Webseite zu holen und kann, also dieses Wi-Fi-Track zumindest sogar sagen, ok, dann starte ich automatisch Mail, sobald ich eine WLAN-Verbindung habe, sodass dann eben Mail hoffentlich gleich mal als allererstes Check, ob neue Mails da sind.
Verstaunlich, dass die Programme so viel Kontrollmöglichkeit haben.
Das hat mich ehrlich gesagt auch gewundert. Das heißt, dass es ja dann auch irgendwann hier so WLAN-Hacker-Tools geben kann, oder?
Ich hab auf jeden Fall viele neue Anwendungsmöglichkeiten entdeckt hier für mein Gerät. Und auch ein paar wiederentdeckt. Zum Beispiel finde ich ja Einkaufslisten für toll. Es gibt also eine ganze Batterie von Programmen, die irgendwie Groceries und was weiß ich wie heißen, habe ich jetzt alle nicht getestet. Das Einzige, was ich habe, so Einkaufsliste, das war mir am Anfang ein bisschen zu dumm. Das hat jetzt allerdings ein Update bekommen, aber ich finde es seitdem etwas besser, weil es so Kategorien hat. Weil du willst halt irgendwie, wenn du in den Supermarkt gehst, möchtest du es halt gerne sortiert haben nach Gruppe. Dass du einfach, was weiß ich, zum Milchregal gehst, holst du einfach Joghurt und den ganzen Kram und so. Das geht jetzt. Da könnte ich mir aber auch ein cooleres Tool vorstellen. Ich hätte wirklich gerne etwas, wo ich auch die Barcode scannen kann, wo ich sagen kann, ich bin jetzt in dem Supermarkt, hier gibt es dieses Produkt, da kostet es so und so was, sodass ich einfach mir eine Einkaufsliste zusammenstellen kann und kann sagen, ich möchte jetzt gerne das kaufen und zwar so schnell wie möglich oder so billig wie möglich. Dass er mir dann sagt, wo ich hingehe und so. Das muss alles drin sein. GPS und so, wozu hat man den Scheiß? Ich meine, ich erwarte jetzt nicht, dass er mich ins richtige Regal führt, aber... Naja, das wird dann nicht so akkurat drin funktionieren. Ist ihr Supermarkt iPhone-kompatibel?
Was ich nicht kaufen kann, kann ich auch nicht bezahlen.
Da braut sich aber eine Marktmacht zusammen.
Nee, aber jetzt mal ehrlich, zum Beispiel so ein Riesenladen wie die Metro oder Ikea, da würde es sich schon lohnen, wenn sie ein bisschen GPS haben da.
Also ganz ehrlich, bei Starbucks in Amerika wird man doch bestimmt bald per iPhone bezahlen können. Dass man sich reinsetzt, seinen Namen anwirft.
Gibt es da nicht jedes Feature, so bei Starbucks?
GPS vielleicht nicht, aber sie könnten das mit WLAN machen. Dass sie einfach so Dummy-Netze posten, damit man da hier mit Skyhook-Wireless, die werden dann einmal im Monat eingeladen, mit ihren Wagen durch die Metro zu fahren.
Nee, die können die da selber hochschicken. Bei Starbucks gibt es auch so ein Programm, dass man gucken kann, also der weiß, in welchem Starbucks man ist, und listet dann die Musik, die gerade läuft, zeigt er automatisch an, und dann kann man gleich kaufen, klicken.
Genau, darum komme ich ja drauf, dass das wahrscheinlich bald gehen wird. Was ich für ein schönes Programm gefunden habe, ein kostenloses kleines Programm, das heißt Around Me, das zeigt einem an, was so in der Nähe ist.
Das hast du gefunden. Das ist der Top-Download seit Monaten.
Ernsthaft? Na gut, dann bin ich ein bisschen spät drauf gekommen. Also ich hab das beim Durchsuchen, ich hab das beim Durchsuchen, ich glaube, das ist Tim, der sich gerade am Hinterkopf kratzt.
Aber weiter.
Auf jeden Fall ist das eines, also es gibt einen Haufen solcher Programme, die Dinge aufzeilen, die in der Nähe sind, aber das zeigt auch was an, was in Deutschland in der Nähe ist und nicht nur in irgendwelchen, irgendwie in San Francisco oder so was. Und da kann ich mir zum Beispiel anzeigen lassen, wo die nächste deutsche Bank ist. Oder, ganz wichtig, der nächste Apple Retail Store, nämlich in Zürich.
Das kannst du bei Google Maps auch eintippen. Da tippst du bei Google Maps Postbank ein und dann zeigt der automatisch alle Postbanken in deiner Nähe.
Zum Beispiel oder Sparkasse. Naja, aber der zoomt dann aber auch schnell mal ganz weit nach draußen und dann hast du einen riesen Überblick, den du nicht haben willst.
Wenn in der Nähe keiner ist, schon.
Also ich hab mit dem Around Me auch schon ein paarmal versucht, was hinzukriegen, aber es hat echt viele, viele, viele Probleme. Ja. Also erstens, du suchst ein Café. Ist das jetzt eine Bar, ein Café oder ein Restaurant? Also du suchst eine Kneipe. Also du suchst irgendwie so einen Ort, wo es, was weiß ich, Nahrungsmittel gibt. Und dann weißt du einfach nicht, in was das kategorisiert ist. So. Und was mir viel mehr helfen würde, als dieses bekloppte, ich suche jetzt nach einer Apotheke und Ärzte sind zum Beispiel nicht drin, das finde ich ja immer wichtig, wäre ein, zeig mir mal, alles an, was du hier kennst, sortiert nach... Nach Entfernung. Manchmal suche ich gar nichts Besonderes, sondern ich will wissen, was gäbe es denn jetzt hier in der Umgebung, was ich mir vielleicht gerne anschauen wollen würde.
Ich nehme mir noch nicht sicher, ob ich dich in den Bein brechen will oder einen Kaffee haben will.
Oder Medikamente brauche. Nein, aber du weißt, was ich meine. Also ich will eigentlich mehr so exploren, ich möchte mehr so da so rangehen, weil dann kommt einem manchmal überhaupt auch erst auf die Ideen, also bei Geschäften jetzt. Man müsste es einschränken auf Business. Sag mal mal, was gibt es denn hier für ein Business? Und dann sagt einem der so, naja, 30 Meter von dir ist ein, was weiß ich, Videoverleih. Oder dann ist es S und M, Latex, Lederbude und so.
Und wenn sie schlau sind, gehen sie gleich nach der Uhrzeit.
Nur Unterhaltung, egal ob Swinger Club oder...
Zeigen Läden nicht an, die zum Beispiel gerade zu haben. Weil wenn du nachts fragst, was ist denn da näher, dann brauch er nix anzeigen, was sowieso schon geschlossen hat. Wie zum Beispiel die Tagesüber...
Ja, okay, es geht noch besser, aber ich find's immer besser.
Es geht immer besser. Ja, aber wir sind nie zufrieden, weil...
Aber wir können trotzdem den Status Quo erwähnen, oder?
Aber wir sind Nerds und wir sind nie glücklich. Wir wollen auch gar nicht glücklich sein.
Tim sieht auch gerade extrem unglücklich aus.
So ist es doch, oder? Ich bin nicht unglücklich. Ich wundere mich nur, was hier knackt.
Also ich freue mich, dann bin ich leider kein Nerd, weil ich freue mich immer drüber, dass es noch...
Guck mal hier auf deine Themenliste...
.dass ich die Möglichkeit habe, das noch ein bisschen zu verbessern.
Das ist langweilig, 3 Stunden über ein 10-Tage altes Update zu quatschen.
Das stimmt, aber wir haben jetzt so lange nichts geredet.
Über iPhones?
Gut, Themenliste, naja, wir haben hier auf jeden Fall...
Gibt es denn sonst Update, war durch oder war es da noch was anderes?
Ich habe nur, naja, ich könnte jetzt noch, ich hatte noch vergessen, bei dem Podcasting-Support noch darauf hinzuweisen, dass man ja auch für die Podcast, die man schon abonniert hat, wenn man sozusagen out of Episodes ist, dann wird ja unten auch noch angezeigt, weitere Episoden. Und dann springt er von der iPod-Applikation in die iTunes-Applikation und zeigt dir dann eben an. Das heißt, er matcht tatsächlich auch von den Podcasts, die du drauf hast, auf den Podcast im Store. Es ist nicht nur so, dass du im Store suchen kannst, dir was raussuchen kannst, sondern er nimmt wirklich die URL, matcht das zurück, vermute mal, dass er die Feed-URL nimmt an der Stelle und zeigt dir dann eben an, was sonst noch da ist. Und dann kannst du das eben dazu laden. Das ist schon fein, aber du musst dich jetzt nicht weiter vertiefen.
Was ich aber nochmal erwähnenswertes Phänomen finde, ist, wenn ich das auch schon aufgefallen habe, wenn man ein Update durchgeführt hat auf das neueste Betriebssystem, ist das SMS-Programm immer total schnell. Man klickt auf SMS und puh, sofort ist das SMS-Programm da. Und wenn man dann erst mal drei Wochen das Programm laufen hat, oder eine Woche oder ein paar Tage, dann wird das SMS-Programm immer unglaublich langsam.
Die Liste wird immer voller und muss halt deine...
Nee, ich meine einfach nur, bis das SMS-Programm läuft, startet. Und ich meine, ich hab ein Update durchgeführt, da ist keine SMS dazugekommen. Das war ja nicht so, als ob da keine SMS drin gespeichert wären, sondern es ist einfach...
Ach so, weil die SMS-Datenbank so groß ist, meinst du?
Das wär jetzt meine Vermutung gewesen, aber das scheint ja nicht der Fall zu sein.
Aber ich hab da auch irgendwie bei mir inzwischen SMS seit September, ich hab seit September nicht mehr gelöscht, weil mein Telefon ist jetzt auch nicht mehr jailbroken, es ist jetzt nur noch unlogged, ich hab keinen Bock mehr auf jailbroken. Ich will das in so einem Clean State haben und ich hab da irgendwie SMS seit September drin oder Ende August sogar. Und es ist schon ganz schön ordentlich was, was da so zusammenkommt.
Ja, was ich ja ganz toll finde, sind ja diese ganzen Applikationen, die so rauskommen, um komplexe Webseiten einfacher bedienen zu können. Also neben den ganzen Social Networking Sites, das weiß man ja schon, die benutze ich aber nicht so häufig, gibt es zum Beispiel eine eBay-Applikation. Naja, die ist etwas absurd übersetzt, also ein bisschen lustig. Zum Beispiel die Sachen, die du beobachtest, die sind hinter einem Button versteckt, der heißt Beobacht.
Hat nicht mehr gereicht.
Da hat er vielleicht mal...
Unterbrechen?
Unterbrechen und eine Lanze für einen kleinen lokalen Entwickler, mit dem ich zufälligerweise ein bisschen befreundet bin, erbrechen. Werbung, da gibt es das kostenlose Programm, das heißt Garage by Mobile oder sowas, das ist von einem alten Schulkumpel von mir, beziehungsweise von dessen Firma.
War der auch bei dem Coahats?
Weiß ich nicht, kann sein. Also auf jeden Fall... Ilyai, was heißt der? Kannst du sagen. Die haben als erstes, bevor es überhaupt von Ebay eine offizielle Applikation gab, haben die das gemacht, dass es eine iPhone-Applikation für Deutschland gab. Und die ist auch viel iphoneiger als diese Ebay-Variante, weil die Ebay-Variante die ist ja wirklich mal... die sieht ja mal total scheiße aus. Und das ist so ein richtig schickes Coco-Programm mit einem Pipapo und funktioniert voll super. Und ich kauf ja nie was bei Ebay, aber... Ich glaub, das ist... also den kleinen Entwicklern mal den bösen Kapitalisten gegenüber ein bisschen eine Chance geben.
Schön finde ich ja, dass Ebay überhaupt andere Applikationen zulässt. Amazon ist jetzt vor zwei Tagen... Was?
Und zwar bei dem Cocoa-Adressen, da meint auch einer, er hat eine Ebay-Applikation. Und seitdem die offizielle Ebay-Applikation draußen ist, schieben sie Updates. Also ihr Programm wurde nicht verboten, aber immer wenn sie jetzt Updates hochschieben, dann kommt Apple zurück mit, ja, der Button gefällt uns noch nicht, hier ist irgendwie was nicht ok, also Fehler, wo sie sich vorher nie beschwert haben und jetzt plötzlich, also ziehen sie das in die Länge. Also das dauert alles, dann muss wieder eine Woche warten und so. Also es ist so, die sind auf so einer Honigspur gelandet.
Du meinst, keiner hat bisher ein Update raushauen können?
Na doch schon, aber sie werden halt ausgebremst, das macht keinen Spaß mehr. Manche hat langsam keinen Bock mehr.
Und man ist wirklich, dass es damit ursächlich zu tun hat?
Es sind so Kleinigkeiten, wie der Button ist nicht richtig schön. Also so offensichtlich komische Sachen.
Schikane. Ja, bei Amazon geht es ja noch weiter. Also es kam letzte Woche eine Applikation, nicht noch Maso oder so hieß sie, die halt so ein Amazon-Frontend ist. Und bei Amazon gibt es ja auch schon seit Jahr und Tag eine API und es gibt ja tonnenweise Tools und alternative Stores und so soll das ja auch sein. Und die Lizenzvereinbarungen allerdings dieser API sehen vor, dass im Falle der Anwendung, wenn sie auf einem mobilen Device läuft, dass dann eine Einverständniserklärung von Amazon vorliegen muss, die diese nicht hatten. Und deswegen wurde diese Applikation von Amazon sozusagen zurückgepfiffen. Also nicht von Apple, sondern von Amazon. Und zu dem Zeitpunkt gab es auch noch gar keine Applikation von Amazon, aber die haben sie jetzt vorgestern nachgereicht. Konnte ich aber noch nicht testen, weil die gibt es nur im USA-Store.
Hat aber auf jeden Fall ein lustiges Feature.
Finde ich aber cool. Also Shopping ist einfach geil. Also auch so mit diesem eBay-Ding.
Ja, aber dass dann irgendwelche unabhängigen Programme zurückgepfiffen werden.
Ja, das finde ich auch schade. Das muss ich auch sagen, verstehe ich nicht so recht, dass Mark damit zu tun haben, dass sie sich davon richtig viel versprechen, dieses Outlet zu kontrollieren. Also das, anders kann ich mir das nicht erklären.
Weil jetzt so mit den neuen Podcast-Features, wäre dieses alte Podcast-Tool, was sie da verboten haben, wäre doch verschwunden mit so einer Integration. Deswegen wundert es mich, dass sie das überhaupt machen. Das hat doch mehr schlechte Presse eingehandelt als alles andere.
Jetzt bist du wieder bei Apple, ne? Ich rede ja jetzt von Amazon, Third Party und eBay und so.
Genau, da genau das gleiche. Die haben doch was davon am Ende.
Naja, die Diskussion hatten wir schon, User-Confusion und so weiter, wie auch immer. Also die eBay-Applikation finde ich jetzt auch nicht so golden. Die ist so ganz okay, um einen Überblick zu behalten, um mal eben schnell mitzubieten, das ist prima. So richtig tolle Sachen kann man nicht machen. Weiß irgendwie nicht, dass du selber der Owner bist, wenn du was verkaufst und so. Kannst also nicht groß herumeditieren, aber maybe they're getting there. Diese Amazon-Applikation hat ja noch ein anderes nettes Feature, was sie da eingebaut haben. Wie nennen sie das? Amazon Remember oder so, ne?
Den meinten die. Ja, irgendwie so was.
Remember. Du kannst halt Fotos machen von irgendwas, was du gerne haben wollen würdest, was du irgendwo gesehen hast und du hättest das gerne auch. Und dann lädt diese Applikation das zu Amazon hoch. Und Amazon stellt das dann in ihre Mechanical Turk-Geschichte automatisch ein und sagt, für 10 Cent oder so kannst du hier rausfinden, was das für ein Produkt ist. Das heißt, Leute werden dafür bezahlt, dass sie diese Fotos nehmen und dafür quasi die Produktlinks in Amazon rausfinden. Nicht viel Geld, aber so, keine Ahnung. Das ist halt so Mikroökonomie. Das funktioniert zu manchen Sachen in der Turk.
Das finde ich eigentlich ganz großartig.
Das ist eine coole Sache eigentlich.
Das dauert wohl noch ewig bisher.
Was dauert ewig?
Wir haben noch beim FSDK-Log das gecheckt und es hat 40 Minuten gedauert, bis eine Antwort kam.
Achso, jetzt mit dieser Amazon-Applikation?
Ja, mit dem Bild.
Aber 40 Minuten ist jetzt ja nicht so lang.
Du willst ja aber spontan kaufen manchmal.
Naja, du legst das dann in deinen Account und dann kommst du beim Einloggen. Ach, übrigens, du wolltest doch irgendwie das und das kaufen, Strandkorb. Also 40 Minuten find ich schon fix. Außerdem ist das ja erstmal der Anfang. Ich find ja zwar 10 Cent nicht so schnell, aber es gibt bestimmt Leute, die kennen wahrscheinlich die Amazon-Produktkatalog komplett auswendig und finden das auch schnell.
Ich hab mich kurz vor die Bilder davor gesetzt. Ich halte das ja so ein bisschen für die Zukunft der Arbeit. Dass es eher so in die Richtung gehen wird, dass es ein bisschen arbeitender wird, spielerischer werden. Und abends die Teenager, bevor die abends losgehen ins Kino, müssen sich erstmal die 800 Euro, die so ein Kino-Ticket normalerweise kostet, an Kino Mittwoch verdienen. In dem sen zum Beispiel bei McKennick The Turk reingehen und dann das Geld live verdienen. Das wird wahrscheinlich auch auf der Playstation gehen. Genau, beim Gucken kann man es abarbeiten. Auf jeden Fall hab ich auch kurz davor gesetzt, da sind natürlich Sachen dabei, Produkte, da hast du keine Chance, sie zu erkennen. Das sind irgendwelche T-Shirts oder irgendwelche Boxen von irgendeinem Hersteller.
Aber irgendwer kann halt.
Ja, aber die Hälfte der Produkte sind auch einfach MacBook Pros. Und wenn ich dann einfach nur drei Links auf MacBook Pros lege und dann jeweils pro Klick 10 Cent, MacBook Pro 15 Zoll, MacBook 13 Zoll, Mac Mini und es ist wirklich, irgendwo beim FSCK-Log war der Link drin zu den Produkten. Das ist ein Viertel der Produkte sind MacBooks.
Du wirst nicht fotografieren, sondern wollen wissen, was es ist, kann ich sagen, oder?
Ich nehme an, das wird einfach sein. Hey, das probiere ich mal aus, mal gucken, ob es funktioniert.
Also er sitzt gerade vor, dann nehme ich doch gleich das.
Ja klar, natürlich. Abwarten.
Dann muss man mal gucken, wie sich das entwickelt. Das ist auf jeden Fall nicht so uninteressant. Und ich meine, es gibt eine Menge Leute, auch Schüler zum Beispiel, wobei die wahrscheinlich mehr so in einer dritten Welt in Indien oder irgendwie so sich das machen lassen. Keine Ahnung. Aber ich meine, auch hier in Deutschland sind eine Menge Schüler unterwegs, die schon ein bisschen Zeit haben. Und zwar immer dann alle Leute, die viel in der Bahn unterwegs sind. Und die könnten ja schon, weiß nicht, eine halbe Stunde fährst.
Das muss ja nicht ein schlecht bezahltes Job sein. Das hat ja, Gott, jetzt hab ich einen Namen vergessen.
Timo?
Timo, genau. Hat ja irgendwie dafür ein bisschen Geld ausgegeben, dass seine Hörer die ganze Sendung transkribieren. So für vier Minuten kriegt man immer ein paar Euro oder ein paar Cent. Finde ich eine ganz hübsche Idee eigentlich.
Ja, das sind genau diese Arbeiten, die sonst einfach, die man einzelnen Leuten gar nicht... Ja, und die man auch ganz gut verteilen kann vor allem.
Genau, das ist eigentlich eine wirklich tolle Sache und ich finde das eine hübsche Idee und da sollte es mehr von geben.
Das ist ja geil, was man da alles so ausschreiben kann.
Man könnte so einen geilen Mobile Macs Podcast machen, wo ich nicht... Ich könnte jemanden engagieren, der für mich dazwischen quatscht, zum Beispiel.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich da viel Geld investieren wollen würde. So, du willst ein iPhone 3G haben, ne? Du weißt, dass du das jetzt auch in Deutschland so richtig irgendwie online klicken kannst?
Theoretisch, wenn ich...
Also mit ohne Vertrag?
Mit ohne Vertrag. Simio hat sich einen Kooperationspartner rausgesucht, oder?
Wer da ihr Partner ist, habe ich keine Ahnung. Auf jeden Fall verkaufen sie die Dinger.
Na ja, man geht da.
Also ich meine, der Vertrag ist ja weiter ein Partner.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass die Dinger da sind.
Das sind graue Importer.
Stimmt, das war das.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die so grau sind. Die müssen ja jetzt auch Gewährleistungen machen.
Nee, da stand da, dass sie ganz offiziell mit Apple abgeschmast sind. Die haben da so einen, wie sagt man, einen Disclaimer unten drunter. Das steht da, das sind mit dem Einverständnis von Apple irgendwie verkauft werden in Deutschland.
Jetzt haben sie sogar mal wieder eins.
Die wurden auch in Deutschland von Apple gekauft.
Also das ist der, der, der...
Neulich hatten sie keine mehr, jetzt haben sie wieder welche.
Jetzt haben sie wieder welche. Die Geräte sind mit Zustimmung...
Genau, ich zitiere mal hier. Zu ihrer Sicherheit, die Geräte sind mit Zustimmung von Apple in den europäischen Wirtschaftsraum gebracht worden und dürfen somit im gesamten europäischen Wirtschaftsraum unvertragt legal vertrieben werden.
Mit anderen Worten, das sind tschechische oder italienische.
Na, das sind Apple-Geräte.
Ja, aber sie sind mit Zustimmung in den europäischen Wirtschaftsraum.
Das heißt, sie sind... Na, aber wo sollen sie denn hergebracht worden sein?
Na, aus China nach Tschechien oder nach Italien. Na, wo sie produziert worden sind. Sie sind von der Produktion mit der Einstellung von Apple nach Europa in den europäischen Wirtschaftsraum gebracht worden.
Europäischen Wirtschaftsraum gebracht? Wie klingt denn das? Ich meine, heißt das, dass Apple es ihnen verkauft?
Nee.
Sondern wer?
Oder von Tschechien. Die gehen, die werden...
Ja, aber da ist kein Gewinn drin bei den Preisen.
Die kosten hunderte mehr als...
Die kosten genau das gleiche wie in Italien.
Ja, aber mehr als in Tschechien. Also in Tschechien kostet die 16 GB Version knapp 550 Euro. Und ich kenn die Preise relativ gut.
550 Euro?
Ich hab noch keins, weil ich... Und ich guck mich ja... Ich bin ja seit Ewigkeiten...
Aber wenn sie in Tschechien herhaben, dann waren die schon im europäischen Wirtschaftsraum.
Genau, die sind mit Zustimmungs-Apple in den Wirtschaftsraum gebracht worden, nämlich nach Tschechien. Und sind da von da aus grau importiert worden. Das heißt, man macht sich nicht schlafer? Absolut egal.
Ach so, verstehe, was du das meinst. Ja, das kann... Na ja.
Glaub ich nicht. Die verkaufen dann nicht so viele. Die müssten ja schon locker ein paar tausend Stück haben, sonst bräuchten sie die Anzeige gar nicht schalten. Und...
Ist ja egal, wo sie herkommen.
Die werden das im großen Stil. Das wird...
Auf jeden Fall. Wer für wen es bisher ein Problem war, iPhone zu haben, weil vertragsgebunden, weil SimLog, wie das ja bei mir auch ist, und der aber jetzt sich nicht scheut, so einen, wie soll ich sagen, so einen Vollpreis zu bezahlen.
In dem Fall sogar ein Premium.
Der kann das unter anderem bei Simeo tun. Was ich wirklich interessant finde, dass die...
Retail Keyshop heißt der Laden. Ich glaube, die haben eine Co-op gemacht, um ein bisschen Aufmerksamkeit zu erregen. Und vielleicht auch, um Druck auf Apple auszuüben.
Genau, retailkeyshop.com.
Das Schöne ist, dass natürlich dann auch bei eBay die Preise der aus Italien importierten Telefone oder überhaupt von wo auch immer runtergehen.
Vielleicht sollte ich meins verkaufen und mir hier nochmal ein neues kaufen.
Du hast jetzt einen Telekom-Vertrag, ja? Du kannst schon was für Italien, ne?
Ich hab ein italienisches, aber halt so mit Italien-Garantie.
Das heißt, wenn dein Kaputt geht, müsstest du es nach Italien zurückbringen?
Keine Ahnung, wahrscheinlich.
Die Garantie gilt immer nur im Verkaufsland. Also in dem es offiziell verkauft wurde. Die Apple-Garantie.
Was steht da?
Apple-Geräte sind sonst weltweit.
Nein, Apple-Port, eigentlich mobile Geräte, oder? Laptops.
Ja, was ist denn ein iPhone? Nein, alles nicht. Mobile Geräte.
Also war es auf jeden Fall so.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es Schweinerei ist.
Wenn du in Amerika einen Mac Pro kaufst, dann kannst du den hier nicht abgeben. Dann sagen die, der ist aber nicht von hier.
Aber dass ich für mein Telefon keine Garantie haben soll, wenn es in Belgien durch Zufall kaputt geht.
Aber ich hab da noch interessante Sachen gehört. Und zwar, dass jetzt Leute, die, sagen wir mal, in Belgien irgendwie sich so ein Unlockedes gekauft haben, also ganz offiziell unlocked, und die dann die 2.2 hier in Deutschland installiert haben, dass dann der Unlock weg war.
Das soll wohl gelegentlich auftreten und bei weitem nicht bei allen.
Das ist aber trotzdem schon ganz schön blöd.
Ja, das ist nicht das erste Mal passiert.
Das ist ein komischer Vorgang, wenn man da zuschaut, was das Ding so macht.
Das kann man nicht haben, sondern die Restort haben. Kann das sein?
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Also wirklich ganz frisch anfangen und dann machst du es nicht mit einem belgischen System und dann kommt halt der Checker da irgendwie durcheinander.
Keine Ahnung. Auf jeden Fall, das ist der Upgrade-Prozess, da kommen so allerlei Sachen. Da dachte ich bestimmt auch immer, das Telefon sei jetzt gelockt und dann bootet er nochmal und dann meint er, jetzt bin ich wieder geunlockt. Also da macht schon irgendwas. Ich schätze mal, dass der wirklich die E-Mail nimmt und wirklich guckt, ist das jetzt ein Gerät, was frei ist oder nicht.
Mit anderen Worten, mein selbst angelocktes iPhone ist leichter aktualisierbar als dein offiziell geunlocktes iPhone. Weil bei mir so ein Software-Update draufgespielt war weiterhin geunlockt.
Das war bei mir auch so. Nur während er das tat, gab das Gerät so alle möglichen Meldungen von sich und man sitzt schon so ein bisschen daneben, leicht Däumchen drehen.
Aber inzwischen gibt es jetzt einen Progress Bar beim Firmware-Update.
Ja, es wird alles besser.
Ich hab ja auch schon in den Zustand gehangen, dass mir mehrfach gesagt wurde, dass ich mein Gerät bei Apple einschicken sollte und dass ich das jetzt wegschmeißen könnte.
Das hatte ich ja bei meinem auch schon hier.
Aber bei drei Stunden. Wir sind schon wieder in der ganz so langen Silvere noch nicht unterwegs, aber zweieinhalb haben wir auf jeden Fall hier schon locker vollgebracht.
Das ist so nichts. Dann lasst uns doch mal.
Wir haben ja jetzt auch so lange nichts erzählt.
Was als nächstes iPhone kommen wird, ich meine im halben Jahr kommt es.
Glaskugel?
Ein bisschen, nur ganz schnell. Ich glaube, dass es mehr speichert, da bin ich mir ziemlich sicher, weil das können die locker machen, ohne irgendwie doll was zu ändern. Dann kann man zum Beispiel größere PDFs irgendwie...
Da sollen jetzt auch die doppelte Kapazitätschips vorliegen, die demnächst...
Ich habe ja dieses Texta-Tool seit heute im Store übrigens. Ach echt? Und da haben wir vorhin mal 28 MB... Nein, da haben wir 28 MB PDF geöffnet und dann hat gleich das iPhone gebootet.
Ach du meinst mehr Arbeitsspeicher?
Nicht mehr vielleicht 16 oder 18. Klar, da wird auch irgendwie 32 kommen, aber dann hast du halt mehr Platz. Aber ich meine von der Power des Telefons, und da ist ja der Arbeitsspeicher wichtig, das sind bisher nur 128 MB. Und laut Apple Tech Talk soll man ja so bis 32 MB für sein Programm benutzen, also ein Viertel davon. Und ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass mit der nächsten Version auf jeden Fall der Arbeitsspeicher hochgeht auf 256 MB. Und dass die CPU auch schon noch ein bisschen schneller wird.
Also ich glaube, das wird also mehr Flash-Speicher, klar, das wird irgendwie nach Weihnachten kommen. Flash sowieso, aber auch Arbeitsspeicher mehr. Ich glaube, das wird größtens mit der nächsten Generation kaufen.
Ist doch dann die nächste Generation?
Also mit dem nächsten Main, mit der nächsten Hauptneuen Version.
Davon reden wir doch.
Also quasi fürs iPhone 4, G4.
Dennis möchte wissen, was das nächste Upgrade ist. Das wird nicht 4G heißen.
Das nächste Hardware-Upgrade, was diesen Sommer kommen wird als iPhone 3G Plus.
Wir werden jetzt jedes Jahr ein neues iPhone sehen.
Weil der Markt ist heiß, da musst du mithalten, sonst bist du am Arsch. So ist das, oder?
Na, sie halten ja mit.
Wie viele Telefone hat Rim jetzt rausgebracht, seitdem das iPhone irgendwie da ist?
Und wie viele sind davon toll?
Also da kommt auch alle drei Monate Neuheit.
Ich war ja davon zuerst ganz angetan, ich hab immer noch keins in den Händen gehalten, aber jede Kritik, die ich bisher gehört habe, war vernichtend.
Ja, da gibt's eine Sache.
Die haben von Apple bezahlt.
Die haben keinen WLAN.
Die haben keinen WLAN, die Software soll so buggy ohne Ende sein, okay, das ist was, was man lösen kann.
iPhone Killer, iPhone Killer. Nokia hat jetzt auch einen iPhone Killer. Buchstabe, irgendeine Zahl.
Hat das WLAN?
Ja, es hat alles. N97 heißt es, glaube ich.
Das N97 hat WLAN? Stimmt, die haben ja immer WLAN.
Das hat alles.
Was jetzt?
Die haben immer alles, aber du kannst nie was irgendwie benutzen, weil es ist...
Lass mal bei der Glaskugel bleiben.
Ja.
Also mehr Arbeitsspeicher.
Was braucht man wirklich? Ich will mehr Akku. Ich will, dass das Ding länger hält.
Kann sein.
Auch wenn es sich in meinem täglichen Lebensgewandel noch nicht so als ein großes Problem herausgestellt hat, aber es liegt daran, dass ich immer ziemlich in der Nähe bin von irgendwelchen iPod-Kabeln. Aber ich finde auch, der Stromverbrauch ist runtergegangen. Also gerade wenn ich jetzt auch so Games daddel und so, da war normalerweise...
Es gibt aber auch viele Berichte, dass mit dem 2-2-App jetzt schlechter geworden ist.
Das ist nur so gefühlt.
Ja, es ist auch wirklich schwierig einzuschätzen.
Das ist wirklich schwierig zu sagen. Tja, was fehlt mir eigentlich?
Ich glaube, der einzige Faktor, der sich nicht so schnell ändern wird, ist die Auflösung. Ich weiß nicht wieso, aber ich hab so das Gefühl, das ist...
Also das Einzige, was ich hardwaretechnisch nicht gelungen finde, und übrigens auch softwaretechnisch, das ist dieser Knopf, mit dem man das Ding stumm schaltet. Weil beim Rausholen aus der Tasche, der steht so vor, komme ich immer mal wieder dran und also wenn ich das Ding nur irgendwie reluziere in irgendeiner Form, schaltet es sich stumm. Und was ich noch schlimmer finde, ist, dass auf dem Mainscreen nicht angezeigt wird, dass das Ding stumm geschaltet ist. Nur wenn du den Schalter umlegst, ist da kurz Glocke, eine Glocke aus. Aber danach gibt es kein Symbol, was dir sagt, dass dein Telefon nicht klingelt, wenn ein Anruf kommt.
Du meinst nicht den Power-Button, der den Anruf ja das Klingeln stumm schaltet für den Moment, in dem dein Anruf kommt, sondern du meinst den...
Den Ruhe-Schalter.
Genau, den Ruhe-Schalter. Ja, das stimmt, an den kommt man ein bisschen sehr leicht ran.
Erstens kommt man da leicht ran, weil er so an der Kante ist und zweitens siehst du, auch wenn das Telefon neben dir auf dem Tisch liegt, siehst du nicht, ob es gerade stumm geschaltet ist.
Ja, nur an dem roten Punkt an der Seite.
Ja, und da guckst du nicht hin. So, roter Punkt ist ja ein roter Punkt, seh ich jetzt mal.
Also mir fällt die leichte Vibration dann meistens doch auf, aber auch nicht immer.
Nicht in der Hosentasche, da fällt mir das nicht auf, da vibriert es eh.
Ich hatte gestern was, also meins macht ja leider nach und nach einen Abgang, habe ich die Befürchtung.
Ich hätte gerne die Headphone Jack. Und das wäre, das wird wahrscheinlich stattfinden, weil unten sind jetzt die Lautsprecher und das Mikrofon und die sind da wahrscheinlich, ja das wird wahrscheinlich stattfinden ich jetzt trotzdem gerne unten.
Das ist mir ehrlich gesagt, wieso?
Wieso, weil ich es einfach blöd finde, dass wenn ich das Ding in der Hand halte, dass da so ein Kabel von mir weggeht. Ich will nicht, dass da so ein Kabel nach vorne geht und dann wieder zurück, sondern das soll...
Das könnte man ganz einfach fixen.
Soll einfach nach unten gehen.
Du drehst einfach das um und das Display dreht sich mit, das würde gehen.
Das tut es ja leider nicht immer. Und der Home-Knopf geht ja auch nicht mit.
Genau, weil der Home-Knopf an der falschen Stelle ist. Aber bei meinem Programm geht das so.
Das kannst du gar auf den Kopf drehen. Ich glaube, wir machen mal eine Sondersendung zu deinem Programm.
Nee, das ist mir noch ein bisschen peinlich.
Dann möchte ich diesen Dreh-Axelerator ausschalten können.
Damit du im Bett surfen kannst. Das geht mir auch manchmal auf den Sack.
Das nervt mich nicht nur deswegen. Es gibt Programme, die diese Autorotation ausschalten können. Manche tun das.
Das muss man nicht ausschalten, sondern man muss es nicht einschalten.
Ach so, okay, gut. Wie auch immer. Autorotation nervt mich wie Sau. Das Schlimmste an Autorotation finde ich gar nicht mal so, dass das jetzt so reinkickt, wenn ich es nicht brauche. Das Schlimmste ist, dass zum Beispiel in der iPod-Applikation auch an vielen anderen Stellen sich das User-Interface total ändert. Also es ist nicht so, dass du dasselbe in Breit siehst, sondern du siehst auf einmal was komplett anderes. Und jetzt bin ich wieder bei einem Podcasting-Supporter, da ist es wieder so richtig dramatisch. Wenn ich mir die Liste von Podcasts anzeige und ich halte das Ding vertikal, sehe ich halt, naja, genau das eben, die Liste von Podcasts. Dann drehe ich das Ding quer.
Dann kommen wieder alle Alben der Songs.
Ja, dann ist jetzt diese ganze bekloppte Musik auf einmal wieder vor meiner Nase, ohne die Podcasts. Ich meine, durch die Podcasts durch scrollen, das würde mir ja glatt noch helfen. Das ist ja cool, wenn nicht durch die Cover Art von den Podcasts. Aber wieso kriege ich auf einmal einen komplett anderen View, nur weil das Ding quer liegt?
Dieses Coverflow in dem iPod ist ja wirklich nur dafür da, damit jemand, der noch nie ein iPhone gesehen hat, dass man dem das geben kann, sagen, guck mal, und das geht. Dann macht er einmal, oh, und das ist das exakt letzte Mal, dass man dieses Feature genutzt hat, oder? Das ist ein reines Demo-Feature. Das hat Steve Jobs gebraucht, um das Ding besser verkaufen zu können.
Du benutzt es auch in iTunes, nicht auf dem Rechner.
Es ist wirklich grauenhaft. Das stinkt. Apple, kommt mal klar. Also das ist wirklich, das geht nicht.
Es ist schick, aber es ist auch, weiß nicht.
Also was ich ja langsam, also ich vermisse, oder was heißt, was heißt, dass es keine MMS kann? Ich verschicke nie MMS, das stimmt schon, aber ich meine, man kann mittlerweile...
Klar, kannst du ja auch nicht, deswegen...
Ja, aber du kannst auch, man könnte bei der Bahn theoretisch Tickets kaufen, die man per MMS dann einlesen kann, die dann direkt von Display eingescannt werden. Es gibt mittlerweile relativ viele Gelegenheiten, bei denen einfach MMS doch so ein bisschen kommt und dass man da so komplett außen vor ist, finde ich auch ziemlich...
Und wer blockt das ab? Also ich meine, die Profiler...
Ich glaube, das hat einfach keine Priorität...
.gibt noch mit MMS ein bisschen Geld verdienen, die wären noch geil, wenn das iPhone das Feature hätte oder nicht. Die verdienen dann ja extra Kohle. Also eine MMS kostet einfach ein bisschen mehr als eine SMS oder nicht?
MMS, müssen wir überhaupt reden? Das ist doch tot.
Ist es? Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Ach, natürlich ist das tot. Das MMS...
Nee, es ist nicht tot, weil es gibt...
Es ist tot wie nix. Ich bitte dich, MMS gibt es schon.
Das heißt E-Mail. Ja, aber das kommt auch im Chat, bei der Bahn kann man auch per Mail-Tickets kaufen, die muss man aber ausdrucken. Die scanne ich nicht vom Bildschirm ein.
Er braucht in der Bahn MMS.
Ich brauche eine Bahn, wenn ich ein Ticket online kaufen will, und nichts gedrucktes haben will, und auch nicht irgendwie brauche ich MMS.
Wie, mit MMS kann man ein Bahnticket kaufen, das gilt?
Ja.
Was? Ja, es gibt ein Mobile Ticket von der Bahn. Das ist direkt von Display und Scanner.
Ach, das sind so ein Quadrat-Dings, Muster, Zeugs, ja.
Soll sie eine iPhone ab rausbringen dafür, verdammt.
Ja, aber so lange, aber ich bin einfach, als iPhone-User bin ich da ein wenig gehandicapt, obwohl ich das eigentlich am geilste Telefon der ganzen Welt habe.
Ja, aber stimmt, ich will gar keine MMS-Customs. Ob du will extra Geld, ich mach das wirklich mit.
Aber MMS ist wirklich eine Technologie, das ist dieses letzte Tolle aus dieser ganzen Wapp-Scheiße.
Ja, aber das ist doch wirklich, das geht doch gar nicht.
Das war aber fies, jetzt müsstest du unseren Hörern erklären, was Wapp ist.
Nein, unseren Hörern muss ich das nicht erklären. Die wissen, was das war.
Und Copy und Paste will ich endlich. Ja, es ist einfach unangenehm, wenn man irgendwo, man hat in Safari...
Genau, wo ist eigentlich hier, die haben doch gesagt, dass eventuell man jetzt irgendwie mal ein Netz per Bluetooth kriegt. Da ist auch noch nichts von zu sehen und zu hören.
Stimmt, von diesem berühmten, wie hieß der Mod? Ich kann mir den Namen nicht merken. Dieses, dass man sein iPhone quasi als externes Modem nutzen kann. Für den Mac. Das ist das ja, Tethering.
Ja.
Dass das gehen sollte.
Das sollte gehen.
Tethering, da steht's.
Irgendwie wird permanent behauptet von AT&T, dass sie das jetzt mal bald auch mal machen. Ich hab den Eindruck, für die Ankündigung alleine dürfte er wahrscheinlich schon...... Ja, der hat wahrscheinlich so eine Privat-Audienz in Steve Jobs eigenem Spanking-Room. Da kommen die ganzen CEOs rein, die Scheiße auf der Bühne erzählen oder auf irgendwelchen Pressekonferenzen.
Zu voll.
Dann so Bring Out the Gimp-mäßig kommt er erstmal in uns Leder- und Latex-Kostüme und wird eine halbe Stunde erstmal in die Truhe gesperrt.
Die Truhe?
Ja, die Truhe. Rein mit dem Zeo, noch so eine Kugel ins Maul, rein in die Truhe, halbe Stunde erstmal leicht vorkochen lassen.
The Gimp?
Und danach The Gimp. Dann wird er noch so ein bisschen irgendwie durch die Räume gezerrt. Irgendwann ist dann auch gut. Dann passiert das nämlich alle auch nicht zweimal. Ist das schon mal aufgefallen?
Nee klar, das sind ja dann auch arbeitslos.
Das ist ja eine andere Form, aber ich glaube, der macht die einfach trotzdem fertig. Steve Jobs Secrets Banking Room. Ja Mensch, ich glaube, alles andere. Ich hab jetzt noch so ein paar Sachen.
Also ich bin jetzt auch langsam durchgekocht.
Ja, wollen wir noch über irgendwas reden oder nicht?
Was hast du denn noch? Was ich gerne hätte...
Was hab ich noch? Du hör mal mit dem dazwischen quatschen, wenn ich gerade anfange, irgendwie eine Antwort zu geben.
Achso, ich dachte du sagst so da, als ob du lesen würdest.
Ja, vorlesen wollte ich jetzt gerade.
Ich dachte du würdest einfach gerade im Chat oder weißt ja doch was lesen.
Was wolltest du denn kreatives beitragen?
Wir haben ja theoretisch, ich weiß nicht, ob wir es noch schaffen vor Weihnachten noch eine Sendung und ob wir nicht so eine besinnliche... Und darauf wollte ich jetzt mal fragen, hat jemand eine Idee, was man in so einer besinnlichen Sendung machen könnte? Wo es mal nicht so um knallharte Fakten und News News News geht. Also Lagerfeuer-Knacken im Hintergrund vielleicht. Vielleicht gehen wir Eiskein jagen.
Was kommt jetzt? Wünscht ihr was oder was?
Ich weiß nicht, einfach einen Vorschlag, was wir machen könnten.
Zu Weihnachten.
Zur nächsten Sendung.
Wahrscheinlich sollen wir alle rote Mützen tragen während des Portgrats.
Das können wir immer behaupten, keine Fotos machen.
Genau, machen wir.
Jetzt hast du es gesagt, und jetzt müssen wir auch noch Mützen tragen. Und uns dabei fotografieren.
Mist, ich hätte mit rechnen können, es kommt, wir sollen singen.
Ja, es kommt voll knicken, Jungs.
Ja, das geht ja gar nicht. Das wollt ihr nicht wirklich.
Blümate trinken, das wär doch was.
Hier gibt es noch was Schönes. Muss man vielleicht nicht erwähnen. Habt ihr das mitbekommen? Der App Store ist jetzt Developern auch erlaubt, sogenannte Promotional Copies rauszugeben.
Zumindest in Amerika?
Ist das nur in den USA?
Bisher nur in den USA.
Sinnvoll. Sie bauen langsam die ganzen Sachen ein.
Lieber iPhone-Entwickler, ihr könnt uns eine Testversion zukommen lassen. Zwinker, Zwinker.
Ihr könnt ja eine von diesen qualifizierten Reviews geben lassen, die wer von uns bringt. Ich wollte dir eigentlich noch ein paar tolle Spiele vorstellen.
Das waren keine Spiele mehr. Du wolltest deine Liste vorlesen. Konzentriere dich mal ein bisschen.
Ja, Safari 3.2 haben wir hier noch. Schon alte Scheiße.
Ja, hat doch jeder.
Die Sache mit dem Fishing. Ich hab nicht so richtig geguckt. Wir haben uns nicht vorbereitet. Das machen wir zur Weihnachtssendung.
Dann gucken wir nochmal, wie das funktioniert.
Skip, skip, skip. Der Rest ist eigentlich auch langweilig. Flash und das iPhone.
Das machen wir jetzt offiziell in der Abendoptimierung. Mehr ist da auch nicht bekannt.
Es gibt ein Update von Stagehand. Das ist die Software, die ich vorhin erwähnt habe. Meine Liste ist jetzt... Songbird könnte man noch erwähnen. Songbird ist ein gutes letztes Thema.
So an iTunes genagelt. Ich weiß nicht, ob man irgendwie wegswitchen könnte. Also ich wäre froh, wenn ich wegswitchen könnte, weil iTunes kann mir eigentlich viel zu viel und bestimmte Sachen hätte ich gerne woanders hin.
Aber dann ist Songbird nicht dein Kandidat, glaube ich.
Naja, also ich finde ja gut, dass es das gibt.
Und sie singen...
Alternatives kann man echt nicht schlecht sein....
ist absolut, vor allem was Syncing betrifft. Es singt halt mit iPods. Zumindest noch. Es singt nicht mit iPhone und iPod Touch. Und ich glaube, das wird auch nicht passieren.
Synken würde mich gar nicht interessieren so. Aber ich habe halt große Musiklisten zu verwalten und zu taken dafür.
Hat denn der Songbird eigentlich einen ordentlichen Podcast-Support?
Podcast ist so Tims Thema. Da brauchst du nur sagen, dann ist es vorbei.
Natürlich ist das mein Thema.
Dann dauert die Sendung wieder eine Stunde.
Keine Sau, ich hab Podcast.
Da sollten wir mal eine Umfrage unter unseren Hörern machen.
Also ich höre irgendwie keine.
Nee, es gibt gar keine Podcast-Support hier. Na dann müssen wir das auch nicht besprechen. Songbird, das war's.
Ist ja erst mal eine 1-0.
Das war ja eine kurze. Die haben ganz schön lange gebraucht. Songbird ist vor drei Jahren angekündigt worden.
Ich hab's vor zwei Jahren oder vor einem. Nee, ist schon länger als ein Jahr. Habe ich mal getestet, 08 oder 07.
Aber jetzt geht's so.
Und das ist auch alles auf dieser Mozilla-Gix.
Das ist wie Firefox. Bloß mit Musik sozusagen.
Warum kann es nicht sein wie Camino mit Musik?
Weil es halt so ist wie Firefox. Firefox hat immerhin... Na ja, gut, du weißt wie das ist. Aber Firefox hat weiter Marktanteile sich geschnappt. Hast du diese letzten Marktanteile von Netzapplications mitbekommen? Firefox hat 20% Browser-Anteil. Safari geht auch am laufenden Meter hoch. Aber was noch viel interessanter ist, der Windows-Anteil im Web ist jetzt erstmals unter 90% und der Internet-Explorer-Anteil ist erstmals unter 70% gefahren.
Und der Macintosh ist in Richtung 9%, ne?
Richtig.
Not too shabby.
Insofern gibt es durchaus eine Chance, dass auch unser Podcast in Zukunft relevant bleibt.
Das ist ganz schön schnell gestiegen, die letzten zwei Jahre, oder? Ich meine, es war schon vor einer Weile noch bei 3%.
Im Web?
Nee, so grundsätzlich.
Grundsätzlich musst du immer fragen, wovon redest du? Marktanteil, Installed Base? Naja, das kannst du ja nicht vergleichen. Also im Web heißt ja auch, wie viel wird ein Computer genutzt?
8,7% oder was du jetzt da schon wieder abendest, das ist doch nicht im Web.
Nein, net applications bezieht seine Statistiken ausschließlich auf Aktivitäten im Web. Und von daher hat das nichts so zu tun mit Computerverkäufen und so weiter. Aber es sagt auch was darüber aus, wie häufig was benutzt wird. Das heißt, 10 hyperaktive Macintosh-Benutzer sind dann vielleicht in der Lage, 50 Windows-User einzufangen, weil Windows nur nicht unbedingt immer im Konsumerbereich, sondern eben auch in Büros wohnen, vielleicht nicht so viel gesurft wird oder so. Keine Ahnung. Es sind auch alles, also die absoluten Zahlen würde ich überhaupt nicht bewerten wollen. Die relativen Zahlen allerdings sind interessant. Also die Änderung von Monat zu Monat. Und das iPhone ist ja auch sehr sichtbar im Web.
Extrem. Nun ja.
Ich würde sagen...
Das war's?
Wir packen mal ein, ja, das ist auch genug jetzt. Aber wir machen noch was vor Weihnachten.
In zwei Wochen. Aber nicht nächste Woche, weil da ist halt Kokoheiz.
Genau.
Also jedenfalls an dem Donnerstag.
Wer Programmierer ist und Lust hat daran teilzunehmen, wir wollen jetzt nicht alle dahin jagen, die nicht wirklich hacken, aber so für Coda mag das dann interessant sein. Vielleicht sehen wir uns ja da. Und ansonsten sehen wir uns irgendwo anders. Und auf jeden Fall, wir können ja auch mal auf den Kongress hinweisen, das ist vielleicht auch mal ganz legitim, oder?
Stimmt, der findet ja auch so schon den Jahren statt.
Genau, der findet immer zwischen den Jahren statt. Wir reden vom Cars Communication Kongress, vom Cars Computer Club. Und der 25. steht vor der Tür, wie immer, in Berlin. BCC, Berliner Kongresscenter. Vom 27. bis zum 30. Dezember. Zu günstigen Tarifen und mit viel Spaß am Gerät. Ich hab nicht geguckt, Macintosh-spezifisches. Also die Jungs vom iPhone Dev Team sind vor Ort. Das könnte ganz interessant werden.
Weil, da gibt's ja...
Die jetzt Linux zum Laufen gebracht haben auf dem iPhone. Das haben wir ja noch gar nicht erwähnt.
Oh, lass uns noch kurz abbrennen.
So, da kann ich schön dagegenhalten.
Ich fand Johnnys Blogpost auf Spritblick ganz toll.
Der war nicht schlecht.
Ja, der war super. Hast du den gesehen?
Nee, aber ich stand auch letztens irgendwie bei Max Pfeffer.
Johnnys Kommentar war noch cooler. Er meinte, Linux jetzt auch auf meinem Taschenrechner mit so einem umgedrehten Taschenrechner wurde... Was hat er eingegeben?
27 oder so.
57 oder 27?
Und dann stand da halt LS.
So LS in diesem LCD-Display gesehen hast. Und irgendwie für künftige Versionen, das ist noch nicht alles implementiert, für künftige Versionen wurde Multiplikation und Tradition angekündigt. Wir sind fies, oder? Wir sind echt total fies. Die Jungs haben da richtig was geleistet. Das ist ja dasselbe Team, was auch die ganzen Unlocks macht. Und sie haben es halt tatsächlich geschafft, einen offenen Bootloader.
Das ist ja auch eigentlich so ganz schick. Es ist natürlich cool, wenn man so eine Hardware unter Kontrolle hat, aber es passiert dann halt nichts.
Ja, aber ich meine, es ist einfach ein Proof of Concept.
Es gibt Linux für ein iPad oder so, aber es gab auch Linux erst für iPad, als kein Schwein sich mehr für iPads interessierte. Also diese von Compact, diese kleinen Dinger. Und da passiert einfach nichts.
Naja, aber ich meine, das ist auch nicht iPhone. Das ist doch, weil es geht und das ist doch, da hat sich jemand hingesetzt und hat sich die Arbeit gemacht und freut sich jetzt, dass es bootet. Und damit hat sich der Salat.
Aber die Arbeit ist ja nicht darauf zu kriegen, sondern die Arbeit ist, dass das User-Interface geil funktioniert.
Ja, aber es ist natürlich ein schönes Interface. Ich meine, wenn du erst mal Ninos drauf hast, hast du sozusagen ein OS, mit dem du auch dann die Hardware besser exploren kannst.
Kann sein, ja.
Du musst dich halt nicht innerhalb von Davin iPhone OS mit seinen ganzen Beschränkungen da rumturnen, sondern du kannst halt in deinem bekannten Environment alle Hex zur Verfügung stellen. Dafür ist es halt cool. Also für einen Endanwender ist das natürlich keine Nachricht, aber ich glaube, für die iPhone-Hacker an sich ist es interessant.
Es ist schick, dass sie es können und ein bisschen, also wie gesagt, ich sehe es ein bisschen, wenn jemand in seinem Keller eine Modelleisenbahn baut, dann diskutiert auch niemand drüber, dass die ja nur im Kreis fahren kann und komplett schwachsinnig ist. Genau.
Ich freue mich auf jeden Fall, die Jungs mal kennenzulernen. Die waren ja auch schon auf dem Camp. Und jetzt sind sie auch auf dem Kongress und machen einen Vortrag darüber.
Haben die sich denn offiziell geoutet mittlerweile? Offensichtlich, ja.
Wie geoutet?
Ich dachte, diese iPhone-Dev-Team, dass die so mega geheim und keine Namen und gar nichts.
Ich hatte da...
Wer Pumpkin oder wer?
I don't know.
Ich hab's nicht hinterfragt. Ich weiß nur, dass sie irgendwie da sind. Ich glaube, sie sind auch nur als iPhone-Dev-Team virtuelle Personen angekündigt.
Ich sollte darauf hinweisen, hier, ich krieg grad hier einen Live-Bericht rein, hier über meinen rechten Kopfhörer. Das ist iPhone-Dev-Team am ersten Tag auf dem 25C3s und in Saal 1.
iPhone ist doch wichtig. Nein, finde ich nur gerade ganz lustig.
Man erkennt sie daran, dass sie einen Apple-Gerät in Saal 1 schafft.
Ich krieg grad noch einen Hinweis über mein anderes Ohr rein, und zwar, dass auf dem Kongress für alle Leute, die ein unlocktes Telefon haben, dass sie doch daran denken sollten, dass wenn sie iPhone benutzen, sie einen offenen SSH-Port mit Route und Standard-Passwörtern haben. Und das sollte man auf dem Kongress nicht machen. Wenn du dein iPhone anlockst mit dem Tool von dem Pornage oder Owned Tool von diesem Dev-Team, dann ist ja der automatischen SSH aktiv, offen, und der Route-User und der Mobile-User, die haben ja das Standard-Passwort Alpine, und Leute, die halt keine Ahnung haben, die ändern da halt nichts dran, und ich denke mal, die meisten werden es nicht ändern, und die rennen alle, also eigentlich alle anlockten Telefonnummer zum offenen Account rum.
Das ist wirklich keine gute Idee auf dem Kongress.
Nee, das ist übrigens nicht nur auf dem Kongress keine gute Idee, das ist generell keine Idee.
Auf anderen Veranstaltungen ist es theoretisch ein Problem, und auf dem Kongress ist es ein Problem.
Ja, aber auch im Sankt Oberholz.
Bist du sicher?
Also es ist kein Dauerzustand. Die haben doch eh keine Ahnung von SSH.
Ja, alles auf dem Kongress ist ein Problem. Ich meine, das ist wirklich schon ewig bekannt. Also jeder, der einen Zydea auf seinem Telefon hat, weil dann weiß das, dann sieht das Zydea oder den Installer von dem Dev-Team, der hat halt einen offenen SSH. Passwort ist root und User ist alpine. Ne, User ist root und Passwort ist alpine, könnte er auslösen.
Ich glaube, es ist nicht, wenn man das Quick-Pwnage-Tool benutzt hat. Ich glaube, da war kein SSH dabei, das muss ich noch nachinstallieren. Zylia SSH oder SSH?
Ich musste jetzt beim Zylia SSH nachinstallieren.
Kann sein, dass man das bei dem Quick-Pwnage irgendwie upgradieren muss.
Aber auch da gilt mindestens Passwort ändern, im Idealfall Passwort-Login abschalten und nur per Key und ich hoffe, dann ist es halbwegs sicher. Und wahrscheinlich sogar komplett abschalten.
Deswegen ist meinst du auch nicht mehr jailbroken, weil...
Wer so sagt, hat noch lange nicht fertig, aber ich würde sagen, wir leiten jetzt noch mal in die Ländefarbe ein. Wir haben fertig, oder? Ich denke auch, wir haben jetzt alles erzählt, wir haben ausgepackt. Jungs, Mädels, alle die jetzt zuhört, vielen Dank für das Zuhören. Das war mir eine längere Sendung, weil wir so lange Pause gemacht haben und es gab einiges nachzuholen. Und insofern...
Beim nächsten Mal singen wir nicht. Genau.
Wir singen nicht, aber vielleicht unter Umständen haben wir trotzdem rote Zipfelmützen auf.
Und trinken Kakao.
Warme.
Wir können ja uns mal in so eine Sendung reinsaufen, mal sehen, dass es besser wird.
Das ist super.
Das machen wir.
Über Glühwein sollten wir nachdenken.
Genau. Und dann alles klar.
Alle sonstigen Vorschläge wie immer und Kommentare zu dieser Sendung ab ins Blog damit. Wir lesen das und freuen uns auch über jede Rückmeldung bei Mobile Macs. Ich lese das. Natürlich lese ich das.
Du auch?
Das ist gut. Dennis, du auch, oder?
Bei Mobile Macs?
Sag mal ja.
Eigentlich immer ja, aber die letzte habe ich jetzt glaube ich nicht so gelesen. Aber sonst schon, ich bin ja mal dabei. Also Urlaub kann ich nicht gelesen haben. Da sieht man das ja.
Genau. Es steht doch erstmal kein Urlaub an und die Krankheitsphasen halten sich hoffentlich auch in Grenzen. Insofern, das wars. Tschüss.